foreign
[Music]
okay good morning members good morning
members of the public you're all very
welcome here this morning to baber
District council's planning committee of
the 10th of March
um members members of the public I think
it may be quite a long meeting so please
be patient with everyone and uh respect
everyone's points of views
may I first of all remind you of some of
the domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak kind of order
declare and or interest or request in a
German please use the hands up function
on the task button I've got to just get
that out to make sure I can see people
just bear with me
participants that's the one that I can
think of
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open
I.E other teams chats
or use the emojos and that if you're
contacted by a third-party Journal
application you should bring this to the
legal advisors attention
that if you're attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting that they must contact the
member Support Officer Mandy Smith and
you all have this phone number members
we will be using modern gov to conduct
all electronic foes during this meeting
I would just point out that if any
member it does fail to work at the
appropriate moment an officer will
contact you and we will ask for a verbal
vote but we're hoping that we will get
the electronic vote to work properly
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated feelings
the hold of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
accept items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consent and being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of these sound recordings
for webcast and and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
I'd like to introduce the officers who
are helping in running today's meeting
Mark Russell the area of plan and
manager strategic project and delivery
manager Stephen Stroud
Alex Scott the case offer for a later
case Linda bacon case officer for latest
case and Andy press the planning lawyer
and Robert Carmichael the governance
officer which is the first you will
often hear
um advising the throughout the meeting
right can I now move to the agenda
please and I just need to get my screen
um Can Can you all see me uh I can't
think why
that's right yeah I've got it now
apologies for absence
do we have any rubber
we have no apologies of absence for
today and no substitutions thank you
Jeff
oh thank you very much
but so we're all present
to receive any decorations of interests
um members do you have any are there any
to declare
no I can't see any hands going up
right then we'll move on to the next
item
which is item number three to the to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 18th of November
are there any points of accuracy please
all right can I now ask for a proposal
then this office oh okay uh counselor
Osborne
yeah thank you Mr chairman yeah I
propose this uh application thank you
there's your proposing the minutes of
the 18th yeah sorry yeah
uh do I have a sector um I'll second it
cancel it thank you very much
right it's been proposed no Robert are
we going through the electronic vote on
this we might as well have a practice or
shall I take it if there's no objections
we can take it as said
yep so um just to like that there is as
for the council motion
um in the first instance it would be
usual to go to the electronic vote you
can as chair
um decide which voting method to use as
per is your prerogative
since we've got it working I think we
should use it personally so I will take
your advice and follow the normal
procedure so members we will now go to
um modern gov dot uh do you want to run
us through it as we do it I think we all
know but yes yeah so if you go to the if
mems could please go to the modern.gov
app and on today's agenda and click the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
on there you will then see a list for
attendance and voting please click on
that and then the blue there will be a
light blue line highlighted please click
on that and the vote is in progress
believe we only have one the minutes of
the meeting held on the 18th of November
2020 be confirmed as a true record
that's in the blue bar and we could you
now click on that members and then
you've got four options four against
abstain conflict of interests so
please vote
thank you members that vote has now been
completed and was carried unanimously
now we press the close button don't we
so we don't lose the page is that
correct members right good
and then you go down to teams and we get
back to the game
right good we're getting there
just get this up
right we're now moved to item number
four members
oh that was Carriage you said wasn't it
yep uh item number four to confirm the
minutes of the meeting Herald on the
16th of December
are there any kinds of accuracy members
no hands are coming up
oh yes Adrian Osborne
uh you're muted no point of accuracy Mr
Jeremy it was just to propose the uh uh
minutes thank you thank you very much do
I have a second to cancel it yep
secondary thank you thank you
great then members are now asked um
Robert to conduct electronic vote
thank you chair if members could again
go to the modern.gov app and press the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
of today's agenda there you will see the
voting and attendance Tab and please
click on that and then on to the light
blue line for the item of pl-29
confirmation of the minutes held on the
16th of December and the votes is now in
progress thank you chair you may have to
scroll it down slightly so just bear
that in mind members
so there's the blue one
that go into that box and click on that
confirm
so
I don't think we've got that
thank you chair all the votes have now
been received and can confirm that it's
they are unanimously approved
and then go to close sorry episode
confirmed is the correct term apologies
chair
come on
right okay we've got that
item number five to receive
notifications petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
thank you
site inspections officers are there any
site inspection requests
Stephen
oh my
none that I'm aware of cheer thank you
members are there inside inspection
requests I know we can't actually do
them at the moment but uh I have to yeah
uh yes I think with regards to the third
application on today's agenda knowing
the area of cotville this is the
cotfield application I don't think we
can give it four
um
does this if we don't visit the area and
see the effect that I'll have on the um
the left surrounding Countryside and the
neighbors and I know we can't do site
visits at the moment but hopefully it's
only about a couple of months and then
we'll be able to go out
all being well
I'll ask the officers if they're getting
comments on that because uh it would
depend I think on how long
um it would um be before we could go on
the site inspection because of the time
restraints and planning applications but
uh can somebody help I see the legal
advisors present so you're you're not
you're still muted
my officer colleague if necessary
planning officer colleague could be
presenting this one but I mean it's on
the agenda today
um I think it I think it's going to be
it will be heard and if if the view of
the members is that this is necessary to
postpone for a site visit then that that
can be proposed and seconded if it's
supported and that can be the decision
um but I mean I don't think any of my
officer colleagues would have anything
different to say unless the case officer
needs to to come in now
um the case officer I think to be fair
the case officer may not be here because
he or she may not be expecting to be
here
if I made sure yeah I know Steve's
supporting today but he hasn't had any
involvement in this case it's been in
for quite a long time
um and I think if we say it might be
another couple of months until we can
have a look I think that's it's starting
to push it a little bit beyond what's
reasonable to be quite honest with you
chair and and also Frank and and of
course to State the obvious the
applicant couldn't make an appeal
against on determination if they so
chose I assume
if if unless they've agreed an extension
of time right thank you well you've
heard the advice given
um councilor Jameson
um what would you like to ask this
committee to do then
um well I personally I mean it's not the
members what they think but I I just
think the site visit will give us a
fairer
um understanding of the area and the
effect this this um Workshop Factory
building we'll have on the local area
but um yeah I mean it's down to members
really what yeah yeah I think members
have to take in consideration what the
officers
because they could
um go for a non-determination yeah um
members is there oh there's lots of
hands come up so I'll start from the top
councilor Ayers
counselor Ayers sorry I'm trying to mute
yes I would say that
um I'm sure there'll be lots of
photographs and things and it's not fair
on the people concerned to to delay it I
think we should go forward today all
right thank you councilor Barrett
thank you chair um I'd like to suggest
that if members uh want to take a visit
out they can they can go and visit the
area and make an assessment themselves
I I know the site quite well it's on the
main road there
um all right thank you counselor Adrian
I was born
please thank you Miss Gemma yes I
totally agree with uh Sue as cancer
series on this one
um I think the presentation will show
quite a lot of stuff but
will give us the determination of the
application so
um yeah I'm in agreement that we we
actually look at the presentation as as
the uh legal advisor has told us thank
you thank you councilor Jameson
um I'm coming back to you uh if you wish
to pursue this you'll need to make a
proposal and I'll see if we get a second
up
bearing in mind what you've heard
well it's I mean we can make the we can
make a proposal and see if there's a
second there I mean if um it sounds like
your proposal then please just very
clearly
sorry if I may come back in as legal
advice I think
um yeah I mean my advice would be that
we we that we come to the item and I
think we have to be mindful public
speakers and Ward members have been
invited to this meeting it would be
legally possible to to for councilor uh
Jameson to make a proposal now but I
think it would be wiser if we come to
the um if we we go ahead if then if the
view of the committee is we really ought
not to make a decision without a site
visit and that they'll the the members
are willing to take any risk like an
appeal against non-determination or or
or already you know complaints about
delay then fair enough that's a decision
to make at the time but I don't I don't
think I didn't I'm not I wasn't in tally
I don't know if counselor Jameson wants
to press the issue of a vote now as to
whether to postpone this item yeah no
we'll go as you say then take your
advice yeah thank you right so you're
going to leave until we get to the item
and then I'll come to you then so
um whether you still want to pursue the
um uh requests for site inspection okay
okay yeah yep thank you okay can I make
a point please yes councilor Busby well
I think it's an important point that we
do see these places I mean I I took a
trip out there yesterday to to get a
good view of it and have a walk around
and there's nothing to stop us doing
that I think we've got to accept that
we're not going to have site visits as a
group and therefore it's down to us as
individuals to take the responsibility
to get the feel as good as we can of the
site okay you won't get the uh the
officers talking through the application
but it's the the feel and the uh of the
site that's important and we can do that
on our own right thank you pint taken
right well we're going to move on
um item number seven scheduled of plan
and applications
um now you've all got uh in front of you
um
item 7A is Chilton wood mixed use
development and then north of Woodhall
Business Park Sudbury Suffolk I will now
invite the case officer Jasmine weymer
to why not to introduce the application
to the committee
uh perhaps your present the application
thank you chair and good morning members
I'll just share my screen with you
can everyone see my screen and my cursor
as well yes
yes and
on presenting a reserve matters
application for the children Woods
development today the application solely
relates to the first stages of
infrastructure to facilitate the
residential development of the site at a
later date
members are reminded that this
presentation should not be viewed or
understood in isolation and it
accompanies both the committee report
and information provided within the
tabled papers
officers have reflected on the wording
of paragraph 12.3 within the committee
report
for the avoidance of doubt we would not
wish to suggest that Energy Efficiency
and the need for carbon reduction is not
a material consideration we are fully
mindful of our own relevant policy cs13
and this council's declaration of a
climate emergency however Our advice has
to reflect the legal parameters within
which this Reserve matters application
has to be determined the outline
planning permission from 2018 does not
contain a conditioned constraining
choice of energy utilities and the and
so the extent to which this obviously
important consideration is applied is
constrained
as we have stated any future dwellings
on site will have to be built in
accordance with the most up-to-date
building regulations of the time and
further assessment of sustainability
will come in subsequent applications and
be subject to assessment by the
council's sustainability officer
outline planning permission as I've just
stated was granted in 2018 approving up
to 1 150 dwellings employment land a
primary school a preschool open space
Community Woodland Sports Pavilion
playing fields and the creation of
access points
the area outlined here shows the whole
Chilton Woods development as covered
under the outline permission
the site location plan submitted with
this application shall be shown in the
later slide which shows the exact
location of this Reserve matters
development but this is to just give you
a general gist of the whole site and the
whole development
thank you
here we have the land use parameter plan
which sets out different uses for
different Parcels of land as secured
under the outline permission condition
six on the outline permissions stated
that the development must be carried out
in accordance with the land use
parameter plan
as part of this access points were
established under the outline permission
one extends Aubry drive and another
created Long Reynolds Way in Acton Lane
which lead into the residential areas
another is approved into the employment
land however this area is outside of the
applicant's ownership and therefore
cannot be considered nor delivered at
this stage
the site Falls within four parishes
so that's Acton to the north Chilton to
the east subroot of the South and long
Melford to the West
there is a County wildlife site located
to the east of the site just here
the star just here also shows the
location of Woodhall moat which is a
scheduled Monument within Woodhall
Business Park
the main road running along the southern
and sort of Eastern side of the site is
the a134
work solely comprise of the spine Road
surface water drainage foul water
drainage site levels and Landscaping and
infrastructure associated with those
matters
that is all this Reserve matters
application is considering
whilst these provide the first stages of
infrastructure to facilitate the
dwellings there are no Reserve matters
under consideration here which directly
relate to the dwellings specifically
these will all be presented within
subsequent Reserve matters applications
many of the matters here are covered by
conditions on the outline planning
permission as well and full wording of
these conditions is detailed under
paragraph 2.2 of the committee report
the purpose of this application is to
provide a comprehensive and coherent
approach to development showing how all
these aspects interact with one another
rather than discharging them in
isolation
further applications will be made in the
future which will deliver further
landscaping and infrastructure
associated with residential development
as well as the details of the dwellings
this application to just reiterate is
solely for the first stages of the
infrastructure
cool strategy policy CS4 is the guiding
policy which sets out principles for
development on the chiltonwood site it
is important to note that the policy
outlines the direction of travel for the
whole site including matters that have
previously been agreed under the outline
permission in 2018.
the aspects currently being considered
under this Reserve matters application
are limited and therefore do not cover
each and every point of that policy
different objectives and criteria within
CS4
would be considered and delivered under
future Reserve matters applications if
they have not already been considered
under the outline
not all of the children's development
site has been acquired by Taylor wimpy
the Western employment land for example
is not under their control as I've
previously mentioned
as you can see the site location for the
infrastructure
um being considered under this Reserve
matters application is shown by the red
outline which makes up a small part of
the wider site
the only aspects at this stage of the
development that will be visible on site
once complete are shown on this site
layout plan these include the spine Road
Suds and the associated landscaping
around the suds
the Spy mode makes connections to the
agreed access points and Loops towards
the West providing a potential link to
the Western employment land if that was
to come forward in the future responding
to the wider Direction and
um policy for the site
the spine Road weaves around and
provides main connections to the parcels
of land that will be developed in later
stages
the site layout plan that you saw on the
previous slide has been overlaid on the
land use parameter plan to show how the
proposal Accords with that plan and thus
condition six of the outline
so you can see this is the site layout
plan and you've got the spine Road sort
of running through and how it links into
these potential Parcels in the future
the spine Road and studs have been
designed to respond to this land use
parameter plan to facilitate the
dwellings on site and other
infrastructures such as the primary
school on the distinct Parcels Parcels
of the land as shown
the connectivity proposed at this stage
is concentrated on the spine Road
active travel options are encouraged
through Crossings
um with a mixture of Crossings designed
for both pedestrians and cyclists there
are footpaths and shared footpath and
cycle Lanes proposed along the spine
Road as well as a dedicated cyclist and
pedestrian route along Acton Lane
however this main highways
infrastructure is subject to section 38
and section 278 agreements with Suffolk
County Council highways in order for
them to be adopted in the future
therefore whilst this strategy is
acceptable in principle from a highways
perspective some of the technical
specifications may be subject to change
in accordance with highways guidance
through the separate agreements required
outside of planning
further connectivity within the parcels
of land would be delivered in subsequent
Reserve matter certification this
application solely relates to the
connectivity arising from the creation
of the spine Road
this plan shows the levels over towards
the western side of the site the site is
relatively level with the highest points
to the North West
and the lowest points to the South
this shows the levels along the Eastern
side of the site so the spine road
across the whole site fits well within
the existing Contours of the land and is
relatively level with it
this plan shows the main connections
being made to manholes leading to
England water sewers
smaller Orange Lines out of the main
Spyro spine road so these sort of ones
over here and are indicative at this
stage and are subject to change if
needed in order to respond to
residential development in the future
the ones that are being confirmed under
this application are the ones sort of
running along the spine Road
angling water have confirmed that their
system will have capacity for the flows
being proposed
the individual technical Subs plans have
been overlaid over the site layout plan
to provide an overall view of their
location the associated landscaping for
the sods and their relationship with the
spine Road and Parcels of land
The Sod strategy is comprised of a
combination of swales and attenuation
basins soft Landscaping is incorporated
into this strategy with a mixture of
native planting Police Services
Landscaping confirmed that the overall
approach to the suds from a visual and
Landscape perspective is acceptable
Suffolk County Council floods and water
were also content with the location and
use of the suds as a strategy to deal
with surface water drainage
in summary this is a small part of the
larger development for Chilton Woods The
Reserve matters being considered under
this application are narrow and focused
on the first stages of infrastructure
infrastructure required for subsequent
stages of the development the only
matters and details for consideration at
this stage are the spine Road drainage
strategies levels and the associated
landscape landscaping and infrastructure
related to those matters
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the reserve matters in
accordance with the details set out
within the committee report thank you
for listening
thank you thank you very much Jasmine
um now before I go to the counselors I'm
going to ask the Stephen Strow the plan
an officer to just clarify what's
actually before us
and thank you chair um good morning
members
um yes I and and in fact there's not
there's not a lot I'm sure that arga uh
can add to what Jasmine has just
presented but I think um in a nutshell
members
um this is obviously a hugely important
application bearing in mind that in
principle this is a development that the
council has supported for uh decades
given its inclusion as a strategic
allocation
um but it is at its heart this
particular application a very simple one
um we have an outline planning
permission uh this is not an application
for planning permission this is an
application for reserved matters that is
consistent with that permission and what
it does is seek approval for a very
narrow set of considerations relating to
what is a fairly straightforward
um set of um operations and works uh
relating to that that spine Road and
related interest structure which is
effectively literally the spine that the
rest of the development the residential
development will connect to so I think
in that respect members and your focus
should be relatively narrow and and as
is set out in the reports I think the
only other thing I would add members I'm
mindful that over the next 20 minutes or
so you are going to hear a lot of
objections or concerns in respect of
this application and in all honesty I
think I would say that I share a lot of
the sentiments that are going to be
expressed however what you've got to
understand is that everything has to
come at its appropriate time and the
planning permission has been structured
in a very particular way and this
application does not offend that
structure or its
um phasing so what I'm saying members is
that this application if you approve it
today
diggers won't be on site in the
afternoon there are still a number of
things that the applicant as developer
needs to comply with not least
construction management plans which do
need to be submitted for determination
and approval by us
um and and that will follow pending the
outcome of this particular determination
today
thank you members thank you very much
for clarifying those points now I'm
going to go to members are there any
points that you would like clarified by
the case officer and what or what you've
just heard
I've got councilor Barrett
thank you chair um actually
um it's something that I I've just
realized I should declare
um having noticed the the exact boundary
um the adjacent to the uh southernmost
boundary is Woodhall Business Park and
um I and my husband have a business that
is located on that boundary
um which is a industrial unit although
it's it's rented so perhaps the legal
officer could advise yep I'll ask um
taking note of that I mean I don't think
it doesn't that does not sound to me
like a peculiar interesting given the
fact that Planning Commission has been
granted what this the precise nature of
this reserve the large outline
permission has been granted that given
the precise nature of this application I
don't think this adds up to a a
pecuniary interest
um for councilor Barrett and I think
it's she's out of perhaps an exercise
accessor not an excess of caution but
absolutely
um the usual good sense and that the
members that exercise
um
mindful of the benefit the doubt it's
been declared that's I'm quite happy
with that and it was interested
just in the interest of openness and
transparency really correct that will be
recorded your comments and again to
answer to you and you can carry on in
the meeting thank you uh I've got
counselor Jameson next
okay thank you
um I think I suspect some of the
objectives relate to the guess the
effect these herzies are going to be
supplied by guests now looking at the
drawings the guest pipelines seem to go
under the road that we are discussing
today
do we get to review those before the
building of the road starts
can you help Jasmine
yeah thank you
thank you and as we sort of touched on
right at the start of the the
presentation
and there is no condition on the outline
permission which restricts the the use
of gas
um whilst noting that it is you know
still an important consideration
um for applications going forward but
I'm not sure if Stephen might have
something further to sort of add on this
point
uh Stephen can you is there anything you
wish to add yeah yes of course I think
um it would be very difficult to Lodge
an objection within the parameters of
this particular application based on the
fact that there's a gas Governor shown
um and Associated
um uh low pressure piping
um the application of course
um when it was first submitted
seeking planning permission included a
utility statement that was very clear
that that gas was uh going to be part of
the proposal going forward and indeed as
Jasmine mentions there is no condition
that expressly controls
um or requires a developer to comply
with a particular utility strategy
um but that's not to say that at the
appropriate time when we come to
determine Reserve matters for the
dwellings we're not going to consider
their Energy Efficiency
um so uh you know gas in terms of its
use may or may not be relevant at that
stage but bearing in mind of course the
policy framework that we have to apply
as well there is nothing there that
expressly precludes the use of that gas
and of course the building regulations
still at this current time allow for it
so I think again just to focus
particularly on this application we've
got here there is nothing objectionable
in it in respect of the fact that it
shows a gas Governor that may or may not
supply one or more of the units to come
forward
so
um we can't decide I mean even though
the gas was agreed was it five years ago
when this was originally
approved that's it it's done deal then
basically in terms of the energy
well we still probably refill on that
when we're in due course
indeed and in the emerging plan there
are of course energy policies that will
need to be considered and are mindful
that you know the the literal
existential threat that we face in
respect of climate change is something
that's very serious and needs to be
factored into account but within the
parameters of this permission there is
nothing to say that you cannot have a
supply of gas to this development
thank you thank you very much any other
members want any questions to the case
officers
no I can't say any hands up thank you uh
Chancellor Barrett you want to come back
yes sorry yes thank you thank you
um can uh you show us slide 10 again
please Jasmine
um because I noticed on there there was
the the uh plan of the site the um spine
road but in the bottom left of that
slide there seemed to be a detail
and perhaps you might be able to explain
you just yes so where it says in set I
think oh here yes so basically just on
like um just on the scale of the plans
um this
part of the spine Road would not
physically fit on the plan if that makes
sense so it's
sort of leads continuation here okay
right and and is there any more detailed
um drawings of the actual Junctions of
uh you know the start point of that
spine Road showing where it it sort of
originates
um in terms of the the access points
they were established under the outline
permission
um so it's literally just how they
connect onto that
um there may be some further
um technical drawings on that but as I'm
sure you can appreciate as this is
infrastructure based these are very very
technical drawings which have been
reviewed by Suffolk County Council
highways
um and it sort of isn't
I suppose they're not you know to put
them in this presentation
um possibly wouldn't have been overly
helpful because as I say they are very
very technical drawings
um but I'm not sure if Stephen has sort
of anything to add further on that
um hello um no only to say that we do
actually have the benefits I believe of
um uh one of the officers from the
County Highway Authority who might be
able to explain uh how some of those
junctions have been arranged or will be
managed bearing in mind of course that
we still don't have any particular use
associated with this this spine Road
um but I'll leave that to I think Sam is
here is is Sam here I can't I'm sorry
I'm struggling with this technology to
see but I think she is I am I am here uh
Sam can you just introduce yourself
yes good morning counselor and everyone
Samantha Harvey Suffolk County Council
highways
please can you help can I just ask just
follow along from that the so you're
saying that the connection points where
the roads meet
um the existing uh main roads as we know
them they have already been decided in
the outline plan and
um consent is that correct
the locations have been agreed as as
Jasmine said through the uh outline
planning permission the details of the
accesses and all the the connections
into the existing Network have also been
looked at by myself and a colleague and
they are to specification
um I can probably find one if if
necessary
um in the meantime to show the actual
connection if that helps to uh
discussions further but they may they
will be checked and agreed under Section
38 and 278 of the highways act when we
do eventually adopt this road all right
thank you well if in the meantime you
can find that connection point if it
comes up later on in the discussions
um then just try and alert us and we'll
bring you into it
thank you thank you very much I think
councilor uh Hinton I saw your hand
Apple that's disappeared on my screen
but ah there you are thank you
thank you chairman and just just a quick
point and probably applicable that uh
the county highways officers there as
well uh reading in the report there are
three access points but only two of them
are actually shown in detail on these
proposals uh because the third one is
outside of the control of the developer
if he never gets control of that surely
we're approving something we're
improving the three-legged stool with
only two legs on it
good point uh Jasmine or the county
hospital
yeah and as councilor Hinton will
remember
um I'm fairly sure Council engine was on
the committee that
um dealt with the outline planning
application uh it was considered at the
time what might be the effect if the uh
Western half of the site being in the
employment land were to be following a
different trajectory of delivery to the
residential land and it was considered
an accepted and tested uh that the
residential land could make you solely
of those Eastern access points and not
the Western point and not lead to a
severe impact in Highway terms
thank you
right members there's no other John did
you want to come back yeah just quickly
could you come back up in May so in
actual fact what we're saying is that
the business areas
um access points will be straight away
through the middle of uh residential
areas purely because the third access
point that we insisted on initially
being required is not available
I'm I'm not sure how you can um make
that leap counselor hint and the the
employment land has its own uh access
point and is in separate ownership
uh I'm I'm I don't quite follow the the
question I mean it will have to uh
include its own phasing plan
um before development can commence on
that particular area of the site so if
it were for example to propose that it
would be built out in an East-West
Direction therefore putting more
pressure on those Eastern access points
I'm sure you would have an objection to
that and I think that would probably be
well founded
thank you right there's no other hand
sorry Mr chairman uh points of
clarification so carry on cancer finally
on that if I if I may yep uh but this
application that we got in front of us
talking about the description of the
development
talks about
uh 15 hectares of Employment Development
to include B1 B2 b8uses a hotel a
household waste recycling center a
district heating Network Energy Center
Village Center
etc etc etc uh if that's not going to
put pressure on that spine Road I'm not
quite sure what will unless of course uh
not any other vehicle is going to be
electric but they're also going to be
flying councilor Hinton those um those
items that you've just mentioned they
already have planning permission they
don't form part of this application the
employment land is on the western half
that's not being promoted or delivered
by this developer thank you right we
will move on uh are there any other
points of clarification from members
there's no hands up so I intend to press
on
right public speakers
um Robert can you
um make a comment please at this point
Robert Carmichael
sorry chair my I have some delay trying
to get the microphones working so
apologies so um just so that all members
and viewers are clear on how the public
speaking will work today so as we have a
cross boundary application for both
Wards and parishes all parishes in which
the application is located have been
invited to speak accepting great
boardingfield who have also requested to
speak and the chair has allowed
um as such each speaking slot will have
nine minutes and that will be three
minutes per Parish Council as we have
three
um and the other time has been divided
by how many speakers have registered in
the other slots the time is at nine
minutes per slot
um as detailed as the parish council
said there will be as we have two
objectives it will be four and a half
minutes each and the applicant will have
nine
um and so just to refer back that that
was as per your request that all points
should be fair that all speaking slots
should be the same just wanted to
clarify that thank you chair thank you
right that's fine
um right so we'll now move on to the
public speakers Parish councils first
and I will now asked Mr Nick antill of
Acton Parish Council to speak you sir
have three minutes to address the
committee which will be retained by the
governance officer when you're ready
um Mr antill
um it's over to you and it won't start
until you start so it's fine can't you
hear me yes I can hear you that's fine
now you can see you fun good morning the
planning officers report for this
application States and I quote the
design code is not a relevant
consideration but in fact the design
code a construction plan and a clearly
defined point of access for construction
vehicles on the site should have been
brought to this committee before not
after this application relating to
infrastructure throughout the months the
councilors have been engaging with
Taylor wimpy in their working group
representatives of the parishes have
repeatedly raised the question of how
the site is to be accessed during the
construction period at no point has
there been a clear response and a
request for meeting with the vapor
planning officers has been summarily
declined
if this committee approves this
application it's inviting a developer to
start on a project that is intended to
extend over more than a decade without
establishing how it is to be delivered
and how material is to be brought to the
site
this is exactly what has happened with
other recent developments in the area to
the serious detriment of residence
Chilton Woods is a massively bigger
undertaking and potentially far more
disruptive than any of these
this application should not have been
brought before this committee at this
time it is premature and on this basis
if it has to be considered at all should
be rejected
you the members of this committee will
lose control of the most important
development ever undertaken by baber if
crucial matters relating to construction
and access are left to be divided
decided privately between the developer
and baber officers
but it does not have to be that way it
is perfectly possible for the planning
committee itself to deal with discharge
of important conditions rather than
being dealt with by officers if you're
not willing to refuse or to defer
applical of this application then you
should resolve
to bring them to this committee where
they can be divided decided by elected
members of the council
I'll add one point in response to an
officer's comment earlier it is
certainly true that Suffolk County
Council highways agreed that the
existing access points would be adequate
for the residential section they didn't
say anything about it being adequate for
construction vehicles over a period of a
decade thank you
thank you very much Mr antill
um I'll see if there's any questions
from Members I've just got one I believe
you perhaps you can just keep your
camera on and your multi-con so we can
see and hear you sorry
um that you I think you said that you'd
requested a meeting with officers which
was refused or something I'd just like
to clarify that point to me yes
um in in the wake of this application
being put forward and at the time when
the it appeared that the final version
of the design code was to be booked to
um paper Council
um a group of parishes including Chilton
Acton and uh great wallingfield
requested a meeting with um baber
District Council officers and the reply
was that the officer did not see the
utility of this meeting at this time
right thank you thank you because I've
heard that I will be getting them to
comment on that in due course right
members any questions to
um Mr Angelo Parish Council
no
okay thank you very much I'll go to the
officer and ask the officer do you wish
to
um any clarification on what you've just
heard from Mr Andrew of Acton Parish
Council
um thank you chair I'm not really in a
position to comment on on every any
correspondence that's gone on between
officers in particular and and the
parishes mainly because I uh I I have
been on leave and I'm just catching up
with those emails
um but I'm mindful that the when we talk
about the utility of of a meeting or
dealing with the particular issues at
hand and to to quote Mr until the
crucial nature of the need to uh agree
and understand construction routing and
it's um Arrangements uh I agree entirely
but the point is uh the condition and
the planning permission has been
structured in a particular way and they
are pre-commencement matters there is
there is nothing here if members were to
determine this was a matters application
this morning that will mean that the
developer can simply have a free reign
and just go on site and construct it in
a manner that they see fit that's
absolutely not correct uh and I would
give assurances to Mr antill that we
will give you consideration to the
construction management plan that
absolutely is required as part and
parcel of the Planning Commission and it
is a pre-commencement requisite can you
also assure me that that those
conditions will be brought to the
planning committee rather than being
settled with officers
I think that would be a matter for
members to consider perhaps this morning
rather than for me
thank you uh
um legal yes I don't I don't I don't
think I need to animals I just put the
camera on in case I I agree with what Mr
Stroud has said but I I think I just
better make a quick point I think this
point has been made in correspondence
not by Mr stradler by the chief planning
officer that if um meetings frequently
take place of an informal nature between
um what say landowners and developers or
on the other side of the fence if I can
put it that way um
Civic societies Community groups that's
as long as people use their common sense
and observe a few safeguards that that's
part of the normal process but when a
matter has reached a stage of formal
decision making and near to a committee
meeting you you really do have to
although it's not against the electrical
law you have to start being careful and
saying well look you wouldn't be
impressive with meeting with Taylor
wimpier at this stage I'm afraid that
the principal operates the same way too
thank you yep I think you've clarified
those points thank you there's no other
hands up um
um Mr antille so uh thank you very much
I'm going to move on we now come to the
next um public speaker
which we now asked Lady heart and John
Steele of Chilton Parish Council to
speak you also have three minutes to
address the committee which I believe is
being shared between you
um but I won't interrupt you I'll allow
you one to start and the other one then
just takes over at the appropriate time
but you will be stopped after three
minutes thank you
um Mr chairman it's uh Valerie Hart um
no that's not good morning
um no Mr Steele is not speaking I'm
speaking and I'm speaking for three
minutes that that's absolutely fine your
time hasn't started so don't worry no no
obviously the information I've got isn't
um totally um up to date that's right so
that's fine John Steele is not um
speaking so now I will ask lady heart of
Chilton Parish Council to speak and you
madam have three minutes in which to
address the committee and afterwards
I'll see if there's any questions for
you thank you thank you good morning
members policy CS4 governs this site to
previously publicly owned land and the
largest residential site in Weber we
were promised an Exemplar development
but we're already concerned that that is
not the case with less Community
Woodland it may be known as Chilton
without the woods the same policy
provides that piecemeal development was
not acceptable but that's what's
happening your statement of community
involvement says parishes views are
important so we ask please take them
into account
all six parishes are clear that
fundamental issues such as the design
code the construction access
construction materials and mitigation
measures are important and these should
be dealt with before any other planning
applications this should be a
construction management plan for these
works but there isn't one your senior
environmental health officer advised
that such was a Paramount importance but
there isn't one why not
three of the parishes have reached an
awful experience of an inadequate
construction plan being approved between
the officers and the developer whereby a
new construction access was created a
noise vibration and dust pollution was
caused seriously disrupting residents
lives we want to avoid a repeat of that
the outline planning permission provided
only for four accesses everything else
is left over to reserve matters and all
and conditions construction works on
this site are going to take 20 years and
can blight residents lives rather than
the dischargeable conditions being dealt
with between officers and developers
privately they should be dealt with by
the planning committee so the parishes
and the public have a proper opportunity
to express opinions and for these to be
considered that's common practice on
sensitive sites
we the six parishes urge you either to
refer refuse permission today or to
adjourn this application to another date
for the reasons set out in our letter if
you're not minded to do this at the very
least we ask you to provide that in the
event that any two of these six affected
parishes requests that your committee
should deal with the dischargeable
condition it should be dealt with by
committee rather than by decision by an
officer on the gas generation I disagree
with your officers you don't need a
negative condition you've got a suite of
existing policies CS 13 cs14 and cs15
which provide that this a policy of a
gas generator installation contravenes
clearly those policies I would urge you
to look at those once the gas generator
is installed you can be no doubt the
Taylor wimpy will be using it thank you
I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much lady heart
um can I just clarify with you that the
letter you referred to is that the
letter I have in front of me of the 8th
of March 2021
um sent by Acton or signed by Acton
Parish Council Chilton Parish Council
great waldenfield Parish Council Lebanon
Parish Council little Walden field
Parish Council along Melford Parish
Council Ward members councilor Mabry and
kensler Nunn is that the one you're
referred thanks just so that members are
clear and they've had chance to find
that while I was talking to you yes
thank you we're good right I'll see if
there's any hands up for you now members
have you any um questions that you'd
like to put to Lady heart of that of her
children Parish Council
no okay thank you very much lady heart
there isn't any questions to you I'll
now move on
and uh asks for
counselor
Russian of great waldenfield Parish
Council to speak you sir had three
minutes to address the committee which
would be timed by the government's
officer can you see and hear me I can
see you and I can hear you good morning
good morning
great warding field oppose this
application on a number of grounds a set
in our objection but most importantly it
is premature several important matters
are unknown
we want the design code and construction
management plan discussed in a public
forum and agreed before submission of
any reserve matters applications
including this one
consideration of landscape in ecology
enhancements in a meaningful way is
impossible unless an agreed design code
is in place
we share the concerns of the other five
parishes and Newton about the lack of a
construction management plan and traffic
routing information
the impact of site traffic on great
warding field could be substantial
Taylor wimpy talked about using the B
triple one five which we object to in
past discussions the residential areas
were going to be accessed at the Western
end of the site
proper consultation and Clarity is
needed about all of this
regrettably a substantial part of the
promise Community Woodland is not being
provided by Taylor wimpy although it's a
key feature of children Woods
great what equals viewers it's
inappropriate that the residential area
is developed ahead of and independently
of the community Woodland
this makes it even more important that
residential land development is properly
landscaped
this point is clearly made in the review
by the independent Consultants but the
new design code was only distributed Us
in the last few days
the development should have physical
separation from the existing dwellings
in Acton Lane and on the B triple one
five this could be achieved by a belt of
greenery to give residents a sense of
place and community
however together with the other five
objecting parishes our Parish believes
that the developers need first to please
agree the design code and a construction
and traffic management plan to address
the valid concerns of us surrounding
villages
for these reasons great warning could
ask you please either refuse provision
today or adjourn the application thank
you
thank you very much for that
uh councilor Rustin right
um lady heart are you still there can
you switch on your camera please and
just come back into the meat and pet
your stay there also councilor Ashton
yeah um I do apologize I didn't ask the
officers if they had any comments to
make on what you'd stated in your three
minutes so I'm going to do that Mr
chairman can I just raise I don't think
constitutionally you're entitled to do
that well it's just it's just if
counselors have questions to put to the
officers they can do that the officers
are not entitled to comment freely on
public speakers comments well it's it's
purely from the point of view of
clarifying if you said something was a
mile away and it was two miles away they
would come in and say no I'm sorry it's
not a mile away we've measured that it's
two miles away and it's purely for that
sort of clarification so with respect I
will just ask if they wanted to comment
on anything that you've said and that
does will give you the opportunity to
um our answer back
um and councilor Rustin I'll take the at
the same time now with you so
um case officer Jasmine is there
anything that you wish to comment that
you heard that lady heart said in her
three minutes and then councilor Rushton
and there's nothing I've
comments
okay
um Stephen any comments no not at all
I'm sure members will take take into
account and give fair and proper
consideration to the yeah thank you very
much I just want to refer to
um Shelton and to
um
Greg waldenfield Paris Council thank you
very much both
thank you thank you hope you leave the
meeting now do you know uh though you
can stay you turn off your cameras and
bikes but I think you can stay in the
meeting and see the rest of the
proceedings
all right thank you
all right
right okay I have no move to China yes
sorry sorry chairman uh councilor
councilor Parker here um forgive me
chair just on a matter of procedure we
didn't get an opportunity to um question
uh councilor Rustin from great
waldenfield right sure quite right I
will do that now uh councilor rushed in
the field still haven't spoke about it
as you can say it's such a um a
complicated uh application we've got to
try and get it correct uh I do apologize
for that uh I was trying to make sure
that we hadn't missed out a lady heart
from children um Parish Council uh right
any questions
um for
um counselor Russian of great
waldenfield parish council members yes
uh councilor Parker thank you chair
um just a point of clarification please
um uh councilor Rushton um I I think you
said at the beginning of your um
statement that great Walding field uh uh
objects to the application and yeah the
report shows on page 26 the great ruling
field in actual fact support the
application so could we just have some
clarification on that please all I can
say is point you in the direction of our
Parish Clerk
um Sue because I have asked her to
change that before this morning
because I said to an objection and and
it turned out as as a support but it was
never a support
um our Parish Clark has been asked at
least three times the last week to
change it and to write to you and I
thought she had I'm sorry if she hasn't
so absolutely clarification is that a
typo then so I think it's a
a lack of understanding on my part that
I needed to write the word object on my
letter which had a list of objections
but in my first line of the of the email
I did not saying
Parker and and councilor Ashton I'm
going to ask our officers
um what they've got in front of them
because obviously as you quite rightly
say councilor Parker it is stated uh
supports the development and then goes
on to explain why so I I think that is
most likely what we're accepting unless
I'm told different
um can I just add to that um sorry could
you so I think just just from what
councilor Russian is saying I mean like
I absolutely accept that Council Russian
herself May object but are we saying
that that waldenfield Parish Council
have taken a democratic decision to
object uh so we do need some
clarification please absolutely I can
remember a similar insertation
with Newton Parish Council which you and
them had different views and that came
to the committee very similar to this so
I want to be clear on that you're quite
right I'm going to ask legal to help us
out I was I think councilor Parker sorry
I'm sorry I just don't want to put Mrs
Rush at a disadvantage if she she uh
councilor Ashton thank you I think you
must get your attention if I made this I
was about I think councilor Parker has
anticipated my point that I was going to
ask has great waldenfield Parish Council
had a meeting passed a resolution saying
this is what we want to say to the
district council yes yes
Monday yes and presumably there's a
minute although you might not have
approved that your next meeting possibly
I don't know you will have to speak to
our to our clock I'm afraid I'm sorry
that she hasn't emailed you to uh put it
straight that we are objecting not part
oh that um we were in fact
um am I allowed to ask
um well no I I think I think what I'm
going to say is I think the legal
officers told us that
um what you've said about your meeting
on Monday and if that is correct uh then
then members have heard it uh we've seen
what's been written in front of us told
them I was speaking I said I'm
subjecting I asked Sue so I'm so sorry
but In the Heat of the movement I cannot
remember her surname sue the Clark from
great warding field
um counselor maybe will be speaking I
believe later on in this so I'm quite
sure she will clarify as well at the
moment we've got both
um views we've heard um from from
we've heard the legal officer say
basically accept what you've said so
it's up to members now to weigh that up
okay chairman if I made just a quick
administrative Point following on for
something else that was said by
councilman I think we you want to make
it clear to everyone chairman that
everyone who's in this meeting has
invited into this meeting
um is is very welcome to stay for the
whole of it if they would like it you
know even if it's oh yes cockfield and
Sudbury but equally there is no
discourtesy if people have other things
to do and as soon as they've done what
they've done and we have got their
results or whatever it is if they need
want to depart that's so there's no
doubt about that
thank you okay thank you thank you very
much
um legal thank you very much
there's a hand up is that yeah I know
I'm coming I'm coming uh to you again
um the case officer uh you wish to come
in hello yes sorry um I thought I would
just clarify where we are with the
objection and the sort of
misunderstanding that's sort of risen
here
um so the tabled papers which members
have been circulated does State um great
wallingfield parish council do object
which is on the latest round of
consultation so we have taken that into
account and it is on the tabled papers
which are which provides the most
up-to-date response
um anything in the report was what I had
at the time when I was writing the
report so the very latest is that they
object right we're clear on that
thank you sue the Clark I'm sorry I
can't remember her full name
it comes to us all thank you very much
Council of Russian thank you and I will
leave the meeting now but if there are
no more questions no there's no more
hands up so thank you very much we're
now going on too and I've
um Parish Representatives I would now
asked Ralph Carter to speak
and Keith Nuttall to speak you have uh
nine minutes between you so you've got
four and a half minutes each but I'll
leave it up to you to stop and start
um the times you choose okay but uh you
will be stopped at the end of nine
minutes thank you very much
uh Ralph Carter are you there yes good
morning sir
um when you start the time will start
I can see you I I can't hear you
foreign
that's Mr Carpenter isn't it yes I don't
know which one uh you're going to start
right right
um we aren't uh working together so if I
overrun then uh Keith Nuttall would be
penalized so I think it's going to cut
me off right okay I'll ask the
government officer Robert Carmichael uh
he will stop you after four and a half
minutes don't worry Mr nuttle when we
start your game you will have your full
four and a half minutes okay Carry On
then Mr Carpenter it's not as they've
got down here Mr Carter right thank you
thank you chairman
uh at this meeting I'm speaking on
behalf of the members of the green party
in baber and numerous local people who
share our concerns about the scope of
this application our objections Center
on two issues the first is the community
Woodland and the second is the building
of a gas Governor you've heard many
arguments about this already
we are horrified that the community
Woodland has been excluded from the site
and as well as any agreement to finance
the planting and maintenance of the wood
by Taylor wimpy Tilton Woods was named
after the new Woodland which is now
absent from the proposal and it will be
a hollow shell of the original plan if
you allow this to happen the ecological
emergency needs this Woodland both for
the survival of the natural world and
also now as importantly for local people
who will be so dependent on a high
quality natural environment as they work
more and more from home
this agreement must be in place before
you approve any applications relating to
reserved matters
the second objection relating to the gas
Governor shows that Taylor wimpy clearly
have an intention to install a gas main
through the site
you will be aware that Suffolk County
Council and baber have both declared a
climate emergency only last year
furthermore a hard-hitting report
commissioned by the County Council
clearly shows that if we are to avoid an
ecological and climate catastrophe we
have no more than eight years to act and
probably less this development will not
be finished within that time scale
buildings are a significant emitter of
CO2
and the proposal by Taylor wimpy to
build the lowest possible standard of
Energy Efficiency powering the buildings
with gas flies squarely in the face of
your own declaration I put it to you all
members of the council that future
Generations will look at your decision
today in disbelief if you vote to
approve this application in the words of
our brave climate activist Greta tunberg
we say to you how dare you support a
proposal which threatens the future of
the planet
you'll be aware that there have been
numerous declarations both National and
international which legally bind us into
drastic reductions in our use of fossil
fuels and that means gas as well as coal
and oil
these declarations include the U.N Paris
climate change Declaration of 2015 the
UK climate change actor ended in 2019
the national planning policy framework
which states at paragraph 149 that the
planning system should support renewable
and low carbon energy and Associated
infrastructure namely the gas Governor
your own local plan of 2014 whose policy
cs-13 states that all new development
will be required to minimize dependence
on fossil fuels and make the fullest
contribution to the mitigation of
climate change through the adoption of a
sustainable energy approach to energy
use and your policy cs15 implementing
sustainable development
all this legislation points to now being
a critical time to decarbonize baber's
energy Networks
it is totally incomprehensible that
Weber District Council should be asked
to allow an application of this scale
and significance to be powered by
natural gas
there is no alternative but to base the
energy infrastructure on on site on
renewable renewably generated
electricity powering air source or
ground Source heat pumps for space
heating cooking and other uses if
natural gas is used you will be allowing
a double whammy a damaging impact on the
environment and high energy bills for
the occupants of the new houses and
businesses
Taylor wimpy stayed in section 2.1 of
their design code the development will
be of a standard that were used as an
Exemplar of good practice in large-scale
developments across the county if they
really mean this Taylor wimpy must work
with baber now and install a low-carbon
energy infrastructure and not a gas
governor in order to share this based
practice across the region
your planners claim that such a change
in energy approach is something that
cannot be considered as part of the
application but baber is wrong the
choice of energy to power the site is
very much a planning decision as your
local plan policies quite clearly State
the choice of a zero carbon fuel must be
placed center stage in this application
using gas will breach your own
declaration to eliminate carbon
emissions from buildings by 2030. many
of the houses on the site will only be
nearing completion by that date many
will not be complete
your time is now up thank you I will now
go to Mr Cliff Nuttall and your your
time will start when you start starts
speaking over to you
well I can't see myself only I can hear
you and we can see you okay so when
you're ready well thank you for the
opportunity of uh stating my uh
objection uh my objection is is one of
detail and it concerns the the linkage
to uh of the access way into Reynolds
Way
um the
in principle this this is something that
that takes little regard for the in
intervening a state of the bowl which
says today and I it's to the detriment
of the estate that continued use of this
access point is taken so I can go back
historically on on the choice of this
this was something probably I believe
was raised within the amec and uh Foster
Wheeler study and they they pointed to
this as being away that decision was
taken on the I believe on the basis that
there was a middle school and there was
land that was uh all um owned and
related to that school in the past that
was some going back some 10 years five
years ago I presented objections at the
time of the uh
um consultation it was in 2015 six years
sorry and the and I've repeated those
are stated those objections in a new
format with in January this year
they
um
the plan the illustrative plan that has
been put out for phase one
does not actually show a linkage between
the the site which is to the north of uh
Albury drive and secondly to the one
that is not of the linkage shown to
Reynolds way and that the spine road is
not actually shown on that diagram and I
would question whether it is actually
going to be installed in Phase One the
uh the next thing is that they I'm aware
that they're I'm sorry I was going to
comment on the historical and the old
school has been demolished the access
roads to and from that school there were
two remain at the southern end of the
um of the site onto Acton Lane and I
believe they should be utilized the
linkage from the primary road which goes
to Reynolds way should be relocated as a
linkage down to the south point of
access that exists this uh this in a way
will also be a determinant whatever
linkage is uh for an access where at
this point will be a determinant in
future work that goes on on site I Echo
all the comments made about construction
management and Logistics but when you
considers that this is only phase one
that's shown uh if we proceed with the
current access point to Reynolds away
then that will be laid in the
um in all future agreements the the
point is if one takes this alternative
way down to that uh existing exit then
that work traffic will then go down
um act and Lane towards Springfield Road
which is an objective stated in your
report of paragraph five seven item J
and I think that should be followed the
the point being also so that the future
work of south of the ex the uh the site
is to be
um could then be accessed by this access
right plus also the work that goes on to
the West all the building housing work
it goes to the west of current
um Housing Works proposed in phase one
and it is important to recognize that
that oh if with the present Arrangement
all the traffic will be going for these
areas we'll be going through uh Reynolds
way and Reynolds way is not suitable for
this purpose in as I've highlighted in
other in my objections to the committee
I press for the uh consideration of this
alternative
um line I've I've also copied uh the um
Mr Carmichael with a such illustrating
the routine that could be taken by this
road and I press for that to be done to
save the danger kill Mr natal yeah
I'm going to call back Mr
um Carpenter if he likes to come back
into it and if you remain sir I'll serve
us any questions for you from members
members have you got any questions you
wish to put to the two objectors
I say ah counselor Parker
um yeah thank you chairman uh it's just
a question to um to Mr Carpenter and um
thank you for um for your presentation
Mr Carpenter and um I'd just like to ask
though you you say that Greta timberg or
you quote Greta turnberg and asks how
dare we determine this application but
do you accept Mr Carpenter that um we're
not here today to determine
um the uh the guessworks on this
application
um but merely what is in the application
before us thank you
my understanding is that the gas
Governor is part of the application
thank you but that's not what's before
us today I think is the point that Mr
the counselor
um Parker is making
but thank you for your answer any other
questions
no hands up okay thank you very much
gentlemen thank you for your time
uh right we're now going to move to the
agent and applicant
where are we uh
I'm sorry I think that it's jumped a bit
right uh as we don't have a support huh
I will now ask the agents and applicants
to speak Samuel kessland and Matt
Richards you have nine minutes in which
to address the committee we you also
have in the background Mark Craddock
Greg Collins Robert Allen and Henry
Leonard for any questions from members
to help support you uh if um
questions become technical out of what
you said
um Mr nuttle can you
um
close down your camera please
I can't hear you because you're muted
I can still see you perhaps you can
close
your camera
thank you uh we've got Mr Hansen
um right as I say you have nine minutes
between you
um we won't stop you if if your
colleague takes over then you just carry
on okay and at the end of the nine
minutes I'll so there's any questions
from Members
um the time will start
as soon as you start to speak
members for this opportunity to speak in
support of the reserve matters
application
the planning manager at Taylor wimpy and
I've been working on the site since we
inherited it from our neighboring East
Anglia office during the land
acquisition process
I have no intention of using up nine
minutes of your time this morning as the
officer presentation and Report
excellent itemizes the application for
you however I do wish to make some
comments
Taylor Wimpy have purchased a
significant part of the land that was
approved under the outline consent and
we are absolutely committed to
delivering the scheme in accordance with
the approved children with parameter
plan and this includes all areas of
community Woodland within our ownership
this major infrastructure Works Reserve
matters application before you is a
critical step towards delivering the
development
the scope of this application is narrow
limited to technical details of drainage
systems and road infrastructure that the
residence residential Parcels will sit
around
as your officers have outlined if
approved it will enable the necessary
site-wide infrastructure Works to be
delivered in an expedient manner namely
the main roads and the cycleways and
footpaths sustainable drainage systems
and Associated planting and Landscaping
with which the residential Parcels will
all sit Within
the application before you has been
developed in close consultation with
baber Council mid Suffolk and Suffolk
County Council highways drainage and
Landscaping and ecology offices and this
collaborative approach has meant there
are no technical objections to the
application
you've heard this morning that some
parties have criticized the application
on its prematurity
this has been disputed by both ourselves
and your officers and I would note that
if you're mindful to approve the
application today we would not be able
to commence with these works until the
necessary pre-commencement conditions
including the construction access and
design code have been formally approved
by the council
also we are committed to working
collaboratively with the established
working group comprising local
councilors and Parish councilors and
other stakeholders on matters such as
construction access
similarly the outline planning
permission allows for the proposals
within this Reserve matters application
to be determined in advance of the
design code being approved
notwithstanding this these major
infrastructure proposals have been
developed alongside the formation of the
design code which itself is going to be
submitted imminently following the
collaborative drafting with the working
group and extensive consultation process
this application seeks permission for
the detailed layout in the site-wide
distributor road with Ingress points
from Orbee Drive Reynolds Way which
route around the site and terminate on
the western edge of the site the road
Network functions in a loop utilizing
the two primary access points as
envisioned at outline stage however
provision is afforded for the extension
of the road Network once the employment
land is brought forward
in addition this application secures
early delivery of the cycle and
pedestrian network with a width of three
meters across the master plan to the
site
delivery of cycle and pedestrian
infrastructure early in the development
will incentivize uptake in use of
sustainable modes of travel by residents
and will contribute to enhancement of
the existing network of local community
the drainage strategy comprises
provision of a series of drainage basins
wet ponds and Associated attenuation
systems set within areas of planting
careful consideration has been paid to
selection of native species in order to
enhance ecological conditions on site
a key priority of this initial stage of
Works has been centered upon early
delivery of planting set around the
roads and basins to enable this to
develop and material with the
development
the initial phase delivering critical
infrastructure will unlock the delivery
of the site within a Time range time
frames envisioned within the draft local
plan
the application proposals are considered
acceptable by the technical statutory
consultees and your professional
officers it presents it represents the
first crucial step in the delivery of
the strategically important site and
unlocking the delivery of new homes at
Chilton Woods we therefore hope you will
agree with your officer recommendations
and vote to approve this application
this morning thank you for your time
foreign
thank you very much
um your colleague doesn't wish to take
up the rest of the time no no not so no
we thank you we don't need to use that
time they're just here in case obviously
this is a very technical application and
I'm a lowly planner so um basically most
questions are probably outside of my
remit right thank you I will now ask
members if they've got any questions
that you wish to put to the agent
applicant
members
I can't see any hands up yeah councilor
Owen yeah oh right yeah your question
I've only got one yes I've only got one
question thank you Samuel um why have
you not sorted out the construction road
yet because that was that's what a lot
of the um moans have been about so why
why is that not come for forward first
of all thank you
there's a few points on this typically
we we actually wouldn't do and submit a
construct um Ascent until we've got sort
of Reserve matters for residential
elements of a scheme and we actually do
want to start start the building of it
um
as you'll appreciate providing a
construction management plan for a site
like this does take a lot of time and
takes a lot of consideration and as a
result of told working group we've been
considering a number of options here and
so in honesty it's it's not quite ready
it's not in a position where we've got
an advanced draft that we can share
um with the working group we have
covered that and it is our anticipation
to bring It Forward much earlier than we
would normally do on a site like this
um but um frankly it's just not in a
position where we're happy enough to
share it with you just yet
and that I gather would be coming back
to the officers and the committee to
make it um comments in the decision is
that correct well as
um Stephen Strauss said this morning
that that will be on on some members if
if they want to bring the dischargeable
condition back to a planet but it will
be coming back later to the office well
absolutely we as I as I mentioned in my
speech we we couldn't put shovel in the
ground with it without that being
formally approved by the council thank
you
uh counselor Jameson
councilor Jameson
all right sorry I was muted
um I think you may have answered what I
was going to say in the last
um sentences I was going to say um so if
this is approved today when you will you
start this before any other reserved
matters are agreed or were you um have
to wait for
other applications to go through first
as
um yeah sorry I sort of lightly covered
this there's a number of
pre-commencement conditions attached to
the outline application that we would
have to discharge what what this
application does is it is it provides us
with
I suppose a bit of a scope to sort
making a start on doing that those
pre-commencement works because up till
now we don't have any certainty of what
you know what we're actually doing in a
way and and how how are we starting it
so yes it sort of Springs those things
in into action and we'll be able to
start discharging pre-commensing
conditions so the point of this
application means that we can start the
works to get the main spine Road in and
that opens up the access to the
residential Parcels so this will be the
first element of the skin that we do
start building
so you will start work on this or you'll
be able to if that work on this we won't
be until we've just formally discharged
the pre-start conditions and that
includes uh the um the design code and
the
um construction management plan oh right
okay thanks
thank you any other questions
members
no don't yes
uh that's counselor Busby well done
uh Samuel yes where where are you with
the uh gaining control over the
employment land is it imminent
the
it's not it's I I'm not sure how much
members have been involved in we
[Music]
um
I I don't know whether that question is
relevant I'll ask our legal advisor
um and whether you need to answer it or
you can choose not to answer I mean
because I think it's a good question but
I think in can you give us I don't think
I don't think it's not a legally
unreasonable question I I think I'm not
going to say advise you to rule it out
of order chairman no so it's up to you
whether you answer it or not um yes
absolutely it's not it's not our
intention to acquire the employment land
we I think um
the case officer shared a plan within
her presentation of the extent of our
acquisition
um and we've also shared that that's on
our website we
our acquisition does not include the
elements of the employment land within
this site that's for the other
landowners to be bringing forward and
promoting
yeah actually the question was gain
control over and if the second part is
if you if we don't get control over that
part of the land
do you plan to build the site out from
the other access points
yeah as I say this I don't I don't want
to go too much in the construction
management plan as I've mentioned we
when we're not a stage of of being able
to present something but it is something
we have been in discussions with the
landowner of a potential
um construction access through that
north east south Western Hub employment
area
that's uh hopefully that helps you
somewhat councilor Busby any other
questions
no okay there's no other hands gone up
so thank you
um Samuel for that and
thank you uh members it's um
nearly five past 11 would you like a
five minute Comfort break or perhaps 10
minutes and get yourself a coffee and
anything else because we have five Ward
members to speak when we come back so
that would be some time before we could
take another break so are you happy to
take a break and say until
um 11 15. good decisions yeah I do I I I
knew you would be very pleased councilor
Busby
okay Robert would you do a roll call
just to see that we're all present thank
you thank you chair if members could
please respond with their presence
councilor Suez
I'm here counseling Madeline Barrett
yes I'm here Council David Busby
yep that's me Chancellor John Hinton
yeah councilor Lee Jameson
here councilman Mary McLaren
yeah councilor Adrian Osborne
present councilor Alison Owen
yeah and Council Stephen plow
wrestling
thank you chair the park will be here
councilor Park will be here as well Chad
I apologize councilor Parker I I missed
you out there I've actually made a note
of councilor Parker because I reloaded
gun by you
right we're all present then uh we'll
welcome back members uh we'll now go
back into item
um item number seven which is the
Chilton wood application
um and I'm now going to go to the ward
members
we have I think one two three four five
six Ward members wishing to speak you
all have five minutes each uh but I'll
take you separately I'm going to start
in alphabetical order again which is
counselor Clive arfi you sir had five
minutes in which to address the
committee over to you when you're ready
thank you chairman yes it won't take
five minutes at all
um
I ought to apologize in advance if my
internet drops out because it's been
really unreliable this morning
um but hopefully it'll stay with you
um so there are some very real concerns
locally and you've heard them this
morning they are particularly about
construction traffic but also you've
heard about the design code the Woodland
and the use of fossil fuels
and that's not an exhaustive list
because there are other concerns being
expressed in the process as well now I
don't dismiss any of these concerns
they're all very serious concerns
particularly about the haulage onto and
off the site
but I have to say I don't think they are
for you to consider this morning and nor
do I think they provide a valid reason
to that oh dear to delay today's
decision
um so I have to say that I think the
recommendation you've got in front of
you is the right one and in due course
all of those concerns will be expressed
thanks thank you very much
um
councilor arfi
um I don't think there's any need to see
if there was any question well members
is there any questions
um to councilor arfi
nope thank you we'll then go on to the
second award member which is councilor
Trevor Creswell
you sir had five minutes in which to
address the committee
right patient yeah that they would turn
up I don't believe that Council
Cresswell he hasn't joined me I will
just double check so that there's no
um yeah
sorry I I am oh all right my sincere
apologies counselor I hadn't seen you
joined apologies councilor Creswell uh
you have five minutes of which to
address the committee
um my only concern obviously is the same
as counselor Owens or one of my biggest
concerns is where the access points are
going to be and I believe they should be
sorted out before uh anything takes
place uh I think that's imperative to
Residents I also agree with Council
Jameson where he was on about the gas I
believe that in 2030 gas boilers are
meant to be obsolete and I believe that
we should be trying to put a different
method of heating hot water whatever
into the premises
and
um I believe that in 10 years that we
will have to um
maybe remove the gas central heat and
then the pipes and everything else which
cost thousands and thousands of pounds
um I obviously have concerns and I
believe some of the issues need to be
dealt with now rather than later thank
you
thank you very much I'll serve as any
questions for you
um members any questions to councilor
Creswell
no
uh councilor Creswell because you've hit
on a couple of points I'm just going to
ask the officers if they wanted just to
comment on that because they're two
points that I know they've come up
before and the answers may be the same
but I think you deserve an answer to
them
um
Jasmine or Stephen would you like to
pick those two pints up thank you
Stephen yes happy to chair uh only to um
to yes reiterate that they are of course
uh important points certainly the
construction management
um aspect of it and you say councilor
Creswell but it should be sorted before
development takes place
um that is entirely the case it is a
pre-commencement condition of the
outline permission
um in terms of the gas lines I think
we've been over and you're right the
government has has expressed its
intention to to phase out or indeed ban
gas from I think it's 2025
um albeit there's no legislation in
place for that as of yet and indeed the
building regulations still do not
preclude it I think I can only make the
point again that the application itself
and the utilities statement that
accompanied it accompanied it did
expressly uh provide for uh there being
a gas connection to the site the extent
to which that that will be part of phase
one of the residential uh application is
of yet unknown and at large
um we don't consider that that matter
Falls within the scope of the outline
Planning Commission however of course we
do have policies that do seek to
um minimize
um carbon emissions and impacts but of
course they themselves do not preclude
the use of gas I think we need to wait
and see what the actual energy strategy
will be for the development first which
um you know may include an element of
gas on that first phase legislation
permitting
um but which of course may include other
measures which would ensure that there
are carbon reductions in in accordance
with our policy framework thank you
thank you very much there's no hens come
up so I'm going to move on to our next
Ward member
you madam have five minutes in which to
address the committee
chair if I might I think I can be pretty
certain on this one and I apologize
um to council Creswell that um Council
malvisi won't be joining us this morning
to speak oh right thank you I'll then
move on to the next Ward member uh which
is counselor Margaret Mabry
you madam also had five minutes in which
to address the committee
thank you very much Mr Mr chairman
I have been part of the working party
for Chilton Woods since its Inception
and attended every meeting which usually
are bi-weekly spoken at each meeting
plus added comments via email and at
times telephone
I therefore feel I have extensive
knowledge of proposals for the site
however
I can always find Avenues from which to
learn through the working party process
for children Woods
to begin I questioned some of the
preciate a consulted comments Anglin
Waters worries me as it smacks off well
it won't affect me
but what of other landowners natural
aquifers ponds
Etc there is no definitive explanation
Landscaping does not include the
promised Woodland which makes Chilton
Woods children without the woods
added to this the land is open having
been World War II Airfield inhabited by
the USAF United States Air Force
therefore all topography has been
removed
Landscaping should include buns
which I have consistently requested and
substantial tree Landscaping along the
northern Edge to prevent noise
transference across the fields to other
established development and parishes
three meters combined cycle and
pedestrian ways concern me as once a
disabled person is assisted by whatever
means this uses two meters easily
recycled to safely pass by a disabled
person and assistant
within one meters and this is passing
each way in my opinion is not possible
these should be wider the width in my
opinion should be a minimum of three and
a half to four meters
almost all comments from surrounding
parishes major on the construction
management plan or lack of it which
these papers which these papers before
you today declare will be considered
under a condition condition 30 in fact
Chilton Woods is one of the largest if
not the largest strategic site approved
under alkaline planning permission for
decades
the residential build out will in my
estimation take a minimum of a decade
a firm declared planned out Hall Road if
not the definitive details of a
construction plan should have been
included in this Reserve matters
application but this District Council or
we as I am part of baber District
Council as an elected member have got it
wrong it should be remembered that this
site is from the sale of public land
owned by one local Authority Suffolk
County Council and planning permission
undertaken by another baby District
Council within the same county
we are here for residents we should be
considering residents both established
residents and future residents which we
will Welcome to our area
I could declare that any Hall traffic or
any increase in traffic will not affect
me personally
as I live a distance off a C-Class Road
however I Champion the need of others
hence I put my personal issues private
life
needs of a husband who has Alzheimer's
children grandchildren vocational breaks
to one side to support and to be an
advocate for others
the blight of 40 heavy Goods vehicles
sorry lost it heavy vehicles per day
trundling chasing thundering through
local Villages along narrow roads where
there are only narrow foot waves or none
at all is something I do not wish to see
or hear about from possible blighted
parishes in the future
this RMA should be refused under
conditioned cert until condition 30 has
been agreed as the LPA has declared the
Hall Road can only be side be decided in
this manner
Mr chairman and members of the planning
committee I urge you to refuse this
application until the matter of the
whole Road has been decided or as there
is always a median decision
adjourn this hearing for another date
when the Hall Road has
has been fully discussed decided upon
taking into account all parishes
concerned and a result clearly
advertised within the Public public
forum
I add I fail to understand
why Suffolk County Council is the
selling body have not concluded this
matter within this RMA as they are also
the highways Authority for Suffolk thank
you Mr chairman thank you very much
councilor Mabry
um I'll see if there's any questions
from Members I cannot see any hands up
so I'll take it that there isn't thank
you uh there's three points that I
forget just sorry
oh sorry uh yes your your hand comes up
on the left of my screen and most of the
others are all on the right of the
screen for some reason I don't know why
you're on the left of the screen but
there you are a councilor Busby there
must be something to be said about being
on the left of the screen anyway
um can I just point out that I quite
tired of hearing how this is the biggest
development this side of whatever in
favor Woolsey Grange is bigger that is a
Taylor wimpy development as well so
please get your facts right thank you
thank you uh I don't know where the
question was councilor Busby but uh
you've said it so there we are
um right there's another hands up so uh
I'm just going to ask the officers to
pick up three points I made a note of
because the infrastructure of the gas
and that sort of thing have already been
explained so I'm not going down that
road again please stay on screen
counselor Mabry
um you did mention where are you
councilman right yeah you did mention
Anglia water
landscape and and cycleways there are
three points that haven't been uh come
up so I'm going to ask the officer
Jasmine and Steven if they wish to make
any comment on those
and kill
Jasmine or Stephen
uh hello uh thank you chair
um I in respect of the specific comments
made by console tease um Jasmine is
probably a better place to answer I'm
suffice to say that obviously within the
the confines and envelope of this
particular application
um those matters and its impacts in
infrastructural terms have been
considered and there are no technical
objections
um if just as two other points of
clarification though and hopefully
um they may be of some um comfort to
councilor Mabry the first in terms of
the construction management plan or
construction Environmental Management
plan
um it is actually
um a part of the condition
um noting her comments that she was
worried about rooting through Villages
um that uh the and I'll read it directly
so you have a quote item J of that
condition is clear that there should be
measures for ensuring that construct
construction traffic does not use rural
routes alongside best practical measure
practicable measures to ensure
construction traffic entering and
leaving the site is rooted by the a134
springlands way so I I do not think it
would be the case that the wider rural
Villages
um will be besieged by
um hgv
um the the other point just a minor the
clarification is that when we're talking
about
um the community Woodland being missing
um that that's not quite right I think
within Taylor Wimpy's acquisition there
is an element of the community Woodland
that they have not acquired however the
land use parameter plan actually
includes large sways of community
Woodland
um which have been secured our and are
indeed part of Taylor Wimpy's
acquisition so Community Woodland very
much will be brought forward by the
developer thank you thank you
to reply am I Mr chairman not really uh
so I think he was quite clear I think
that's good but um
um Stephen and um the case officer you
haven't responded to
um Anglia water and the cycleways have
you got any comment on those two points
briefly that they may be uh yes I
suppose I can answer those um so in
terms of angling water
um they when they provide responses they
have said that they've got capacity for
these flows
um the sound water drainage system that
has been well foul water drainage
strategy that has been submitted with
this application
um has been assessed by them by Suffolk
County Council floods and mortar and
also by the environment agency and I
think the other thing probably to note
is that the proposed
um fatal drainage strategy is to go to
exist existing manholes where there are
angry mortar sewers existing
um that's sort of all we can really
consider at this stage and in terms of
the cycleways
um highways and I don't know if Sam
Harvey might have something else to sort
of add on it she's still there
um but obviously that is sort of
um subject to highways assessing it both
within the planet after
as you've sort of seen it today and
there are shared footpaths and cycleways
as well as just pedestrian footpaths and
I think the other thing to note is that
it also goes through this sort of
secondary stage of section two seven
eight and section 38 agreements um under
the highways act so it is assessed at a
later date
um but they have got guidance that they
have to sort of adhere to and assess
things against
thank you Sam Harvey are you there did
you just want to briefly comment on the
cycleways because I think it's a valid
point you may already have it in your
watch anyway yes
on the spine road is three meters wide
which is a route which is a width that's
adequate for a shared use Cycle Way
we know that in the government issued a
paper ltn 120 which is a local transport
note for making sure that cycling isn't
considered as second form of Transport
it's got to be highlighted as it's we've
got to give provision as much as
possible for cycling so with talking to
Taylor wimpy the developer we are making
sure that within the development itself
also there are cycle routes that are
um more direct
for the cyclists so going towards the
school or to the shops so they don't
have to stay on the spine Road we're
looking at a three meter plus
routes within the area so as that they
can go to these facilities and making
sure that a sufficient cycle provision
within the plots that are going to be
coming forward in the phases to come
thank you hopefully that reassures you
councilor Mabry that the officers have
have guttered in that right well thank
you very much for that thank you we'll
move on
um
there's no other hands gone up so I'm
going to move on now to the last ward
menu okay look to your Lefty via screen
again okay yes so I do apologize
councilor Busby uh councilor Busby you
have a question how dare you it's just a
point that Steve mentioned the Steve
trout could I just pick that point you
mentioned about all construction traffic
going
up in through the employment
area
as past the condition
um no sorry Council I didn't I didn't
say that apologies if I gave that
impression what it's saying is it needs
to come by the a134 which is the main
route that passes the frontage of
um Tesco's and the Woodhall Business
Park
oh so then it could go up the the narrow
Lanes uh it is um what do you mean by
narrow Lanes sorry
well the two alternatives to the
employment site entrance
well the the Alternatives that were
explored in the um committee reports um
when the application was determined
envisaged that it could come up the B
triple one five it could come through
um existing residential
um uh
um the local network
um but at this stage we don't have
anything before us to to assess um but
clearly there are a number of options on
the table and and what the committee
report expressed was that those
particular options May wax or Wane I
think was the precise term used
depending upon the particular phase and
the item to be delivered and where it
would be delivered and the nature of the
traffic to be used so it's it's going to
be quite a complex strategy it may be
that all of the traffic comes across the
Western half of the site
um I don't know it's clearly going to be
very important and everybody will need
to consider its content very carefully
but it is a pre-commencement requisite
and it is absolutely going to come in
for determination before any part of
this particular infrastructure
development is is facilitated or
implemented
so that when you say before any of the
infrastructures does that include
the building of the spine roads the the
drainage scheme the other infrastructure
Landscaping Etc absolutely the
conditions actually worked it on a on a
phase by phase basis so every element or
every uh application for reserved
matters that falls within this
permission or for the development will
require its own construction management
plan
right well aren't we put in the cart
before the horse in this in this
instance where we haven't got the
construction management plan
I'm talking about this well and I think
we're going to be getting into debate
there perhaps you can bring that point
to when we get into debate cancel a
Busby so that we can move on thank you
I'm sure you won't forget and I'm sure
that uh Stephen straywood will um make
sure that he comments on that uh but
with two more award members I'll now go
to a ward member councilor John Nunn you
sir have five minutes in which to
address the committee
when you're ready okay thank you chair
uh at the risk of uh tiring councilor
Busby even more I I will get and
probably go over old ground again but I
will proceed anyway uh Mr chairman of
members uh today you are here to make a
decision on what is one of the largest
planning applications in many years for
this District
one so great it will impact upon the
whole area for generations to come
we have to get it right the public
through their councilors have to be
fully involved
decisions cannot be made in private
meetings or deferred for later they have
to be fully transparent
Suffolk County Council is the largest
financial beneficiary of this scheme
labor District Council is another
beneficiary through the development
process
one body judge and jury over the highway
system and the other body deciding the
planning permissions
that is factual and how the public see
it
all the matters raised by The Joint
parishes in in particular Chilton should
mean this application has hit the
buffers until the matters are resolved
through the open Democrat Democratic
process so please refuse it until the
construction access and practicing plus
other issues raised by the adjoining
parishes are resolved
this development is going to have a huge
impact for a very long time on our local
area and we need to get it right from
the start
thank you
thank you very much
um right there was nothing extra that
you highlighted other than the point I'm
going to pick up which I wasn't very
happy was Private meetings I'm quite
sure the District Council planning
committee and officers that we are
transparent and open
um but I accept that there may be
meetings that take place that you might
consider to be private but I'm going to
ask the officers
um or um Stephen Strahan
um just to pick that point up and the
legal expert can you just comment on
that on that point for us please and
then I'll go to members for questions
Stephen and legal
well I I don't know how to respond to
that I don't I'm sure it was meant in in
Good Nature obligation of a serious
nature um I think I I'd only point out
um to members that of course and has as
has been touched upon there is a working
group so the idea is that all of these
particular matters
um do come to the group they're aired
and they're discussed and it helps to
formulate and shape the applications to
come now I fully appreciate that there
are criticisms that there has not been a
flashing out of detail in respect of
construction management at this stage
and I think I can only respond as I have
done previously that it is not a
requirement for the developer to do so
yet but they must and they will
otherwise they're quite simply be in
breach of planning control they cannot
commence development until that
construction routing has been dealt with
thank you very good answer Ian if I
measure something I mean I I didn't I
interpreted counselor nuns comment to be
that he was making the Fairly obvious
point that where it's a discharge of
condition it could or it often generally
is a decision by officers and that it's
private in that sense I didn't
absolutely absolutely I think Mr Stroud
has answered that there is in this case
we do have the working group and we have
I mean discharge of condition
applications it's fairly rare in local
governments once they go to committee
but not unheard of but it's a matter for
us as has already been said more than
once for members to decide
um
the decision-making method as it were
right members any questions I see
councilor Busby's got his hand up
yeah you should pick up a point uh John
you mentioned that the the beneficiaries
were going to be Suffolk County Council
and labor District Council hopefully the
main beneficiaries are going to be the
1100 families that get a house
absolutely agreed agreed well done thank
you uh there's no other hands gone up so
I assume that there's no more questions
councilor none so I'll move on to the
last ward member to speak councilor Jan
Osborne you met him had five minutes in
which to address the committee
thank you and morning Mr chairman and
members I will be brief as I appreciate
that there has been many people wishing
to speak we have waited many years for
this application an important
application and I welcome it coming
forward
over the last few months Taylor Wimpy
have spent a great deal of time holding
virtual sessions with local members
giving them the opportunity to raise
their concerns although not part of this
application the construction
Environmental Management plan is of
great concern to members and residents
I note from Pages 36 and page 37 5.7 of
the report clearly states that no
construction can commence until this
plan has been approved and I also note
the proposed contents of the plan there
is also a condition 30 of the outline
application I hope this plan can be made
available as soon as possible to help
align any concerns that people may have
and have indeed raised today at this
meeting and I do hope that the council
will approve this application thank you
Mr chairman thank you members
thank you very much counselor Osborne
um members is there any questions that
you wish to ask counselor Osborne
I can't see any hens coming up
right then I think we've got to the end
of the public speakers we're now moving
into the debate stage
so I will now open It Up For Debate
um again counselors can I ask you to use
the hands up function uh right in the
absence of um trying to get started I'll
go to councilor Sue Ayers and then if
any others um wish to come in will you
put your hands up cancel Ayers
just so you're at the beginning of the
alphabet I think thank you and as my
dentist said at the end of the A's
because it's a why afterwards
um I'm just concerned
um about this construction traffic
because I do know the roads very well
and um particularly Acton Lane
um and the other access roads because
only because living where I do in
Weaver's Lane and how my life in the
last year has been disrupted by all the
big traffic just going to gainesville's
house
the patients are all broken up and and
yes you do need these large lorries but
that's why I really do feel that we
should look very carefully and make sure
that
um these lines you think Acton Lane I I
mean it's so narrow
and that unfortunately lorries have
their satin abs and they don't always
follow the route they should so that is
my main concern thank you chair thank
you I'll ask the officers to comment but
I would think that any any damage done
to the lanes or Pavements and that would
have to be obviously repaired and made
very good but anyway
um Jasmine can you help
or highways if they wanted to come in on
that
um I think Sam has unfortunately had to
leave at the meeting but
um I think I can only really Echo what
uh Stephen has sort of fully said in the
that construction management plan will
be considered
um at an appropriate time and it will
have to be done before any work can
start on site
um that's that's really it
um
Busby
yes chair uh there's going to be a lot
of the discussion I will think but look
can I cut things short
yeah as I said I think it's a case of
carton horse we've got here we know we
can't start any work including site
preparation until there's a construction
management plan in existence
therefore
I propose that we postpone this decision
until we've got a construction
management plan and we can look at the
two together
thank you I need to
um take a face on this
um illegal can you help out here before
I go for a seconder it's it's a
perfectly it's it's a perfectly valid
problem I think if it's seconded I I
think I would suggest you take the
senior officer's advice as to the
practicalities of it
um I mean as you have been advised that
if you decide today to follow the
officer's recommendation and approve
this Reserve matter that condition 30
prevents as Mr Stroud said condition 30
prevents the diggers going out on site
tomorrow it's it needs to be discharged
in respect of this this phase this this
Reserve matters
um proposal in itself but I think I
would suggest you take some some
practical planners advice on that's my
that's my legal advice towards at the
moment thank you Stephen did you wish to
comment before I get a second
um thank you chair only to say that I
think that the developers reasoning for
taking this approach um has been
explained in that this is a commercial
decision in terms of putting forward an
application for works that will give
certainty they know that they can then
plan for that and they can then prepare
formally the construction management
plan to support it because of course
there is no approved Reserve matters at
this stage
um I just again point out that of course
the the structure of the permission has
been worded to enable this to take place
and to allow for applications to be
choreographed in this way uh and and
again they cannot commence until that is
um until that is agreed albeit they will
have the certainty knowing that they've
got Reserve matters approval for those
works and can plan accordingly I think
the only practical uh the other
practical consequence and and this is
not material but you need to be aware of
it is of course the risk should you
decide that you don't want to determine
this application
um the applicant could be free to make
an application for non-determination and
I think they may well have reasonable
grounds for
um even seeking costs um that's not
relevant to the decision you're taking
but nevertheless as holders of public
office you need to be aware of that that
there is nothing
um wrong with the way that the applicant
is proposing and indeed it may be
considered unreasonable for us to delay
um the determination of this app
particular application
yeah if I might just add something like
yeah yeah Steve Stephen is quite right I
mean a cost risk is not a material
consideration in any planning decision
however in planning it's fairly
straightforward you're only at risk as
any as the local planning authority of a
cost award if you've acted unreasonably
and caused detriment and expense to
someone else and I think Stephen's
advice is it would be in his his opinion
would be an unreasonable act in all
these circumstances
could I just very quickly asked before I
get a second I would
um are the is the applicant doing
anything different to what anybody else
would do whether it was a small or large
application in front of us
Stephen in my experience no chair and
construction management plans or simps
um they're always pre-commencement they
have to be pre-commencement so that
you've appropriately considered and
understood what the impacts of
development might be
um but they do typically follow a
reserve matters approval um because the
developer knows precisely what it is
they've got
um approval for because of course you
can have a planning permission but not
then the finer detail or granular level
of detail that goes with it once they've
got that approval they can plan for it
and they can apply to discharge that
particular condition and that's
absolutely the situation here and that's
open and transparent
yep thank you right so as your hand went
up when I first mentioned a seconder uh
thank you thank you very much right well
members it's been proposed and second
that we defer this and make sure that it
comes back with the
um other matters that have been outlined
by councilor Busby and seconded by
councilor Ayers
um and I think we can go to the photon
that either for a game store abstain
unless there's any debate which there
does seem to be so I'm gonna have to
take that
um
followed by councilor Parker
thank you uh chair um I wanted to come
in here because I wonder whether it's
really entirely fair to make this
proposal
um when there are other issues that we
could also be
um quite quite concerned about
um it's not just about construction
there's landscape issues there's design
issues you know we could go on on on
onto the these different areas that
might be of equal equal weight
um
of course
um people do get concerned about
construction and it's in everyone's
interest to to have a construction plan
and that seems to be universally agreed
um
but um but we can condition it and and
you know if you look at the
recommendations in the report there are
a number of
um uh stages the developer has to submit
to before before
um proceeding further so we could easily
um condition it and also just because it
is a big development
um I don't think it should be treated as
as a all-consuming issue because it is
over a 20-year period so although there
is a there is that looks like there's
going to be such a volume of
construction uh transport movements
um this is a very long period so if it
if it's it's it's like a developer
proposing 50 new dwellings each year
that doesn't present a particular
problem
especially when these roads are coming
off quite a main road the a road it's
not down tiny country lanes at all so I
really cannot see how we cannot get over
this with the usual measures
thank you
um before I come to councilor Parker if
you're just bear with me
um Mr Robert Carmichael has indicated
and as you know he's the little man in
my ear that values me so I would love to
go to him next
um Robert Carmichael thank you chair um
just a quick point of housekeeping
um as we've now reached over the marker
in terms of modern.gov logging out I was
just going to remind members that before
we get to the vote they will need to do
that so if any members want to do that
in the background
um to do it now thank you chair all
right thank you uh well you may have to
remind me because I can't do that while
I'm doing these other things uh
councilor Parker
go next
yeah thank you chair um same thing
that's completely confused me having to
do two things at once now yeah we're not
that clever are we sorry I didn't mean
that like that yeah
um I mean I just want to concur with
councilor Barrett
um uh chairman on on this um I I think
that we have got all of the info I fully
take on board what what um
Council Busby is saying and I do fully
understand the concerns but I also think
that those concerns are adequately
addressed
um within the report and we can
condition
um and and we're often accused
um about this it's just interesting
listening to the debate we're often
accused about of of of bureaucracy uh
and and lack of transparency
etc etc so there's there's a number of
items that that arise from councilor
Busby's
um uh proposition
um actually
[Music]
um one in my opinion unfortunately I
think it just kicks it into the long
grass I mean it does exactly that it
just defers but at some point if the
construction management or when when the
construction management plan comes
forward and it has to as per the
original outline application
um but when that comes forward is there
now a suggestion that that will come
before um committee and all of the uh
all of the consequences of that and
uh the the potential of of that being
refused Etc
um there is no surprises here with um
with with children Woods uh it's been
around for as long as I can remember
um and I just think we we need to be we
think need to think very carefully
um about pushing this even further down
the line
um I I'm satisfied that we've got the
conditions to uh to be able to make this
um uh recommendation today however it
goes that's what I'll say thank you
thank you very
um that's councilor Parker A very wise
words I think uh right well
um there's no other hands gone up so I
think we now have to jam in my hand's
been up virtually since that's the Busby
started talking no I can't see yours at
all but that's uh counselor John Hinton
I think that's why mother not on the
left but off the top somewhere probably
I don't know where you are but you're
not on my screen at all but cancel a
hint and you are next
right just a couple couple of points in
support of what councilor Busby said in
actual fact if you look at page uh third
and prepared if you look at page 32 of
the report second paragraph down it
talks about several there are several
discharge of conditions applications
currently under consideration so there's
a lot still to be decided on this before
we even uh look at the uh application as
far as the
spine road is concerned but also when
the legal advice and the chief planning
officer start talking about the
applicant might decide that that we
haven't determined it in time according
to page 23 of the reports today uh it
talks about the expiry date for this
application being the 13th of March
2021.
so it's out of time now
but at the same time it was granted in
2018 so what on Earth as a developer and
the officer's been doing since then if
it's not been trying to get some of this
together
so I think we're perfectly reasonable in
deferring this until we've got a bit
more solid information if you like to to
go on
I think you've asked a valid question
there
um councilor Hinton I'm going to ask the
officer over there you can explain why
they haven't got to us before the 13th
uh Stephen Stroud
um well I I don't really know how to
respond I mean Taylor Wimpy have only
had the site now uh had it had it
acquired it last year I mean the uh the
the disposal of land is is a long
process it's a complicated site and uh
it's been through a long marketing
process
um Taylor wimpy with the preferred
bidder and acquired it last year and
they've done
trying to um progress the development
since then so I don't think it's a case
that people have been sat on their hands
and the other minor point is to say that
the 13th of March hasn't yet occurred um
that's in three days time uh yeah I just
I just want to add I mean I think it's
the 13th of February oh well you said 13
for March
right the Irish chairman I was just
going to add the Fairly obvious this
isn't the common sense Point rather than
the legal point that one first things
you notice with this planning permission
the outline permission is it allows 15
years for as a masses which is an
exceptionally long time but it was
clearly considered fair and Justified
three nearly three years ago when
permission was granted so I think it you
see matters in that context and of
course as Mr Stroud said this this
developer has acquired the site
um not not the day after the granting
information
right thank you I see no other hands up
uh
David Kent counselor Busby
look the the intention is not to delay
this in any shape or form we all know
how important this site is to baber and
to uh people looking for houses that is
not the intention of this my concern is
look if we approve the uh
the access routes Etc today
but we don't approve the construction
management plan
could that impact on the decision that
we've made today it might be that they
have to change the roads uh access if we
don't approve their construction
management plan that's why I say it
seems strange putting the cart before
the horse I mean perhaps Steve could
explain that to us
um Steve I don't know I think you've
done a lot of explaining but is there
any any extra bits you're gonna add to
help counselor Busby only to say to
council the Busby that the access points
into this site um have already been
granted planning permission under the uh
the permission of March 2018.
right uh there's no other hands up so
I'm gonna ask uh Robert did you get down
what the proposal was in second and
seconded
Robert yep
so if I could just run through with what
I've got down to check with the proposal
in a second
so
I have got that application DC
2005183 is the third to be heard
alongside the construction management
plan for the Chilton Woods application
um I don't know if I need to seek advice
from Mr Dupree Mr Stroud and
autologous whether that is appropriate
well yes I I was going to say we do need
to be absolutely precise and clear and
avoid any muscle understanding about
what this proposal is and Mr Stroud may
have to You may wish to take his advice
so that there are two issues as I've
already said the the um this this
Reserve matters application and the um
the discharge of condition 30 insofar as
it relates to this first this first
phase of Reserve matters if I can put it
like this so is it being is what we're
being asked the committee being asked to
prove it is it that the construction and
management the decision to discharge the
condition the condition 30 in respect of
this phase of Reserve matters and the
reserve matters application self
come back to another committee together
and be considered I think I would like
you to take Mr Stroud's advice on the
practicalities of that race yeah Mr uh
Stephen strahud uh perhaps uh you can be
very clear because this is important
yeah I I understood um the nature of the
proposal which is that
um in effect the determination of this
big application be held off until such a
time as the construction management plan
has been submitted and that in effect
they be determined alongside
um
I can only say members that
there is nothing wrong with the approach
that the applicant has taken and indeed
it is reasonable when you consider how
the permission has been constructed
construction management remains a
pre-commencement matter there is nothing
to stop and indeed as as I've already
stated the applicant has explained the
commercial reasons why they would like
the certainty of having approval for
this first phase before then dealing
with the construction management plan
and my concern numbers in Practical
terms is that by in effect stating that
what they've done is unreasonable and I
think that's what could reasonably
inferred from taking the the action that
you're proposing uh this this does leave
things in a in a difficult position for
us going going forward but that's not to
say that I do not think you can
legitimately
um not carry forward the proposal that's
been made I just think that it may have
adverse consequences elsewhere which are
not Material
thank you right members I think it's
been clearly explained to us now so uh
Robert will you take us through the
voting process
yes jim I've got to go into dot gov
headline yes so if members could please
open the modern.gov app and please uh go
to the plus sign in the top right head
Corner whereby numbers will get the
selection of voting and attendance if
they could please click on that Tab and
the vote is now in progress in a light
blue line you may need to scroll down
if any members are having any issues
please let us know
I've got to the photo the attendance and
Photon but it won't go any further
have I got to close and come out of it
and start again
um
so what sorry chair could you just
explain that again sorry uh right I've
got up by the planning committee
Wednesday 10th of March um 21 attendance
photo yep if you if you click on that
does it take you to the next screen no
it doesn't okay
I believe everybody else has managed to
get theirs but I needed to work don't
know
you might need to close the whole of
modgov and reopen it then I'm afraid
sure will I lose you all no no because
that's on the team's cool chair it's
just that software right it's gone back
to the agenda page with the plus sign in
okay
um if it's helpful to share it's only
yourself and one other counselor so if I
take those two and then right okay
that's fine so if I could take your vote
share
uh I'm um I vote against the proposal to
defer it and kill
thank you I've lost everything
and you had one other you needed to take
yes I believe councilor buzz it was
Council Buzzy but he has now done oh
that one
um so chair the result of the vote is
six of votes against the proposal and
five votes four
so it will show on your mum.govers
as drawn but the motion is lost
thank you
right
um it's because I can't get back into
mud gap for whatever reason but if I try
and come out then I think I lose all of
you and we'd have to go all through the
process again so we'll carry on as we
are at the moment right I've got
councilor Lee Parker uh would you like
to continue
thank you chair
um so on on that basis then assuming
that we're back to square one I would
like to propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation uh as um set
out in the uh in the committee report
happy to listen to any Amendments of
members might want to put in thank you
thank you do I have a seconder councilor
Barrett foreign
Plum next uh thank you I'll I'll second
that thank you councilor Plum I was
going to Second it it's okay I'm sorry
thank you any other comments
no it's all uh councilor Owen yes
um we ought to bring try and bring the
construction
back to the planning committee I don't
know if this is the right right way of
doing it
bringing the construction back to the
planning committee I'd like that as one
of the poor please it's one of the
conditions yeah uh right I'll ask the
legal and officers
um to comment on that
um right I don't know if Ian wants to go
first yeah I mean that's a that is a
perfect if
if the proposal and secondary can be
persuaded to include that so that that
would be a so in fact the the the the
the promote if the proposer and
secondary accept counselor Owen's
suggestion what would happen and if it's
passed what will happen is we Grant
Reserve matters approval today but the
committee is directing the officers to
bring when the we get to the point where
condition 30 has to be it's charged in
respect of this this reserved matters
phase that the decision not be made by
officers were brought to the committee
but hopefully I've understood councilor
Owen correctly in in what she wants um
uh and then that is but it's for the
proposal and seconded to say whether
they would like to yeah
um sorry uh Robert Carmichael you're
coming in at the moment yep
thank you chair um just as a quick quick
point of
just a point to Mr pray just to clarify
this would it would that necessarily be
possible to add that to this application
as it does not directly relate to this
application in the sense of course or
would it go through the delegation panel
as described in the planning Charter
yeah that Mr thank you Mr Carmichael
that's a very fair point yeah I'm
thinking on the hoof a bit here yeah
that's
so I think yes in other words we're
saying to members either vote for or
against the proposal made by Council
Barrett and then yeah then we go to
delegation panel so in other words
well how would the delegation panel
normally works by award member asking
that something could be concerned
yeah yes it does and In fairness uh
there's only three members that vote in
there which is the chairman the vice
chairman and the chief Clan and officer
and so I think that's a little bit
unfair to put it all on to them
um I'm gonna ask
um uh Stephen Stroud to comment on
whether the he feels this is a necessity
to pick this point up or whether we
should proceed as we normally would and
allow the situation to come back through
its normal Avenues Stephen Stroud
um that's a very very difficult one to
answer chair I think I can only comment
that of course it's it's up to members
um whether they wish it to be recorded
that they would like to see that
particular application come to
um uh committee
um you are here determining the
application before you
um I think and In fairness
um in light of all of the comments that
have been made during the the public
speaking
um part of this this meeting
um it is clearly something that the
public would very much like to see I
would only make the point that it is
fairly um unique to see a condition
um discharge application come to
planning committee it's not something
that you would expect certainly
um for for technical matters
um or indeed for every condition
applying to a planning permission but I
fully accept and note the local feeling
in respect of construction management
routing and if members would like to
record that that they very much would
like to see it come forward then and
that that seems fair to me but actually
I think the mechanics of that with our
Hospital past I think is is best for Mr
Carmichael and Mr debris to how it's
recorded if I make if I may add further
yes having listened to both of my my
colleagues I think yeah the delegation
panel is the normal
mechanism under this council's
constitution for the council to decide
whether planning applications include it
in this that includes in this context
discharges of condition and Reserve
matters are dealt with by officers or by
the committee and it would be quite
proper even in the normal course of
events for any Council to say excuse me
I no discharges of conditional normally
dealt by officers by a delegation panel
hello there I really think you should
direct this goes to committee that
that's uh Mr Carmichael's book I think
yes Stephen is right that it would not
be wrong this this committee is perfect
in Liberty to express its opinion
collectively and say that it it would
like to see that and it would then I
think it would they can't do delegation
panels job for it but they can express
an opinion I hope that makes sense so
that that could be down to the
delegation panel at the end of the day
yes whether it does come regardless of
the outcome uh I've got councilor
Stephen Plum face chairman so I'm going
to take him next
thank you thank you chair
um I'd just like to make the comment
that I I think what we've heard today
um is is the fact that people would like
to see more openness and on something
like this that is going to go on for a
period of time I hope it won't make a
precedent for every planning application
but I see personally no reason why we
can't come back to committee with the
plan
thank you uh councilor Lee Jameson
if
yeah
sorry Jr
yes uh thank you sorry about that uh
they're slightly different though can we
um in some way look at the the gas
supply in in some way in the future is
as keeps being mentioned this is a
20-year plan guess isn't going to be an
option so it seems pointless the develop
our plans I guess it's not going to be
used in 20 years time so is there any
way we can get that reviewed and I was
agreed originally but that was a long
while ago
well again I suppose I would have to ask
the
um proposal and sanctor as to whether
they'd take any of these on board which
I hadn't done yet so uh that's in the
mix as well I would assume thank you
um
right I'm going to go to the proposer
who wanted to deal with the clan which I
think was Lee
um Parker and seconded by
um councilor Barrett uh whether they
wanted to pick up any of those points or
not I think that's the simplest thing
that was the gas and the other issue
uh well yes certainly I mean I suppose
the issue that I've got is that having
just gone around all the houses and
things I'm I'm not entirely clear for
example if we take the first point with
regards to should it come from should
the construction management plan come
forward
um before committee I'm not entirely
clear
um I'm gonna need some clarification
from Mr Duprey
um ordinarily chair I would have to say
and this comes back to a point that um
uh that councilor Nunn raised earlier
about transparency
etc etc and ordinarily I would say that
the uh the the charter that we have
offers more than adequate transparency
actually and um and it is highly unusual
I can't think of another time where
we've listened to a you know a condition
being discharged via VIA committee
um and again it comes back to that uh
bureaucracy issue however
given the magnitude of of this
particular application I I I would be
persuaded I could be persuaded I have
been persuaded that on this occasion
um it it would be appropriate if
um you know if my secondary agrees
um with that that we do that with
regards to the second point and and the
gas
Etc
um I do need some further advice because
that just simply doesn't form part of
the uh of The Proposal as it's in front
of us so I I need to understand that a
little bit further because that that
seems to be a material change
um to um you know to the whole
application so I'm I'm I don't know is
the answer um
I'll get the legal and the officers
respond to that and then I'll go to your
sector
um on the on the first one yeah my
considered advice to the committee is I
don't think it's legally possible for
this committee to direct and require
that the a discharge or condition
reconditioned 30 Comes This committee
that under our constitutional around
that is a matter for delegation panel
but as I've said if this committee
insists it may it's not improper for it
to express it's it's its opinion that's
that that's my opinion on that and
that's it would mean going to the
delegation oh yes yes it would
absolutely it's very limited
um I know I know it is
unusual to do this yes
so can I can I just absolutely clarify
then Mr Duprey so what you're saying to
me is is that actually I can't accept
that as um I I can express the or sorry
I can um I can accept the expression of
wish but we we can't um it's I can't
accept that that Amendment so I think I
think you see I think it's basically it
would almost be like an info we
sometimes you're you're advised with
normal planning outline or full
applications that oh I'm afraid we
really can't advise you to have a
condition on that or an amendment but it
could be an informative it would be
that's the nearest analogy I can think
of okay text it would it would be like
this committee has noted the strong
public concern about the construction
and management plan and it's and some
elements of public um I can't um uh
consideration of of it formally but
that's that's up to you and your your
secondary counselor
yeah right Stephen will you come in
please to see if you can help him
yeah
yes chair just on on that first point um
I I think obviously follow follow the
legal advice that's given to you I mean
I I from a lay perspective I suppose it
would be the fact that you're recording
that members have expressed a wish for
it to come to committee and I dare say
as somebody who sits on the delegation
panel with your chair um that would be
an expression that would weigh quite
heavily on my shoulders
um I I think that's uh without I think
it was ways heavily on the other two
members as well yeah so I think you know
we put that down to three members
um but this is within your gift yes and
in terms of the gas issue um I think
we've covered the extent to which
um it would be material to to consider
um the energy impacts of Simply Having a
gas Governor station as part of this
application but that's not to say that
going forward in time of course
um applications for Reserve matters for
dwellings will need to
um adhere to the up-to-date building
regulations at the time
um they will of course be subject to
assessment by the council sustainability
officer and we do have policies that are
very clear that there needs to be uh
an evidenced reduction in in um in
carbon emissions
um albeit not expressly precluding the
use of gas and as and it may be that
legislation overtakes Us in that respect
anyway thank you all right I'm going to
go to councilor Barrett who's the second
of the original proposal
uh do you accept any of these or your
comments okay
um on the construction plan sorry as
I've as I think I've said
um it's only everyone's interest to have
one of those so
um as I understand it we're being
advised that it has to go to the
delegation panel and not for us but but
I suppose what we could say is that this
this uh committee believes that there
must be
um a management plan that that looks at
hours noise and dust management measures
um weight signage and all those sort of
issues that should be should meet a
certain standard
um could that could that strengthen
um the um position for the delegation
panel so they have some some Benchmark
to to to know what what we're looking
for
um but otherwise you know um
uh oh sorry so can I get you an answer
to that part of your request
um legal and Stephen can you come back
please
um yeah I've do you want to go first
Stephen sure just just in terms of the
construction management
um point there Council about it and it
is something that is already conditioned
on on the outline and it's that
particular condition that the applicant
would be
um applying to discharge or comply with
um I think the question is really
whether you want to record that the
planning committee would very much um if
it were possible to see that application
come to planning committee for its
determination and not one under officer
delegated powers
there you go yes
I can't add nothing to add all right
right
uh so I'll come back to you too how do
you want to move forward on this your
proposal are you accepting the um the
um added in conditions that are wanted
uh yes chair is the answer I I I think
you know we don't need to over
complicate it I think we um we propose
the recommendation as shown in the uh
the report
um and note members desire that any
construction management plan
um is is heard by uh committee but
that's for noting only
I'll go with that I'll go with that
thank you right okay
um there's a couple of hands still up I
don't know whether they're old ones but
I'll try uh cancer Plum and canceller
Busby
thank you chair
um I'm I'm a little bit concerned as the
third member of the delegation panel
um and in in terms of openness I I think
we're moving to a certain extent back
into that darkened room yes
through
um a desired for openness that we we
really ought to be asking for this to
come back without having to put upon
three people sitting in a darkened room
uh yeah so a very understanding is that
uh that's the only way it can come back
is by going to the delegation panel and
those three members well two two elected
members and chief planning officer
um would say yay or nay
um and as you say it is in a closed room
to tell me why I can't insist on that
well I think if I may cancel the I think
the the
the council's decision certain matters
are laid down by law by planning
legislation by The Local Government Act
particularly the 72 Act of there's
certain
um
processes every Council owner whether
it's a county or District or Borough or
whatever or indeed a parish has to
follow but we um councils have their own
rules and that for instance I mean our
neighbor mid-suffolk Council has a rule
in its Constitution that goes beyond the
less of the law saying Ward members
don't vote if they haven't a member of
the committee and it's something in
their Ward whereas baber and West
Suffolk the other Council I look after
in the shared legal service doesn't have
that rule nor the majority in England
actually but that's that's fine with
Suffolk have that rule so but one of
baber's rules is that it has a
delegation panel whose job a combination
of men but it's not a formal Committee
of the council but it's a mechanism
which determines
how it's a kind of safety valve to make
sure that there is public and a way of
decisions that would normally be
um
officer decisions can be as it were
called in to use that that's that's
perhaps the wrong word to use here but
it's
can be made by committee and it is the
way that baber District Council in its
Constitution which is obviously adopted
at the full council meeting does this
sort of thing so I've thought about this
quite carefully as we've been sitting
here right I think it is it is
it is the way in which labor Council has
chosen to make a decision about how a
decision is made if I can put it that
way uh I think I've noted all the
concern that every member's expressed
but I think the best really my advice is
the best you can do today is to if you
like add this what I've called an
informal informative
recording the committee's um opinion if
that's what is if that does turn out to
be the majority view of the committee
I accept that with great reluctance so
so do I but lungs members are aware that
free people could end up making the
decision on this well I was going to say
we we both know that the the
um
coverage that we can achieve with the
delegation panel is extremely restricted
absolutely absolutely very very firm
lines that we have to go down well I
hope the proposals are on seconder
hear what we're saying anyway I'll go
back to them as the final two to see who
uh councilor Busby you've got your hand
up have you got anything you wish to add
because I didn't really want to get on
with this name yeah we had something
very similar with Wolsey Grange where
the decision decisions were made
maybe it was a delegated decision I
don't know but uh
the the
members and the members of public and
the parish councils didn't get a chance
to to
participate
in the decision after outline planning
there was a lot of anger
in the in the community about that not
saying that they would have disagreed
with what came forward but it's the
opportunity to participate in that
decision making
and for the for the committee we're
supposed to look at all controversial
items I thought
and that's where this is potentially a
controversial item I think looking
longer term we probably need to change
the planning chart if need be to make
sure that this we don't have to have
this discussion again and that we can
ask for items to come back to committee
it makes sense if the first part to me
if the first part of the planning
process I outline planning permission
comes to
committee then there's a good chance
that following
parts of the process should come back to
committee as well especially on these
large sites he can make a huge
difference
thank you thank you very much uh yes it
can and I take on board or what you're
saying but uh you know I just have to
remind you the delegation panel it does
have lots of restrictions there is only
three two of which are members and one
is an officer so I leave it there I'm
now going to go back to councilor Parker
and councilor Barrett
um would you like to make your proposal
again very clear what you want uh well
uh yeah I will in a second chair but but
if I can and I think it's important I
think it's important that this is played
out in public
um I just need to understand uh Council
Plum and yourself for both members of
the um of the dedicated decision board
um from my understanding what's being
proposed here is that um the the wishes
of the committee are being noted and
those wishes are that they would want
the conditions the discharge conditions
to be bought back before
um committee so
um the alternative to that is to as a
proposer is to say well no
um I I I don't accept that then and we
just go with the officer's
recommendation as is but that that say
that in itself seems a bit of a backward
step so I'm struggling to understand
because to be clear all that you would
be doing as a delegation panel is
deciding whether that condition can come
back before
planning committee or not is is that
correct so I just need to understand for
example with councilor Plum I need to
understand what his reservation is there
I'm not I'm not fully understanding it
right I think I'm going to ask
um Robert Carmichael to tell us what the
delegations powers are and what they can
be allowed to
discuss and put forward Robert can you
come in there and help us I think that
might help thank you
um just before we get to that point well
actually perhaps we should do it the
other way around because I was going to
do run through the um
what I've got down before members but in
essence the council as a whole has
agreed to the delegation panel being as
Mr de prey has called it the safety
valve as it were to
um to go through applications that are
called infra members that go outside of
the that are below the designated level
as outlined in the scheme of Delegation
that the council holds so that's
anything below 15 dwellings and I'm
afraid I can't remember off the top of
my head because it's not my area the
amount of floor space and there's also
one other option in there as well but
these are defined in the scheme of
Delegation
um the key point of the delegation panel
is to then work out is to have when
members call in applications
to look at them for their um whether
they are I'm afraid I haven't got the
part right in front of me at the second
is still loading the
um
impact on the district and whether that
they have significant impact going to
committee so in essence that is the
function of the delegation panel to go
before members I would also just add
um as well that Mr Isbell has the
overriding authority to bring any item
that he believes controversial to
committee so I can't obviously and we
can't let as he is not here we cannot
comment on what his thoughts would be
but there is also that mechanism as well
that I hope provides some
um
comfort for members that anything that
is extremely controversial would be come
in that point so I just apologize it's
still loading up for the um planning
chart but if I chair would you like me
to just run through what it says so that
we're all clear just please okay thank
you chair but um just just as another
very brief aside that this is the rules
of the council and we have to follow the
process as agreed by Council
um into what procedures must be followed
so the delegation panel
so officers agree so I'll read verbatim
said that we're clear officers agree not
to determine planning applications using
their delegated authority where a member
of the council requests that the
application is determined by the
planning committee where a member of the
council requests that the application is
determined by the planning committee and
the request is made in accordance with
this Charter members should discuss oh
sorry that's probably not the most
relevant part
so
find a relevant part here we are so upon
receipt of the referral request from the
board member the corporate manager or
the chief planning officer in this case
will report the call in request to the
delegation panel as soon as this
reasonably practicable the delegation
panel will comprise of the chairman and
vice chairman of the planning committee
together with the chief planning officer
um the chief planning officer will
support the panel and record its
conclusion the member making a request
will be invited to speak and the case
officer will briefly present function of
the panel is not planning decision
making but simply to decide whether the
application proceeds the determination a
planning committee or under delegation
if the panel decide that the application
does involve significant policy
consistency or other material
considerations and a decision on the
application is of more than local
significance then the application will
be reported to committee once publicity
and consultations are complete and the
application has been evaluated by
officers I hope that that provides some
clarification share and I don't know if
Mr deprove wants to comment any further
on what I've said I do have the um
The Proposal just to check as well
whenever we come back to that chair
that's very useful Mr Carmichael thank
you so so as as you've reminded us Mr is
our chief planning officer Mr Isabel has
the Constitutional authority to say
although this would normally be a
delegated decision I'm deciding is going
to committee
um I think I don't know if Mr Stroud
could just reassure us I don't think
I've not heard anything in what you've
just Mr Carl Michael has just read out
that means that the delegation panel
would somehow would really not be going
Beyond its its um
duties and responsibilities if it
decided on this special occasion given
the amount of public concern on the size
of the development that um that that
this should go to committee that says Mr
Isabel hasn't already hasn't decided any
way that he thinks he should go to
committee if you see what I mean I'm
sure your Chief planning officer will
take respectfully take note of any
resolution you pass
right
um Stephen
yes indeed and just to answer um Mr
Price question
um yes quite right and one of the key
threshold sort of tests in the
delegation panel meeting is this point
of uh more than um local significance
and and um you know without preempting
what the decision of that panel might be
um of course I think
um a whole range of
um persons have spoken today across
parishes who who may well have a case to
make that it is of greater than local
significance
um but you know I'll leave that there
right thank you I think that's clarified
quite a lot uh councilor Parker yeah
thank you it has clarified it and um and
and um actually I Echo the thoughts of
um about uh lead officer there
statements drowned in in fact so I'm
actually quite comfortable with it now
chair to be fair so you've accepted the
two amendments yeah yes sorry one
Amendment one yeah yeah yeah thank you
the best one wasn't accepted yeah
yes um yes I accept it yeah thank you uh
right okay that's um been proposed and
seconded we'll now go to the vote
um
see whether I can get on this thank you
just before we go can I just check the
wording specifically
um so that we're all in agreement before
we go any further
so I've written that application DC 2001
oh sorry 05183 be approved as detailed
in the officer of recommendation and
note the committee requests that the
construction management plan discharge
of condition come before the committee
yeah
okay councilor Parker yes I should just
acknowledge thank you councilor Barrett
yes thank you uh right uh how do you
intend to take the vote on this
um so yeah I've got that in the
modern.gov so I will open the vote and
I'll just run through
um getting there so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app and the
agenda for today if you click the Plus
in the top right hand corner it will
bring up the subsection of voting and
attendance
bear with me because I've got to log in
again which I'm doing while you're
talking okay I'll run through it again
I'll run through it again
um so if members could then please click
the voting slash attendance subsection
and then that will take you to today's
votes it will be highlighted in a light
blue color further down the page you may
need to scroll down
just let me know when you want to run
through again sure uh it says login has
failed again
right I don't look like it's going to
let me come in for some reason they'll
try it again
password
and try this
all right serve that would let me in
this time
could I just check yes I think it's
working this time uh I've got to go to
the uh today's meeting oh it's loading
up again to take a moment or two okay
Chad do you want me to take your vote
verbally
I support the
um requests to
um approve subject to the
counselor
um Parker and Barrett's
um request
thank you Jim so
with that all coming through now I can
confirm that the vote is eight votes
full with yours recorded share two
against and one abstention so the motion
is carried all right thank you
uh let me get out of this now I've got
into it
all right let's come back to the meeting
right so members
um we've taken a photo on that
um we've recommended approval subject to
the um Clause that we've or the node
that we've added to it is that correct
Robert
right so right now how are we doing for
time and where have we got to because
I've lost my agenda if you're not
getting it back up
whether I'll be pleased when we can get
back to Endeavor house and we can do it
face to face
um right
um now where are we number seven right
so uh we've finished that then members
uh but I'm trying to find the end of it
now debate
uh right
uh so we've
we've got down to it says on move and
take a break at this point uh what is
the time and now 12 39.
um do you want to take a lunch break now
and and then we'll come back and take
the I think the Victoria Hall uh Sudbury
is next
um and uh we can restart at um what
quarter past one or is is that long
enough to have a quick bite and freshen
up members over there yeah yeah so
quarter past one
um Robert is that okay with you
Rob
uh
yeah so it gives us about 35 minutes to
have a break
and that's long enough for all of you
okay we'll see you back then at um 1 15.
foreign
good afternoon members good afternoon
members of the public thank you for
being patient with us today and that uh
as many of you as possible have managed
to join us this afternoon uh I'll ask
the
um government officer Robert Carmichael
if he'll take a roll call of members
members to see that we're all present
and then we'll start on the next
application over to you Robert
thank you chair if members could please
respond
um
with their presence so councilor Suites
good afternoon I'm here Council Melanie
Barrett
present Council David Busby yeah Pastor
John Hinton yeah Council Lee Jameson
yeah
that's a Mary McLaren present
Pastor Adrian Osborne
present without dessert
councilor Alice knowing
yeah here Council Lee Parker
present and
counselor Stephen Plus president thank
you chair we're all here um for the next
well done I've got Lee Parker wrote big
letters in front of me but uh you you've
got him in this time so that's brilliant
Robert okay thank you very much well
members um we're back and all present
now so we'll make a start we're on DC
stroke 19 stroke zero four eight two
nine Victoria Hall conservative Club New
Street 39 and 41 Prince Street New
Street Sudbury
um I think before I ask the case officer
Linda baton to take to go through it I
think
um yes we can't hear you and Mark
Russell
um but the legal officer sorry chair
it's myself that's presenting it Linda's
not here
right sorry I'll contact them
um I'll ask the legal
um and to
um run through a little statement
regarding the conservative Club I think
you were going to point out a few facts
oh yeah um oh yes indeed I'm simply
going to repeat the advice I gave on the
an earlier occasion that it's a stately
obvious this is a conservative club and
some of you happen to be conservative
counselors but the applicant is not the
concern Services party does not and the
old Northern nor is the owner as far as
I can of the whole site as far as I can
tell from the papers and it does not
appear to me that any member of the
committee who happens to be a
conservative should be embarrassed
purely by that fact of course all
members should be mindful of their duty
to consider whether they're having a
declarable interest in respect to every
application but not not simply from the
the fact that part of this site includes
a former conservative club which I
understand anyway has not been so used
for about four or five years at least
that that's correct I was a member when
it was open that must have closed about
19 the
2013-14 now hasn't been conservative
Club since then to mine knowledge anyway
um so okay members on that the case
officer now is Mark Russell so over to
you
thank you chair I will now share
hopefully the presentation bear with me
please
[Music]
can everybody see that
yep
okay I'll be brief chair because members
have had a long day and um you've had
you've heard this before so I'll press
on uh this uh is a proposal for the
partial Demolition and demolition of
buildings
um at the site you've just described
Victoria Hall conservative Club New Hall
in the center of Sudbury uh members
deferred this
um sorry and the other half is then
build some residential units and um a
studio
members defer this on 9th of September
for the reasons you can see in front of
you which involved a structural report
and viability assessment
um for the conservative Club facade to
be retained and if not then to be
replicated
um and for changes to design such as
removal of hips and looking at a single
pitch roof and different materials
uh remind members that the site is in
the middle of Sudbury
um as shaded here
and in terms of constraints it's within
sudbury's Conservation Area there are a
few listed buildings over to the east
but generally the pattern is of older
buildings which are deemed locally
listable you can see it's a mix of
others that aren't but there's several
in the blue which are locally listed our
site is the hatched area in the middle
and that contains three locally listed
buildings
um just to clarify the red line you can
see it goes hard up against those
properties to the east
just to clarify how the site Works um
the yellow and blue buildings have over
time become merged as one but there is a
linking element or linking elements
um and the red building is New Hall
those are the three buildings we're
talking about that is the site
there was an earlier permission for
conversion
um so just to let you know that that
link there was part of the um to be
removed was part of the earlier
permission and this was in 2017 so there
is a permission which is just about X
stand for residential use of the site
and there is a block plan
um so it's not the block plan is not
much different to that which has been
proposed now apart from the fact that
the southern aspect of New Hall is
proposed to be removed
our site plan before us today is as I
have described so you can see the
buildings that we know well
um in their form at least so to the
South is the current conservative Club
um which is tabled for removal and
replacement
um the smaller building on the western
aspect over to the left is Victoria Hall
which is tabled for demolition apart
from the facade
and these slim building uh in the middle
is New Hall which is tabled for
retention other than one third of it
being or 30 of it being removed three of
three of three of The Bays being removed
and all of these are to go over to
residential apart from one part of New
Hall which would be a an artist studio
so um many of you know will know these
buildings very well but just for those
who don't
um this is the conservative Club aspect
as you can see there are three elements
there are two historic houses there and
a third historic house to the right so
three buildings which gives it its
complicated form that we see on the
planets
other aspects of it just to give you
some um context
and this is the mill building which is
um a slightly a long new street from the
conservative Club this is a tall locally
listed building um which has been
described in some consultation responses
so there's new Street you can see the
gulp brick
and that's looking down to the Prince of
Wales Pub
I'll flick through and won't tell you
about every building a drawing because
it'll go on forever but you get a
feeling
um this is Victoria Hall with its um
very um distinctive Frontage and uh
somewhat more blank Frontage over to the
right there
and the proposal is to retain the facade
of this
so here's New Hall
um you can see it's a long building and
three of the bays are tabled for removal
as as described to facilitate access and
parking
the applicant has provided some of these
photographs and including the inside of
the building which is very helpful
there's also a video but it's too memory
hungry and it goes on for cumulative
eight minutes so let's not do that let's
just look at the Stills which I think do
tell the story
um you can see the building obviously
has fallen into
um
disuse
not as loved as it was once
and the applicant has provided in a
structural survey update to suggest that
the the weather is now getting inside as
well and and therefore some of the the
Timbers are rotten there's the bar
um and that's added to the tale of the
building's um poor state of repair
U-Haul again might be some repetition
here all around there's a little bit of
demolition to the right of of
um of the conservative club which
obviously is not very slightly at the
moment
that I think there's a linking element
between the two buildings I described
which has been partially removed
so that was what it looks like on the
ground just to go back to what we've got
so far we've got those three buildings
and to emphasize the scale of demolition
which is proposed it's roughly this
um the white areas of those which are to
be removed so as you can see part of New
Hall
um all of the conservative club and all
of um Victoria Hall apart from the
facade
so in terms of drawings we've got some
some handy drawings here you can see New
Hall at the top there and Victoria Hall
as we've just seen
and this is the conservative club with
its three rangers which um step down to
the right
now these um were the drawings which
were brought to you in September and I
would draw your attention to the ringed
elements those are the ones which you
flagged up basically the smaller circles
are the hips
um the one on conservative building at
the front is is the facade of that which
members felt was not in keeping and
should be looked at and changed and
preserved if possible but if not then
certainly replicated and you also asked
to check whether a single pitched roof
instead of the double pile on the right
there would look better
um the applicant has provided this and
our viewers offices is to um the massing
is not acceptable it's overspanned uh
the pitch is quite slack albeit that it
does actually mimic that of of um
of um Victoria Hall around the side
okay so the amended drawing which is
showing
some of the things you asked for is here
so the hips have gone
and the facade of the conservative Club
is a lot better
so these are the proposed amended
elevations
officers do have concerns about the
range over to the right still the double
piled range um it's better than doing it
as a single pitch but it's still a lot
of building and it does compete with the
mill building over to the right now to
remind you none of these buildings are
listed
many of them are locally listed in a
conservation area so we do have to
consider Heritage matters and we have
our heritage expert um Dr Jonathan duck
here who did his doctor at Leicester
University in these matters so he's Keen
to provide you with any information you
want on on these matters
the applicant kindly provided
um a financial appraisal and I've given
you just a very quick summary of what it
what it came to basically the applicant
is saying that
um a knock down and rebuild as described
would bring a profit of about 3.3
million which equals about
um 16 17 which
um you know slightly below the industry
standard but this is heritage site
um but if they were to repair refurbish
convert
um as describe the report that would
actually lead to a loss that was the
applicant's um summary of things we
haven't had that checked and tested um
but there is a concern that other
options maybe haven't been looked at
um the um so I go back to that the
um
built building rigs for older buildings
can be relaxed for matters of thermal
property for noise transfer in fact
pretty much anything apart from fire
secret you can have lower building rigs
if it's a Heritage building and I'm
showing these next pictures because they
have been supplied by an objector just
to demonstrate some of the buildings in
Sudbury which have been converted rather
than being knocked down so that's that's
just for the record you know how it can
be done obviously all buildings have
different properties but that's how it
can be done and they've also asked if we
could just look at this as an example of
how facade can be wonderfully restored
so if you were to agree with the facade
being removed for Victoria Hall it
should be this good but obviously the
preference is that it's kept
hmm
so the key issues are the fact that
quite a bit of demolition is proposed
these are non-designated Heritage assets
but they do have an effect on Sudbury
Conservation area which is itself a
Heritage asset
um other matters in terms of amenity
highway safety Etc would be tend to be
side issues which have not been
identified as being crucial to
consideration here the the gross issue
of land use is completely acceptable
it's a sustainable location there's some
parking it's in the middle of Sudbury
it's a good place to put residential
development we have no issues with this
whatsoever but we are concerned about
the um the loss of of historic fabric
so for that reason and notwithstanding
the fact that members didn't uh instruct
us one way or the other are
recommendation at the moment still is
that this should be refused because of
the extensive sets of Demolition and the
fact that
um the justification has not been
properly provided and also that the
replacement building to the right is is
out of keeping with the conservation
area and is not acceptable thank you
chair
thank you very much for that uh members
is there any points of clarification
that you would like by the case officer
counselor Adrian Osborne
yes thank you Mr chairman um yes I would
just um first of all when when we go if
we go back and turn in this life could
have been made a bit bit larger
particularly the ones that show the uh
um the overall picture of the of the
site because they're very small on the
on the on the screen for me
um the the point of clarification is is
what I uh I'm I'm confused in the
structural engineers report that is on
page 47.
and in fact um the question
is
um we've had the structural engineers
report and the concepts of which we
should take into consideration
but on on paragraph two this is where
the confusion lies is this is the is
this the officer's view or is it the
engineers structural report view because
it seems to me that they've they seem a
bit mixed
it seems clear to me yes yeah have you
got that bit uh page 47 yeah Mark could
you tell me the paragraph sorry I've got
different documents you haven't got the
oh Structural Engineers report and it's
the second paragraph in there and it
starts it seems clear to me
uh could you give me the paragraph
numbers go against it no it doesn't oh
you've got a paragraph page three I'll
read it out to you then okay it seems
clear to me that the cost is a factor in
the retention of these buildings which
include the non-designated Heritage
asset known as the Victoria Hall got it
got it sorry yes that that is yeah if
you look above that I mean yes fair
enough in terms of formatting it's
probably not clear but that is the
Heritage team's response to the
structural engineers report Ah that's
Heritage that's not right yeah so so the
the hair the engineering structural
report is just that first paragraph is
it now if you go further up
um it says internal Consulting responses
and then its heritage's turn to say what
they think and they say what they think
about the structural engineers report
so the comment on the structural
engineers report yes by the Heritage
officer
so which bit is the actual Structural
Engineers report just that first
paragraph no no that's that's um that's
elsewhere in the report chair
no it's covered in the report itself let
me find a paragraph for you
okay if you go to um
if you go to paragraph 2.5
we haven't got two point values
give us the page number well it's page
16 of my report sorry I didn't realize
that I thought one Italian for the other
leftover modern golf sorry
things opening my screen at the same
time sorry not very well handled no
um 2.5 chair is uh shown on page 60 of
our report it's page 60. thank you very
much councilor Parker
uh 59
and so
so that now there's paragraphs 2.5 you
say
2.6 2.5 almost yeah
2.7 I think there's the financial
viability appraisal
yeah I mean 2.5 Begins the commentary on
it but yeah can I ask councilor Osborne
you know I I don't know whether this
helps us or not
well no it's just it's just it was just
confusing because they talk about
Structural Engineers report I mean quite
kind of with you it seems to me a bit
badly laid out and and with the uh with
Mark uh having to uh tell us that it's
on a different page uh you know the
whole thing
doesn't seem to doesn't seem totally
does it well I have to say sorry that
the basically the the financial
considerations is is in the body of the
report it's it's not a consultation
response quantity responses come to
start the report as I always do and the
structural appraisal is part of the
report and the analysis which is in the
usual place
so the structural engineers report which
is to demolish I I'm assuming yeah um is
is in that first paragraph on page 47
and then the comment from uh Heritage
Department uh which is the second
paragraph there is sort of in answer to
that no well if you if you look all of
it all of it is is the um Heritage
response all of it is Heritage response
even the first paragraph yep internal
Consulting response Heritage team
comments structure engineers in response
to a repressive LBA blah blah right a
structure engineering report was
submitted and drafted and then so where
is the structural engineers report that
councilor Osborne wants to look at well
it's it's it's on the website it's part
of the submitted documents and it's also
quoted um in places amongst the
financial analysis on paragraph 2.5
onwards
well it's obviously in in opposition to
demolition in it so I think you'll have
to uh look at it like that counselor I
was born
uh
right let me just catch up with it
um
right so any other a counselor Barrett
you're next
thank you thank you yes on that
structure report I thought that when we
heard this in September we felt that we
wanted
um a a proper structural report but I
note that the ones that have been quoted
are quoted from July previous July and
previous February so there hasn't been a
news structural report since this would
referred back that there was an addendum
to it which I quoted which referred to
that the weather and the rotting of the
of the floorboards Etc so it was an
update on that I'm saying sorry and
saying the photographs you could see
that uh yeah it's in a sorry state of
repairs sort of in yep yeah
all right because I think we'll have to
take it as that uh any other comments
members
any other points of clarification off
the top off the top of your screen Mr
chairman yeah uh when I've got counselor
uh McCann next Mary yeah thank you chair
um can I just ask Mark a question is
this the only application that there has
been for development that there's been
for this site or is this just one in a
long line of them
um there was the permission that was
granted in um 20 it was a 2016
application it was Grant in 2017. I
don't think there's been one
subsequently there has been a
pre-application but not an application
as well I was just wondering if there'd
been lots of people interested in this
site no this is the same I think isn't
it same people it's it's the same
application yeah
I understood that but I just wondered
historically if there had been an
interest from other
parties and other developer
developers um not that I'm aware of but
um obviously you could speak to the
applicant in a minute about whether okay
thank you good question Mary to put to
him uh councilor Hinton
foreign
just a couple of points really on
clarification
um firstly on page 47 County Council
responses uh no means of sustainable
traveling Alternatives travel to where
Town Center you're in the Town Center so
do they actually know where this site is
I'm sure they're doing that and the
second and the second point is on the
the cost options option one
uh talks about protect income at 2525
triple o thoughts about expenditure at
one nine six three seven five oh
um but
they don't add up because 1963 750 if
you take off two two six five eight six
three eighteen hundred five sorry
eighteen thousand five oh eight triple o
and three five two five oh take all
those figures add those figures together
they come to more than one nine six
three so one of those must be a negative
but I fail to see which one is Page 61
members
thank you Council I better check that
haven't I it doesn't add up
unless it's adding up to what they want
it to be well
they'll look into that while we're
talking uh right any other points of
clarification to the case officer
no
I see no hands up so we'll move on
um right public speaking
uh
as far as I'm aware we don't have a
representative from the Town Council
and no one's jumping up and down sound
they are from it right
so but we do have an objector Simon
Harris you sir have three minutes in
which to address the committee perhaps
you'd like to put your camera on and
your bike on and when you're ready Sir
Robert will give time you the three
minutes and at the end of it I'll see if
there's any questions for you thank you
over to you thank you chair good
afternoon can you hear me and see me yes
I can thank you very much
um I'm speaking on behalf of the subway
Society I'm depicted to the chairman of
the planning committee of the society
um I I'm not here to object
wholeheartedly to these proposals but to
propose the society's thinking on how to
handle each of these separate buildings
because it's high time something was
settled as we've heard today from the
case officer the condition the buildings
can only get worse
but these buildings are of course in the
conservation area they're on the local
list and in that respect they're not
unlike Bellevue house itself which is
not even in the conservation area most
of the council is Keen to retain
we understand the need for financial
viability for structural viability and
we are not ourselves calling for the
whole self-preservation of all three
structures
if I could take them one by one
the society believes that if it helps to
make the site more accessible more
habitable to remove a piece of New Hall
doesn't destroy its original
architectural and Industrial character
so provided that um it's an essential
part of the site plan we would not and
we would withdraw any objection we've
lodged against that
Victoria Hall by contrast that's a bit
of a nightmare the interior and this
structure are in very poor State the
floor levels are all over the place and
it makes a very difficult building
to make into residential accommodation
and so we would support the idea of
retaining the facade not facsimile
please but to retain it this is a brick
building town and there are skills and
materials available locally to make that
facade a genuine restoration rather than
a facsimile
behind whatever residential uses is put
to the space
but it's the conservative Club buildings
itself where we would urge the committee
to draw the line
the frontage is of a character in scale
that enhances the Conservation Area
the Heritage officer the Suffolk
preservation Society have all challenged
the engineers assumptions that the
building is not structurally viable
it's simply not true to say the
foundations are too weak to support
restoration
and as we've seen in the photographs
from the case officer buildings like
this can and have been very successfully
converted to meet modern needs some
Leonards walnut tree are prime examples
the developers there could have argued
for demolition if you said no and the
results are very satisfying their
adornments to the town and so could this
building be
and finally there's the question of
precedent
retaining the club May cost more
than restoring it but a great deal of
planning matter is is decided by
precedent and if you allow the
destruction of a significant building in
a on the local list in a Conservation
Area
what signal does that send to
protect other buildings elsewhere in the
town thank you very much
thank you um thank you
excuse me I'll say if there's any
questions uh to Mr Harris
um members do you have any points of
clarification that you wish to ask
um councilor McCarron
uh thank you chair thank you Mr Harris
um I appreciated uh your comments
because it was my mind was really drawn
to the fact that these three buildings
are integral to the history of Sudbury
and Subway
um people think very strongly about
their town
my question to you is why has nobody
Within
the boundaries of sobri be that
yourselves or the Town Council
considered making this site a heritage
site or a center that can be used for
the people of Sudbury who are retaining
with obviously different Renovations but
retaining these buildings because these
buildings seem to me to be integral to
your history
thank you thank you for the question
would you like me to answer now yes
please
um our view is that the desire to
restore a conservative Club as a club
and a Victoria Hall as a hall and a new
Hall is a factory uh uh Wishful beyond
the possibilities of today's housing
needs and if you tried to do it it would
fail whereas I think the case office has
made the case that they are
they would make very good residential
accommodation provided that the scale
and appearance was consistent with their
parts thank you thank you Mr Harris
thank you chair thank you uh councilor
Busby
thank you
it may be that what you want is not
financially viable and in which case you
might be left with the applicant
withdrawing and the buildings go into
even further disrepair would it not be
better to be pragmatic and say
let's knock them down and rebuild in in
the style that the buildings were and
have something that looks acceptable and
has a future
yes we are concerned about financial
viability which is why we made the
suggestions about conceding on New Hall
conceding on Victoria Hall and
concentrating only on the retention of
the conservative Club buildings which
are generally savable
and I don't think that that the careful
program of that kind could be
financially non-viable
thank you
any other questions member of clarity
no thank you thank you Mr Harris we'll
move on I'll know
um go to
the agent
um Nick pleaseland you have three
minutes sir in which to address the
committee
okay can you hear me okay I can hear you
I can't see you yet it hasn't started so
you're right yep now I can see you yeah
okay I can hear you so when you start
okay you've got three minutes good
afternoon chairman and members of the
committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to address you today as
you're aware this application was
reported to the planning committee on
the 9th of September 2020 at that time
the development management planning
officer presented the application to the
committee outlining in full The Proposal
with four members the layout and
location of the site and the officer
recommendation development management
planning office and responded to members
questions on issues including how long
the existing properties have been
unoccupied the color of the building
materials and the surrounding properties
and whether the previous planning
information on the site had elapsed
members debated at length the
application on issues including the
Heritage comments the non-listed
building status of the existing
properties the poor condition of the
existing buildings on site the building
designing context with the area and the
facades of the buildings
the committee at that time were broadly
supported of The Proposal but resolved
to defer a decision on the application
until such time that additional
information had been submitted
comprising of a structural viability
report and assessment together
withdrawing showing amendments to the
fenestration of the elevation fronting
New Street the members agreed that they
wanted to see some small changes to the
design including removal of hips the
addition of first floor bay windows to
replicate those in the existing
conservative Club facade fronting New
Street the use of a single pitch roof
over unit 5 and 6 and different
materials all of the information
requested by the members was prepared
and resubmitted by the applicant on the
4th of November 2020. this included
amended drawings with the design and
materials changed in accordance with the
members comments with additional
elevations showing a comparison between
the single pitch roof over the
three-story element unit five and six
requested by the committee members and
the double pitch roof originally
proposed it also included a full
viability studying cost analysis
prepared by Apex CM project consultants
and quantity surveyors which compared
construction costs for the scheme with
comparison made for both Demolition and
convergence supported by a financial
viability appraisal prepared by Percival
and Company
this viability assessment and financial
appraisal categorically conclude that
due to the poor structural condition of
the existing building the Demolition and
rebuild is the only viable and practical
option for this site
the committee report presented to the
members today contains subsequent
comments to the revised proposal from
the Heritage team we understand that the
Heritage officer dealing with the
proposal has now left the council we
also understand that the Heritage
officer that has taken over the
application has not had the benefit
without accessing the site for
themselves which is a concern Nicholas
jobert the applicant's historic building
consultant has provided a response to
the subsequent comments from the
Heritage team with regard to the
interpretation of power 197 of the mppf
relating to non-designated Heritage
assets which we understand is now
included within the table papers
notwithstanding this our understanding
is that you are not here today to draw
back through the application proposal of
the game you are here to assess the
revised and additional information
requested by members in support of The
Proposal with the intention of obtaining
planning permission to enable this
unsightly site and regenerate it thank
you thank you thank you very much for
that yes I think uh I I just want to ask
a question before I ask members
um you're under the impression that
we've asked you to come back purely on
the double hit bit and the facade in New
in New Street
um because uh certainly the the
photographs that were shown show it in
very poor condition and and what have
you
um but so you've you've come back and
you've answered the the three points
given us the opportunity of a one pitch
or reverting back to the two pitch is
that correct yeah I mean we provided the
information that the members requested
at the previous committee meeting
um and on that basis that's what we
understand what's being um reviewed
today that's right yes that's my
understanding I think thank you uh I've
got penciler Osborne followed by cancer
Jameson
your question counselor Osborne thank
you yeah thank you Mr chairman um I'd
just like to ask um Mr paisland um
if um
if he was able to and I might assuming
that he would actually put the frontage
correctly as as to um make the uh
Heritage setup of that building be
almost the same and in fact reflecting
back on the fire of a house in uh or a
shop and and flats in um in Friar Street
uh is he prepared to put it back to
those type of uh Heritage assets
well as you're already aware we were
part of the scheme retains the whole
elevation fronting print Street of
Victoria Hall
so uh so it answer you're saying that
the the Princess Street which is the
Victoria Hall entrance side uh would be
retained absolutely New Street which is
what I call the entrance used by the
conservative club members that's correct
uh which
um
I have to say in my opinion don't give
me any cause for wanting to save any of
that because it doesn't look right or
anything but that aside
um that would be put back with bay
windows and some sort of character
keeping is that correct yes yes I mean
my understanding yes thank you does that
help you yes indeed yeah thank you Mr
pigland that um actually
um gives me a a better a better Outlook
now on on what it was and with your new
Arrangements that you that the uh the
committee asked for on the last uh
deferral when we deferred it uh he's
actually brought that into perspective
thank you thank you uh I've got
counselor Jameson
um I can see before you start constant
emson uh Mark Russell uh can your point
weight or do you need to just clarify
something in case we're going to repeat
ourselves
just a brief point of clarification okay
previous officer was Caroline ipperman
who's now left um but Jonathan duck was
her effectively line manager so being
involved with the case from the word go
and knows the site very well I don't
think he's been inside to inspect but he
knows where the site is and he's been
involved from the beginning I think most
members know the site very well yeah
okay uh councilor Jameson thanks thanks
a lot
um I'm just wondering
um is there any what is the reason
behind not using the same style of brick
currently in place at the conservative
Club rather than going for a more modern
rendered look is there a reason for that
well back at the last committee meeting
um there was a quite an in-depth
discussion on materials
um and the members resolved to request a
gold brick and some various amendments
to the materials which we've provided in
line with their with their comments so
you know I mean that didn't come up at
the last um at the last meeting oh I
wasn't at the last meeting
thank you
for Jameson
um right councilor Parker
no question yeah sorry sorry getting
there hello Nick good afternoon hello
hello uh just just um some clarification
um Nick if you will because the previous
speaker Mr Harris
um talked about the facade being
retained
um not being a facsimile
um are you saying that it won't be a
facsimile and it you know it'll be
retained Brick by Brick is is that what
you're saying first question yeah the
the facade um to the Victoria Hall
exactly that yes
okay all right and and can I ask a
second uh yes please do something right
um and again just referring back to um
to Mr Harris's comments uh Mr Harris is
of the opinion that the existing
foundation of the the Kong Club the
former con Club is inadequate
um but I uh sorry I think he says that
it is adequate
um and yet you you say differently
according to your structural engineer
now it's probably a question for the
officer really more than anything but
can I just have your comments on that
Nick absolutely yes now this is where we
we come back to nobody having the
opportunity because of obviously the the
um the period of time we've been with
through covid of there being a science
inspection but you clearly you can see
from the photographs contained within
the structural report that there are no
foundations to the building and um yeah
you know it would be to everyone's
benefit to have a walk around inside
this building because I mean everybody
can see it from the outside and it looks
in a pretty poor state of repair but
once you get inside it's it's a hundred
times worse and now literally are no
foundations and if you look back through
the structural report you'll see
photographs of that with the evidence
okay take your name thank you chair can
I just comment Council Parker that uh in
my days of going into the conservative
Club I can remember once we got into the
Victoria Hall near the rear uh there was
constant flood and dampness and many a
lot of money was spent trying to solve
that problem whether they ever did or
not I I just don't know can't remember
but uh certainly I would say the state
inside is really popular
but then others know it as well as I do
uh councilor Barrett
thank you um good afternoon
um Mr President
um good afternoon I'm just intrigued by
the different treatment to the frontages
so proposing to retain the red brick uh
exterior of Victoria Hall
um which looks like a soft red brick to
me
um so it shows quite a lot of wear and
tear on that exterior as opposed to not
being able to retain the white brick
um on the other side of the development
which is a much harder brick
um and also can I just add on to that
the figures that we've been presented in
our report on the sort of projected
sales
um sort of backing up the viability of
rebuild are those figures supplied by
you your your applicant
well they've commissioned somebody to
look at it and Supply the information
they'd say pick cm and their project
consultants and um quantity surveyors
that are working independently
right okay and do you have any comment
on the bricks because I was rather
impressed that councilor Barrett knew
soft and uh uh odd ones I know what a
soft ready is but uh I would have lost
with the others well if you if you
remember uh Council about when we when
we were back at the last committee
meeting we discussed the brickwork and
um you know it was agreed that we would
change to a gold brick on the elevation
facing uh Prince Street
um but as I say it was that that stage
we it was resolved subject to the change
of materials as requested which we've
come back with
um it would be acceptable
um
sorry does that answer my question
I'm sorry but you will you will replace
the red brick element at the uh not not
of the um Victoria Hall because you're
you're saying it's going to be yeah
this is for the um yeah sorry New Street
not print Street that's my mistake I
meant New Street on Prince Street
all right
there as well well done
uh any other questions
for clarification yes please uh sorry
who's that come to the Busby yes
oh sorry
um I've got I'll come to your next
counselor plan I'm very sorry about that
councilor Busby
yeah I'm concerned that we're trying to
make a silk purse out of a sales air
here and I wonder whether have you
have you presented what you consider to
be a silk purse if you we are allowed to
demolish the whole lot and start again
yes yeah we're coming forward with a
proposal which we think is uh is right
for the site
um and it's going to regenerate this end
of North Street which is in desperate
need of of of something being uh done to
to bring it to back to life
but it's your design reflects what was
there before
rather than have a fresh thought on it
sorry say that again you'll do your
current design what you're proposing is
aiming to reflect
that what was there before the history
of that particular site rather than
necessarily saying well let's scrap that
and start a fresh yeah yeah but when
we're retaining as I said as I've just
said we're retaining part of the of the
facade of the existing buildings facing
um print Street and also the
um obviously replicating
um first of all bay windows in the
elevation facing
um new streets and also
um with the the three-story element at
the end uh mirroring the mill building
which is next to it yeah well I'll hear
what you say I just think it's going to
be another hodgepodge I would have been
interested to see a fresh thought on the
whole thing without the constraints that
were there
but those were those restraints I think
that we asked him to go away I know but
I'm still not convinced that we're
coming up with anything which is
actually going to deliver what we really
want or well what could be delivered if
we had a fresh start
well I mean I'll go back to what I what
I said in my in my presentation you know
we had the conversation at committee
last time and it was resolved it's
subject to some amendments to the design
and they were quite specific amendments
um we would bring it back to committee
and it to have those assessed thank you
uh thank you thank you councilor Busby
councilor plum
thank you chair uh Mr peasland a simple
question you you you said we were
missing out because we haven't had the
site visited are you willing are you
willing to defer until such time as we
can have a site visit when you wait
it depends how long we need to wait for
because we wait too long the building
won't be there it'll fall down so
um I mean it's difficult isn't it
because I really do 100 believe that if
members were to see the building
internally they'd have a very different
view
um as as to as to you know as to what
can be done with it
thank you
I I I think the view from both yourself
Mr President and from
um the councilor plan
um can be applied to all applications at
the moment because we're in that
situation
um so we'll move on I've got councilor
Barrett
okay
that's God uh no other questions then to
the agent applicant
nope thank you very much thank you thank
you uh we'll now uh go to the ward
member councilor Jan Osborne new Madam
have five minutes in which to address
the committee
thank you and good afternoon Mr chairman
of members again from this morning site
referred to in this application has been
standing empty for several years and
it's become a real eyesore in our
Sudbury members there is an opportunity
with this application to at long last
improve the appearance of this site for
both our residents and visitors to our
town
the application states that both the
Victoria Hall and the conservative Club
is on a local list but apart from the
bay windows and the large cast iron
plaque there is no real significant
value compared to the benefits that this
development would bring to the town to
quote part of the listing the lower
story has become very cluttered and the
soft red brick generally is in poor
condition and it needs a sympathetic new
owner indeed in my view this application
is sympathetic to both the area and the
site
when this application came to the
planning committee last September
several suggestions were put forward by
members of the committee including
retention of the bay windows which has
now been agreed in this application
page 47 of your report makes reference
to the structural engineers report also
requested by the planning committee
together with some changes to the design
which again have been done
could I bring to your attention the
response from Sudbury Town Council to
quote approve in principle with this
development Town councilors felt that
the proposed brickwork that faces
directly onto New Street should be
sympathetic and in keeping with the
existing Street Scene for example white
buff brick and slate tiles they also
felt that the proposed design of the
properties on the existing conservative
Club should resemble the site's history
unquote
of course I am sympathetic to the view
expressed with reference to the history
of these buildings but a balance between
this and the benefits of this
application is key to your decision and
I am confident that members will see
that the balance is on the side of the
benefits and far outweigh any Heritage
concerns raised today and previously
if this application is not given
approval there is a real risk that the
site will remain in its current rundown
state or worse for many more years to
come and members let's bear in mind no
other interest has been shown on this
site
I strongly request that members give
this application due consideration about
the benefits that will come from this
application rather than trying to
protect a building that is already in a
state of bad disrepair thank you Mr
chairman
thank you very much
um members have you any questions to
counselor Jan Osborne
no that's fine thank you we'll move on
the other award member which is
counselor Trevor Creswell
um you sir had five minutes in which to
address the committee
cancel request well
it's not present I'm going to share
again I don't want to make the same
mistake as last time that's fine um but
I did get him there was a message put in
the chat um just before the lunch break
the council cressel said he had to leave
but I will just double check yeah yes I
did see that I did see that
um the attendance to make sure
it doesn't look like he is here chair
I'll call him once more just to make
sure counselor Trevor Creswell are you
present just the ward member to speak on
this application
I'll take that as a no that you're not
present thank you we'll move on
so we now get into debate
uh members who would like to start this
um well I suppose I have to go to
counselor Suez
would you like to start no thank you I'm
sitting and see what the others have to
say right okay
uh any any
oh well I suppose oh cancel about it
you've come over yeah
um
I think it was councilor Hinton who
queried the figures earlier I've just
had a quick look I can't really
understand it perhaps someone can give
us the bottom line really on that yes
that's a good point uh officers uh Mark
can you um answer that question there if
you had a little while to look into it
yeah I have and I agree they don't they
don't add up um it's been embarrassing
um obviously not my figures from the
applicant um so I don't know why they
don't add up but I think if you look at
the conclusion the applicant is saying
that the knock down rebuild will Garner
a reasonable profit not an unreasonable
profit but you know an industry standard
profit and to do otherwise to try and
retain make good would actually be any
negative so that that's what their claim
is but yeah you write the figures don't
add up so these are figures submitted by
the applicant or or somebody
um on their behalf with the applicant is
that correct
these are not our figures no these are
taken by Linda um from the
um analysis and put into
um
they're not nothing to do with the
applicant speakers no no they are no no
Linda has taken the applicants figures
well I could ask and I'll ask legal
um to ask the agent whether he can
comment on that where it's legal good
idea hello it's I'm legal advice myself
visible
um yes I I was yes indeed it was in my
mind to say well we didn't ask so we
might have asked the agent to question
about this and I suppose it was still
with the officers it would sing to me
although they think they've had their
chance it would only be fair to ask the
agency there's any comment now if he if
he has got it in comment if he hasn't he
hasn't he hasn't
um Mr
um peasland
is that correct yes
um are you still with us
yes it's coming up good uh are you quite
happy to take this question to try and
answer uh you're muted at the moment
so we can't hear you
first of all will you be quite happy to
take a question uh on the on the um
these figures yes I will and just hang
on I'll get I'll get the officer the
um councilor Barrett to ask the question
again and then you can try and answer it
for us councilor Barrett
yeah um I was just just had a quick look
at as it was highlighted earlier um and
it was 61 sorry for that just just be
interesting to know you know your bottom
line is that you've given a figure of um
expenditure against income but that
doesn't seem to correspond with the
figures Earl uh and I've I've just
provided I've just obtained
clarification on that and that is the
the the figure is actually incorrect the
total figure of 1963 750 is incorrect
that should actually be two eight two
seven one one three
can you can you just say that a little
bit slower
1963750 is wrong it's wrong give us the
figure please two eight two seven one
one three two seven one one three yeah
which is which is what that adds up to
when you've got selling costs site
acquisition expenditure to date and the
build cost and then if you take that
figure the predicted income away from
the expenditure you're left with the
three
02113 that's the figure of two five two
five is that correct that's it that's it
I've got it even I've managed to work
that out now
so yes there is an incorrect figure in
there I apologize for that
well done members who picked it up
um cheers yes counselor Barrett did you
want to come back
[Music]
um
I think Mr paisland we've finished you
thank you very much
um right I see it other hand uh Steve
and Strode
yes thank you chair
um and I wasn't at the previous
committee so in effect I'm coming to
this fresh and I've read the papers and
um didn't spot the uh the typer and the
figures but I think it's the outcome is
a little bit more serious than than Mr
peasland has set out because of course
that residual is not a profit
um this is also a loss making scheme
when you deduct the expenditure from the
projected income
so I think what what you are in effect
left with is the fact that they've tried
two options which may not be the only
options and both of them are unviable so
the you've got two choices I think
members you either give very little
weight to this letter because quite
clearly there's a fundamental flaw in it
or you you look at it and say well
actually the developer it seems is
themselves progressing a scheme that by
their own account is unviable and
therefore it may simply
um be a question here members of looking
at the harm that this development itself
proposes on its face and weigh that
against the benefits because we actually
have the optimum Bible use here or
indeed a viable use thank you for that
members will have to worry that point up
councilor Parker
thank you chair and
um oh sorry am I there yeah yes I am the
perfect segue there um by statement
Stroud um into
um harm so um I was going to see if we
could um perhaps bring in Dr duck if
he's if he's here or Heritage
um at this point because
this is really tricky chair
um this this application on on the one
hand I think paragraph 10.1 in the
conclusion on page 66 is a slam dunker
um uh you know and it talks about
um that the harm and the fact that
actually the is there a benefit
um from the additional housing because
we do already benefit from quite a
healthy five-year land Supply so
therefore I think Stephen is absolutely
right
um it principally comes down to um the
reasons given in the recommendation for
refusal around the harm
um and so I would like some
clarification because uh to my mind all
over the um that we want to talk about
low to medium level of less than
substantial harm in paragraph 10.1 we
introduced the word demonstrable harm so
I'm not sure where that sits in the
hierarchy
um but the problem is if if we if we
don't go against officer's
recommendation and and support this
application
um
that's going to stand there for years
derelict so this this really is a tricky
one um chair so I haven't got anything
to um to add for that or to that at this
at this particular time just adding to
the debate but I'd like to hear really
the um uh the Heritage officer's
recommendation on uh for me I I need to
know a little bit more about the
non-designated Heritage asset and do we
treat that in precisely the same way as
we would with a with a normal listed
building
um so because I think I think that's
going to steer us thanks Jeff uh thank
you councilor Parker it's a good point
you've got two points there Dr duck can
you respond to this but on those two
points rather than complicate and
confuse the issue at this stage
that is a difficult one yes appreciated
um yes non-designated assets are
obviously of a lower designation they
are not protected by central government
they are however something that we as
legal authorities uh should take
um
we should be we should be sentient of
these
um or cognizant of buildings that are
not designated if they are considered
locally listed
um and the Sudbury Society has a local
list which is amended in 2018 it does
include all three buildings it includes
New Hall conservative club and Victoria
Hall they are all here on the listing so
while they're not statutorily designated
they are protected in so far as they
have been given a a status above those
buildings which have no other protection
and they contribute to the importance of
the town and of course they are all
within the conservation area and the
conservation area itself is a designated
asset so
some people put a spectrum on things in
terms of the importance of assets and
they start with world heritage sites a
conservation area can be as important as
listed buildings and because they are
designated by government or or they have
the designation
mechanism is is created by central
government so Sudbury is a conservation
area it is a not it is a designated
asset the building's within it that
we're talking about are a lower level of
importance but nevertheless they are
important because they are locally
listed by the Sudbury Society the
buildings here are industrial buildings
and and Leisure buildings in a Suburban
setting and that's quite traditional in
Victorian Urban extensions so we have
the we have you know a Leisure Center or
a Leisure Hall a club and a an
industrial building the new Hall
uh so they they do contribute quite
significantly to the the Victorian
development of this part of the Town
um and and because they are they are in
the in the setting of uh various other
non-designated assets they have they
have an overlaid sort of um their
settings overlay each other and so
they're all they all add to each other's
story so they they're important is
Amplified by their neighbors so the new
Hall and the conservative Club quite
traditional the the new Hall is very
traditional in its form and sometimes
it's like they look like Baptist chapels
they look like some banks they have a
very traditional form they are very
important little buildings they they
tell us a story about how Sudbury
developed in this northern part of the
town in Central in the mid and later
Victorian period
um thank you I don't know if I've gone
off peace sorry about that no no that's
fine uh that is obviously uh another
opinion councilor Barrett
[Music]
thank you chair um just a question to Dr
dark
um have there been any requests or
applications for uh full listing for any
of these three buildings please
hello councilor Barrett as far as I know
there there hasn't
um historic England have a fairly they
run a fairly tight ship in regard to
listing buildings and and these
buildings are in terms of rules of thumb
these buildings are perhaps a little
late
um the there is a rule of thumb that
anything after about 1840 has to be
um either very special unique or created
by an architect of you know some
significance so a lot of the Victorian
extensions in this country uh in being
Suffolk and baber Sudbury but nationally
a lot of these Victorian extensions are
not protected by listing but they are
within the conservation area which is a
form of protection already a statutory
form of protection thank you
any other comments
any other members wish to speak a
counselor Jameson
thank you chair
um just basing on what Stephen said a
moment ago about both the options
available to us showing a loss based on
the applicants figures
uh I'm not really sure how we could go
against the
um officer's recommendation and to prove
this is specific both options are at a
loss Will the developer even go through
with this um application
uh
I don't know who can help us on that uh
um Stephen
or Mark I suppose Mark you're you're
dealing with it
sorry Stephen I think it's Mark
sorry chess so um
the councilors I'm not quite sure
it was more a comment Mark I was just
the question I'm just saying if um the
developers or applicants figures both
showing a loss whichever option it takes
then um how could we go against your
recommendation and to prove it basically
that's more a comment than that yeah
right yes yes I see well that that is
another point of view isn't it and
another comment
um do you do you leave it there to
continue to fall down or do you try and
take some sort of action uh councilor
Ayers
thank you chair
um just going back to the St Leonard's
Hospital the way we kept the outside
there and the the one
um round at the back of Saint Gregory's
Church
um the old walnut tree building they
didn't make a loss and both the
buildings are lovely so I really don't
understand how this one would be at such
a loss thank you
well we only had the figures in front of
us which suggested it is so
um unless you're an expert to argue
against that I think we have to accept
them but it's up to you to weigh that
point up counselor Barrett
thank you Emma I I think we have to move
towards towards
um a vote on this matter
um and so reluctantly I am going to
propose that it we approve
because I because of the difficulty is
that if we decline it then I think it's
likely that it will just deteriorate
further and that doesn't preserve an old
building we've we've heard that they're
not they're not listed
on the official listing
and and they're not unique they are
properly replicated elsewhere and
they're not architecturally
um significant
um so I would like to see
something something being done about
that site to improve it and it does
retain old
uh old Hall
um they'll be at that element to it so
um also just just touch on um some
Leonard's and walnut tree in in town
where um older buildings have been saved
they're much larger so they offered a
opportunities to to get claw back some
money and on all on both of those
um some of the site were demolished they
weren't all retained
um so I'm going to I'm going to propose
that we
approve against the office of
recommendation and the reasons um which
I would need but uh I would have said
that uh somewhere in the report and I'm
just trying to look at page 67 it says
uh nppf
um would cause a low to medium level of
less than substantial harm and and it
was quoted somewhere as I wrote it down
and I think it was by Dr duck that this
was lower than um substantial harm and
also somewhere in this report uh it does
point out that um by going along proven
this there would be the
um dwellings made available which there
is a demand for in the center of Sudbury
so there would be a significant benefit
uh to the population so I think that's
two points you could add into your
reasons for approval as well as the fact
that they've come back and they've said
that the the building can be kept they
will that they will retain the
um the Princess Street facade which we
know as the Victoria Hall and that the
new Street element they're going to uh
keep the bay windows or insert bay
windows that the two pictures does look
better than the one pitch so I think we
have to accept that so I think there's
some points there that can be worded
into your recommendation for approval
and I'll be happy to second that okay
and and actually I had just highlight
50 of the report the baby local plan
says that consent to demolish and
unlisted building in Porter Hall would
be granted only where it can show me
it's only Beyond repair and capable of
being Regional be beneficial
inappropriate structural design so I
think we are varying towards that back
the bits that I mentioned
um right Ian
I think we'll just come in I think I'm
oh sorry
can I be heard you're sorry yes yes
um indeed I think as I as I've I've
given advice before where you're in a
situation where you know as is your
perfect Democratic will and Progressive
you choose to just you disagree with an
officer's recommendation
um there's no Duty in law to give
reasons for an approval but it is there
is some case law from our higher courts
that says there are situations where it
is right to do so and the court will
expect and require it and it's it wise
anyway but I've listened to you and what
you've said and what counts the Barrison
I think unless one one of my planner
colleagues wishes to say anything
further on this point it's in essence
you're making a judgment and you've said
what you think about the level of harm
and your your you you've noted what your
officers say but your judgment and
uh decision if it's if your majority of
your colleagues are vote with you is
that it the benefits to do um outweigh
the harm even when the amount of
statutory weight to that harm that the
law requires has has been is being given
so I hope I've understood you correctly
there but I'll see if any of my planner
colleagues wishes to comment further on
that
uh yeah
um Mark is there anything you wish to
say to what we've proposed and seconded
I think that Stephen wishes to say
something um right okay thank you
Stephen Stephen Stroud
yes thank you chair
um yes of course and you know officers
are not here to stand in the way of
whatever decision it is that you would
like to take as as experienced members
of the planning committee I think um
what you need to be clear on and indeed
is Mr de brace just uh Mr Dupree has
just touched on is the statutory duties
that you have in respect to the historic
environment
um what I've heard so far is the point
about in effect a simple balance of
benefits against the harms to a
non-designated Heritage asset but I
think we're at danger of misdirecting
ourselves and not fully taking into
account the harm to the conservation
area which is protected by law and does
require you to uh by law give
considerable importance and weight to
the harm that's been identified so it is
not a simple balance it is one where
actually the courts would expect you to
refuse planning permission unless you
think that the benefits are so weighty
that they nevertheless out weighed at
home and I think it would be incredibly
helpful if we're not going to defer to
effectively write those reasons for you
to vote on members that you are very
clear in the way that you articulate
this going forward because unfortunately
um Heritage matters it's quite a
litigious area and and there may be
um proposed legal claimants waiting in
the wings if you were to take a decision
that doesn't absolutely flesh out those
matters in respect of obviously the
letter that shows both options as being
loss making
um if the developer wants to be
charitable about it and put forward a
loss making scheme that's fine I think
the simple Point here members is that
you only have one detailed scheme before
you and no other alternative so I think
you need to take the harm that's been
articulated decide whether you agree
with that level of harm or not and then
weigh that against the benefits but
bearing in mind as I say for the
conservation area it is not a straight
forward or or simple balance as it were
you've really got to be clear that you
are wringing your hands over this as it
were and you fully accept that you ought
to refuse but you may find the benefits
to be far more weighty and and that's
aside from actually before we get to the
point then once you've made a decision
um we need to think about conditions and
things like that as well which is again
why I'm always slightly nervous about
sort of doing these things on the hoof
but so are you proposed as you
suggesting that councilor Barrett and I
was the seconder uh that we asked you to
uh take away our comments and put them
into a balance that you feel happy with
that will satisfy us if we got it
through with our colleagues that would
deliver the outcome
I I think from experience chair that
would be cleaner
um appreciating that as Mr Duprey says
there is not necessarily a duty for you
to give reasons but Heritage is
unfortunately a very litigious area and
I think the preference would be for us
to just be very clear if you can sort of
walk us through you know your thoughts
on the harm and how harmful it is and
the benefits and then we go away and do
that for you and put forward some
conditions as well because again we're
in danger of sort of marching over the
precipice and and you know we made
things going away uh doing this uh with
a slight deferment or would you want to
um take it away because you'd say it's
all time consuming again and uh at the
end of the day this has been going on so
I think we need to be clear-cut and our
resolution but I'll just see what
councilor Barrett has to say on what
you've just proposed
well I'm
um
I'm trying to know what what quite to
say
um am I what I I'm am I needing to just
focus on the harm that I perceive and
the benefit that I perceive is that
right okay so the harm is clearly the
demolition of the conservative Club
but that is offset against the retention
of the new Hall and the exterior of the
Victoria Hall which is a benefit because
they are
that is the benefit because they are
protected and preserved
so that must be that must be the benefit
although they're already there and we've
already got them then by no means secure
in the future
so can that be the the benefit aside
from the new dwellings and and that
that's right
um Stephen Stephen I'm I'm well I'm
happy with that Council about in the
sense that um you know giving you advice
in respect of what is a non-designated
asset but I think what's been
articulated in the papers and and from
the advice of Dr dark is that there is
also here harm here to the conservation
area which is a designated asset which
all of a sudden makes things far more
serious so I think again you know if you
feel that the benefits are more
weightier than that harm even though
that harm is really really important
that's fine but we just need to be
absolutely clear on that I'm sorry isn't
that just another point of view
I know he's the expert and I'm not
dispute and taking any of that away from
any officer yeah but that is a point of
view
um a councilor Barrett and I don't
altogether agree with that we can see
another point of view that we feel will
be more beneficial
um at the end of the day and better
benefits the people so it's just two
points of view and we're asking members
whether to at the end of the day they
will be voting whether to accept the
Heritage point of view over our more for
one of a better way of putting Common
Sense approach to it and your your right
chair in the sense that it's your
judgment as to whether it's harmful or
not however it's the Court's judgment
that if you find it harmful you've got
to be absolutely clear that the benefits
are really compelling and and that's
that that is your legal duties
unharmful in which case you know we'll
we'll all call it a day and that's fine
but if you agree with the Heritage
officer that it is harmful you've got to
be clear that because it's a
conservation area it is protected by law
let's see what the other members have to
say because I see some hands up but um
you can if we came back to it
um work out
um what councilor Barrett and I are
suggesting right that's fine uh I'll
take us councilor Busby's there next and
then councilor Parker and then Kent uh
know that um Dr dark which I'll bring
you in at a certain point uh councilor
Busby
yeah I think there's two parts to this I
think the officer's recommendation
is a refusal for uh
it says for the following reason but the
application fails to demonstrate the
extensive demolition is required always
Justified and I think we probably all
feel that extensive demolition is
Justified is needed
and therefore
if we agree that then the next thing is
what goes in its place once that
demolition has occurred so if the office
could go back to
because I've lost track of what actually
we're going to be approving in terms of
what it looks like so if Mark if you
could go back to the slide that shows
what we finally approving or going to
approve that would be useful because we
chopped and changed between what was the
last one what we asked for what was then
put forward what you ult what you didn't
like Etc so I don't know what we're
going to do yeah that's the bit that
Council of Barrett and I are saying we
should put forward for approval
at that point I think we've accepted
that it demolition is required so that's
fine
really what we're approving now is
whether we approve this proposed scheme
or not and maybe the officers have got a
view as to how it could be better and I
don't just mean tinkered by moving a
wing here or there or whatever but
there hadn't been any other interest
that's that that's another disadvantage
anyway uh Mark can you help us out yeah
I will share
slide in question
so it's this one
um I think there might be a bit of
confusion about the reference to gulp
brick I don't know whether the only
difference I can see that I thought was
articulated was that the
uh
the left-hand side element of the
conservative Club I thought it was said
by the applicant it would be called
brick I might have that wrong but apart
from that this is what is the proposal
yeah so what what of that do you not
like
it's professional opinion um accounts
it's it's the um double pitch thing over
to the right
um seemingly it's out of scale with the
conservation area and not sympathetic
too Etc the way the other bits of
conservative Club be done is good now I
like it you know it's personal taste the
Victoria Hall is preserved that's fine
you know I'd say that the track the
detraction is that double pitched um
element can I just come in there mark
the the single pitch can you just show
that because we suggested a single pitch
which everybody's decided afterwards
yeah you say do we think that's better I
suppose no but in my opinion neither is
acceptable but this is probably worse
but that's just my opinion yeah yeah
could I ask Dr duck to give his opinion
on the choice of the two yep I think
that's a fair point Dr duck on this
point can you help us yeah thank you
chair I I can uh
yeah on the balanced on the balanced
roof I think the the the the form is not
uncharacteristic in Victorian Urban
extensions
um my concern was with the height of it
and the the materials
um but the the balanced nature of the
roof the m shape I don't think is
uncharacteristic per se is that any
lower side interrupt you is that any
lower than Milhouse that's beside it
Eddie higher sorry because they look
about roughly all the same size same
height
yeah
it's the same height they can't be able
to keep him
well it well why not I mean everything
else in the building in that area is
smaller
yes well as a fact everything else in
that area in that immediate area is
smaller even the three-story house is
opposite I think on St John's Terrace is
smaller the mill is clearly the biggest
and most most obvious building in that
area because it's a Mill and the
function dictated the form and the
Weaver's Cottages to some extent also
did that but residential dwellings in
New Street and Prince Street a two-story
um to compete with the mill and and in
in fact to infill that space and then to
put something of three stories competes
with it visually and also diminishes the
views that you get obliquely from the
junction of the four zones the single
pitch which one do you think is best out
of the two or perhaps I don't think it
makes any difference cheer it's not it's
not the roof it's the fact that it's
three-story rather than two all right
yeah and to be I mean my view is that
the three-story with that pitch we now
see it looks rather like a very large
and
contemporary articulation of the the
thing around the corner Victoria Hall
and that's not on that's not
characteristic and certainly not of
dwellings it's not like it's not a house
that fits yeah I've got the answer now
um councilor Busby is the three-story
element that's fine yes I understand
where you come from now whether the
developer would be happy to get into two
story and I don't suppose they will
well we have to deal with what's in
front of us and at the moment the
proposal is unseconded for what's in
front of us
um anyway
um councilor Parker
yeah thanks Chef um okay so I wonder if
we've got uh Mark have we got any uh a
slide I'm sure I saw a slide earlier of
a streetscape that sort of shows um
along new straight and up towards North
Street have we got have we've got a
slide respect photo yeah uh yeah yeah
sorry uh I think we've got photographs
just let me have a look number 10 I
think ah thank you well I think I've
made a notice and photographs thrown
about that point so that might help you
there you go I mean that yeah so it will
mean several photographs but this is
basically the buildings we've just been
talking about yeah I can't can't see it
man it doesn't come up yet I haven't
shared sorry I understand I'm going to
share again stop sharing options share
content
[Music]
um
well we've got councilor Parker very
very lifelike ah there we are so there
is there are the buildings we've been
speaking about
um yeah granted I'm just wondering if
we've got a photo I'm sure a sort of
photographer yeah I work along the
street um there you go
that's tall it's oblique but that's
that's the best
no I'm sure there's another one that I'm
sure I saw that on the other side you
did with globe yard in it that sort of
looks towards North Street there we are
there we go that's right yeah that's
three story yeah okay so with with
regards to Conservation Area
um I'm just wondering I mean is it you
know it's a technical question I suppose
um but is there anything and when we're
talking about harm to the conservation
area is there anything that allows us to
challenge
whether they're actually
um is harmed to the conservation area so
you know for example why can't we argue
that uh this application represents uh a
benefit by virtue of the fact that it
actually improves the conservation area
and I think if we just Linger on uh on
on that photograph there let me go back
sorry athlete
right that's all right there you go
yeah that one yep yep so if we you know
if we just Linger on that and look and
look at that as a Conservation Area
um now obviously
the conservative Club there lies in a
parlor state but that's not to say that
with love and attention it couldn't be
brought back to its um to its former
glory and I understand that completely
however
we haven't got any other options on on
the table in terms of of anybody else
that's that's looking to do something
with this building so if we follow the
officer's recommendation okay I
understand everything behind that but
that doesn't improve the situation and
it certainly doesn't improve the
conservation area
um and and I just can't help looking
with no disrespect to that uh to that
building uh in North Street there but I
I just wonder how on Earth
you know what's being proposed here is a
detriment to the conservation area and
and therefore I ask again why can't we
argue that this actually represents an
improvement and so therefore is a
benefit why can't we add that into the
mix thank you you can you can disagree
with the advice you've been given
completely right that's your prerogative
thank you councilor Osborne
cancel Adrian Osborne
yeah sorry yes thank you Mr chairman yes
what uh councilor Parker said is
absolutely right and my belief is this
the harm uh is that the building if it
is left to stand many more years uh will
fall down and then the conservation area
will be uh hung by the loss of a of a a
building uh you know in and it will just
lead into degradation so and and if you
look at that street scene again you'll
notice that across the road from that is
a modern building so you know what we're
proposed what the applicant is proposing
is to actually enhance that area just as
uh councilor Parker has said and and I
believe the harm uh will be at the the
harm the benefit will be more than the
harm because you'll have a building
which actually will come into the look
of that street and make it uh make it a
a more of an amenable uh area for
Sudbury thank you
thank you
great members
um going back to
um Stephen Stroud
um's comments
um
if we took a deferment for you to work
out some words for us
um would 10 minutes be enough for you to
do that
I I will ask Mark to assist me but um
but yes we we can do that members and I
think from what I've heard and getting
back to your very um important question
earlier Council the bear chair is um is
that yes while while the legal duties
you can't avoid ultimately the Judgment
as to whether there's any harm or not is
yours alone and if you're not convinced
by
um your officer's opinion on that and
you actually feel that there would be
preservation or indeed enhancement
through the progression of this scheme
then then that's your call your your
decision takers
uh well I have to say I think it can
only be beneficial so that I may upset
people but uh that I do believe that
um right members we'll take a 10 minute
it's um uh 1442 10 minutes is 52. uh if
we come back at 14 50 follow you
again your hand doesn't appear on my
screen but please speak can I could I
just uh pose a rather
strange dilemma having brought up the
the anomaly of the figures earlier on
what makes us think that somebody is
going to make a loss of three hundred
thousand on I on on the demolishing
development or was it 1.9 million on the
uh renovation development uh surely
somebody should be going away and saying
well hang on a minute let's see if we
can come up with something that is
actually going to break even if nothing
else well I I under the impression that
if they can't make it work or they're
prepared to build it to the last the
choice is there is if they don't do it
then then then it's like given plan
permission on a piece of grain that's
not in your ownership if you can't
purchase it you can't go ahead with it
there's the choice to me see is entirely
in their Court this is a loss or not if
they then come back at a later stage and
say sorry this is uh economically
unviable we want to change it and do
this where do we stand then well I think
we would then have to treat that
application before far as as the sole
one but uh just to be sure on that I'll
ask the officer
um Mark or Stephen is that not correct
that
um if if they came back with another
application and they hadn't built this
or hadn't started it I assume we would
be Duty bound to look at it
so I've Mark appeared then disappeared
you're here now I think yes nothing to
say contrary to to what you said chair
there um you know if the developers
feeling particularly charitable then
then that's for them um it's a bit of a
known goal to say something is
profitable when when it's not but I
assume that they have carefully thought
about this before putting the
application in
um so it's for them to progress if
ultimately they find that when they run
the numbers again they can't make it
work well then if they have to make a
new application it will be judged on its
merits again but I dare say the
weightiness of this permission as a
fallback
um you know we'll have to think very
carefully about that thank you right
members uh sorry if I could just come
yes yes sorry John counselor yeah but if
they if in the meantime they have
demolished
several buildings and then said oops we
can't make any money at this
we want to build something that's
equivalent to The Shard instead in the
middle of the conservation area
um where do we stand then I don't think
that'll get through yeah we'd be in a
tricky we have an empty site we'd have a
building site with nothing on it
well sorry I think what you're
suggesting is there's some sort of um
phasing of the development we could look
at a phasing um condition
to ensure that things happen in a
certain order
that could Safeguard us to a certain
degree couldn't it yeah right uh
councilor Osborne have you got something
new
uh yeah I have uh well it's not it's not
as new as that I just I just my concern
is and and uh bringing the other members
into this who probably have witnessed uh
areas of uh this this Heritage situation
uh and you know
um Ganges is one of them and the there
you've got an iconic Mast which was
supposed to be a a monument which is now
in pieces in in the hundreds of pieces
so they're never going to put that back
up as it should be and as it was so you
know I I have con real concerns that
this will be another building that will
just end up
degradation bound I'm afraid right
um members I think
um that's a good pint cancer Osborne I I
think we'll allow the officers to go
away until three o'clock so they've got
nearly 15 minutes should be long enough
and uh to put the words together come
back and present them to a councilor
Barrett and myself and then if they're
acceptable we can then um debate it and
then put it to the vote
um so if you're all happy uh you've got
a nearly 15 minute break three o'clock
please be back
welcome back members officers
um right I'm gonna call on Mark Russell
to update us as to where we are
thank you chair I've spoken to my
colleague Stephen Stroud and uh Dr duck
about the wording and also the
conditions I'm gonna two goes at showing
what the word is I've just put it in
chat
oh um and it will appear any moment
there you go and I will also share a
Word document with you where hopefully
you can read it better than that chat
box because it's a little bit slim
chat box conversation isn't it yeah yeah
I can't see it okay I'll call up a Word
document which should be a lot clearer
uh I've got it in chat yeah but I can't
oh let me move that thing oh God
come on where is it so I don't know what
this thing is I don't want that go away
um I'll have another go at that um I
just want to show you a Word document
that I've got
I don't want to show you that whiteboard
thing and I'll read it to you as well
once again that'd be better yeah
um I'll have one more go trying to share
it if not then I'll just say it I've
found it in the chat anyway okay
right
now I don't think it wants to show you
my word document no well I think members
that is in the meeting chat if you go
into that um
you can't that's a similar right you'll
read it out okay can you can can you see
a Word document now is it not showing no
oh well fair enough I will just carry on
so it's about a minute long so get
comfortable
um members have paid special attention
with regard to their duties under the
listed building Conservation Area Act
1990.
notwithstanding the harm due to the Lost
partial loss of the existing
non-designated Heritage assets
and the concomitant harm to the
character and appearance of the
designated asset that is the
Conservation Area
the economic and social benefits as well
as the replacement of derelict buildings
with newly built ones with the resultant
visual improvements of the Conservation
Area
overall this leads to preservation of
the character and appearance of the
Conservation Area
the the development therefore complies
with local Heritage policies and the
mppf the development complies with the
development plan as a whole and there
are no considerations that indicate
otherwise
so sure we have actually said that we
have given reference to the fact we'd
think there is some harm but we've
weighed it and concluded that the that
it's acceptable all right thank you
councilor Bauer are you happy with that
uh yes I am so that's your proposal and
I as second I'm happy with that so
before you proceed before you proceed
obviously there's the conditions as well
right you better tell us what they are
bullet point condition before you vote
is that okay if I say those yes please
do please do yeah sure okay I I
mentioned the phasing condition now I
mean this will have a limited effect
because the the two main buildings are
all joined up with each other and
probably will go at the same and all
that so it will be tied to New Hall
probably but we're just going to say
there'll be a phasing condition
um and in terms of
specialist
um Heritage conditions we'd like sample
panels materials
detailing and hard surface
um and Boundary treatment conditions
and also just to pick up on a part of
the conversation we had for the
conservative building to have Galt brick
to the front as is now rather than the
red that's shown on the drawing
right
uh uh yes I think that's more consistent
with what we want to see
yes I agree with you yep
that that's fine those sort of
conditions and obviously it was
realistic about the phase and one that
you you accept or understand that two
parts of it might go quicker than the
other part yes yeah yeah
yes the councilor Hinton I understand
that the phasing condition is uh is a
little bit difficult to do because of
the joining together are two parts of it
to make it uh more uh strict if you like
but bearing in mind that this site is
well out of the town center and Suffolk
County highways have said that there
should be some environmental
um sustainable transport things in there
do we want anything in there about uh
electric vehicle charging points or
anything
I I always think it's good if there is
parking spaces to get in electric
vehicle charging points uh I don't think
that's unrealistic I don't know about
councilor Barrett what your views are I
mean they're not going to get that many
in but you could most likely get a
couple inside that area
yeah yeah yeah sure I mean
that seems sensible
I Suffolk County highways yeah I don't
know whether we need a condition or
whether you can uh get that agreed but
um you've asked for it so we can ask for
it as well in a condition also you
remind me I should put the parking
condition as well you know the parking
shall be provided just to make sure and
bins and stuff like that you know the
usual stuff yeah yeah so you're just
adding that an element of
um electric charging Point yeah we'll
leave it open to see how much can be
provided yeah yeah so you can't be
unrealistic but I'm sure they can do
something right that's fine uh let me
come over to this meeting chat let me
get back to participants because I can't
see any of you now
participants yep
um could I just run through just to make
sure that I've got all the points that
Mr Russell has raised as conditions
right uh hounselor Barrett please listen
yeah
so I have got
phasing condition sample panels
materials detailing hard surface and
Boundary treatment details
and gold brick gold gold white white
brick Yellow Brick to the front is
conservative I'm afraid that's a new
term for me you'll have to spell that Mr
Russell g-a-u-l-t
that's a light colored brick isn't it
yeah which which goes Smoky over time
yeah thank you so gold brick for the
conservative club building was that
correct uh just for the frontier
conservative Club
hey sure
from New Street from New Street New
Street
and then
scheme of electric vehicle charging
points to be agreed and parking and all
within reasons and bins yeah
and while you're there sorry these
things come to your mind later um the
the issue of the facade being preserved
on Victoria
um Street at Victoria Hall there should
be a condition relating to how that is
done
okay could you just read out what you
would like me to put please condition to
ensure the retention of Victoria Hall
facade
yes
thank you all right so I've made this
will be able to view this as well chair
because that'll be in the um wording for
the electronic vote
all right uh well hopefully I can get
that up I haven't been able to yet uh
counselor Jameson I see your hand is up
I didn't know whether you'd enforce or
something yeah just I was just thinking
do you want bike Shades as well I mean
not uh right I think that's a valid
point
yeah if there's room yeah cool I'd go as
far as say electric bikes but I won't
okay I'll just add that in share
well you've only got that bit of area
where the old um Stables were the the
single story stuff so let's see they
won't get everything in there but they
can most likely pick up uh one of the
you know one each of the points so we'll
get we'll get something
sorry should have tasted water
yep no that's fine and Spike sheds
oh well was it bike rack
all right cycle parking just leave it
yeah sorry that's right yes because you
know you might find it's easier to do a
shade or a rack or something else might
you yeah
or more practical right uh Robert are
you going to read that all out to us
please
uh I can do chair so there's just the do
you want me to just read the points of
the additional conditions again as
remember you will see that point
so um the conditions are the conditions
and the conditions as follows are facing
conditions sample panels materials
detailing hard surface and Boundary
treatment details and gulp brick for the
conservative face here new street from
New Street the bike shed and it was oh
that's taken off that other bit about
the facade
no
um retention of Victoria Hall facade
yeah
and cycle Provisions I think was the
word they were used talking yeah not not
sheds no
I have a feeling that it might not fit
into the box on this but as long as all
members are aware yes we're aware
I just want to clarify we've mentioned
gold bricks on the old
Frontage the fascia is that all three
houses then that we're no that's just
that white bit that looks the one on the
corner uh no it's the middle bit there
was a picture of a slow 10 or whatever
it was it shoe a white sort of area and
that's the area of gold brick no no
sorry the drawing show showed a red
brick over to the left and the
conversation went the way that it should
have gone so it's notwithstanding the
drawing you shall have gold brick on
that bit of the building from one one of
those buildings
well the one on the corner which is
predominantly yeah yeah but I know what
you're saying
we have materials condition anyway so
you know we've got a bit of movement
okay chair um I've got all of that I'm
not
I think that is now
all in there so apologies for the delay
on that
um so I've got everything up to the
conservative Club place here from New
Street retention of Victoria Hall facade
and bike storage
correct thank you Jim
okay uh members
um has been proposed and seconded we'll
Now take us through the voting procedure
um Robert
thank you chair uh if members could
please be uh please go to the mob.gov
app
and go to the plus to today's agenda and
go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner and click on the subsection
on the screen that comes up with
attendance and voting from there could
you please click or scroll down to the
light blue bar
for today's Vote or this for this vote
for this item which is now in progress
members do have any issues please
um I'm still waiting for it to log on
I've taught that's Dawn things but we're
not there no Logan's failed
I don't know why so I have to give it to
you
um verbally
when when you're ready
yesterday you can do it now if you wish
uh I am in favor of
um approval
thank you chair
I've got to log in again if I can so uh
John Hinton is a improved approval as
well
so that's football cancer yet
that has a yes
waiting on three more chair
I'll have to have words with Mandy
um another time because that's just
stopped doing it again
I'm gonna come out of it because it's
pointless
okay I'm just waiting on one more vote
um Council suit is are you having any
difficulties voting
yes
sorry I was trying to Vlog on and
couldn't get to my mute yes I'm four
thank you
thank you councilor
so chair I can now confirm the results
of the vote are 10 votes for the
proposal and one against so the motion
is carried thank you very much thank you
all right so let me have a look
um
trying to get my agenda up again
um right we now moved to item number
three DC stroke 20 stroke
03116 land east of Sudbury Road copfield
those Snowden Suffolk
um now somebody brought up that they
wanted
um I can't remember know what it was a
site inspection
or deferment
um yes chairs
suggested that's at the beginning yeah
councilor Jameson yeah I suggested yeah
I mean there's no change to that but
forgotten what you suggested so perhaps
you can tell us okay a long while ago
wasn't it oh no yeah uh and that is just
I just said at the time that um
due to
the the site and the fact you know the
um we'd benefit from seeing the site and
how the two-story development will sit
in the landscape and against the
neighbors that was all it was going to
benefit from
um actually go and look at it but I mean
where the councilors have actually gone
out and it looked like uh councilor
Busby I'm not sure well I know the site
very well yeah
um so I I don't think we need to but um
did you want to make that a proposal or
is it just a thought yeah I mean yeah I
mean it's fairly
um evident from the earlier
conversations that members weren't Keen
so so
I will carry on then okay with it thank
you very much
I think if we if you I think it's
obviously right to receive the officer's
report and hit the public speaking
obviously and then anything can be
suggested in the debate if members see
that yeah that's true yeah so you can
come up at any other point if you don't
we're assume that you're quite happy to
and we'll just continue okay uh now
um info case officer Alex Scott to the
meeting good afternoon Alex a long time
no see you so um
yes well I still can't see you at the
moment so you haven't let yourself I'll
try and
um
Camerons that's
bring his screen from whatever we were
doing before on mine so I might need to
ask Mr Russell
Alex in full color and everything
that's fine right
um
uh
case officer Scott would you like to
take us through this application
uh yes indeed sure I'll just try and
share my screen and the presentation if
you just bear with me
right
yes that's that so you can see that
lovely thank you very much so I'll just
um
try and maximize that if I can from
beginning
there we are
right okay so um this is
um item 7c and the agenda application
reference DC
2003116
and without what's described as land
east of Sudbury Road in cockfield
and the application is for um for full
planning permission for the erection of
a workshop building
and the upgrading of an existing access
to the a 1141 that's the lavenum uh
cockfield lavender road to the south of
the of the site and
um the application is in association
with first grade recycling systems
who specialize in the design manufacture
and installation
of waste processing and recycling
equipment so that's a quick rundown of
the application proposal
this first slide is a um General
location of a site within the district
for the avoidance of Doubt um hope
that's helpful
and we have a wider aerial view
and this uh star indicates the
approximate location of a site and it's
at The Junction at the a
that's the Sudbury to bury some Edmunds
Road
and the a1141 which extends away through
cockfield towards uh towards lavender
for those that aren't familiar
the application site itself is
um with an existing development cluster
at the junction and the nearest
um what could be termed as a village at
Cross green is approximately 0.2 of a
mile away
and we're about eight miles to the north
of Sudbury
and six and a half miles uh to the south
of bury Saint Edmunds for reference here
it's a a closer aerial view of the site
uh so we have uh the site here
edged in orange and purple hatched
the applicants are existing
site and business is here at Ivy House
to the north of the site
we also have uh hux haulage which is a
haulage company
existing to the south of the site
and over here is uh
Loft Farm which also has a number of
large industrial character
buildings and I'll come on to
um a few slides for you later hopefully
that's uh useful
um in terms of neighboring dwellings
there are three in the uh
in the immediate
location of the site we have
um Crossways which is uh
approximately here and I measure that to
be
87 meters from
the proposed building
we have uh bendish I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly apologies if
not and that is uh
approximately 112 meters from the
proposed building on the opposite side
of the uh the Sudbury Road the a134
and we have a bungalow over here at
Raylene
um which is the closest dwelling to the
site uh on the opposite side of the
a1141 and that's uh approximately 34
meters I measure from the proposed
building
um so hopefully that's useful
here is the um the planning constraints
map so um we are in the countryside
outside of any settlement boundary is
defined in the um in the current plan
and we're at the junction of um two
major roads which are speed limited only
to National speed limit of 60 miles an
hour and the
30 miles an hour speed limit for um
cross green commands was about here I
think
um from from memory
and other constraints affecting the site
well the the conservation area the
nearest Conservation Area is um
is over here quite a distance from the
uh
from the site itself as are the list of
buildings which are are colored
um
the uh the orangey yellow indicates a
grade two
um I think that's all there is there but
uh grade two star would be red and grade
one would be green as per our color
coding and uh
the site has
um has some
archaeological potential
um being close to the
Roman Road and
um SEC archeology have recommended a
scheme of archaeological work should you
be minded to approve and that's in the
included in the Lister suggested uh
conditions
so I think they're the they're the main
constraints affecting the affecting the
site
um moving on to the plan submitted with
the application this is the site
location plan
uh with the application
um important to note that um
the
application site is edged in red here so
we're looking at a portion of the
what's described as the the meadow
um in um in console T responses received
and not the entire Meadow so there will
still be a an area of undeveloped land
um between that and the
and the neighboring property
um as I said approximately
um
approximately 87 meters which is the
length of a uh the football pitch
approximately for a find a reference
this is a topographical survey of the
site as existing so it's just a area of
grassland predominantly with um
uh some clusters of trees and hedgerows
to the boundary and um I've got some
photographs later on so hopefully that's
uh
demonstrates that a little bit more for
you the existing access uh
to the site is here that's supposed to
be upgraded as part of The Proposal
and it has a large concrete apron a a
gated entrance set back from the highway
here and a a long
um concrete driveway which connects the
um
the
a1141 to the existing site
um in in the North
here is the proposed
site site plan
and
[Applause]
yes I mean you will notice that
um
there isn't a lot in the way of
landscaping proposed and that's that's
been raised in um a few of the comments
received
um
but you'll also notice that there is a
landscape condition including in
included in the list of suggested
conditions so uh it's felt that if you
are minded to approve we could secure a
bit more in terms of landscape uh
softening and screening
um by way of condition we think that's
reasonable
um as part of your case officers there
was one significant tree to be removed
at the point of the access but um we
feel that's justified in order to make
the access uh safe in terms of Highway
Safety and what uh caddy highways have
suggested
and there would be opportunities to um
replace that
um
several times over
um in terms of a landscaping scheme if
you reminded to approve so uh that is
the uh that is the layout we move on to
the elevations of the building
uh the building measures uh 55
by 25 meters that's a approximate floor
area of 1 375 square meters the maximum
height would be 10 meters
and the eaves height would be
approximately 8.8 meters and externally
the building would be finished
predominantly in
profiled steel uh and a color given of
Willow Green in the application so a
green profiled sheeting
in other words
and onto the floor plans so we have
within the building the main Workshop
area here and what's described as the
paint shop in the back for uh print
paint spraying and the like and that
includes a
a flu for uh for ventilation
and as part of the conditions we would
need more detail of um of those
operations and what's proposed in terms
of ventilation and extraction
um mainly in terms of noise impacts but
um yeah we would need more more
information on that if you reminded to
approve
um this section of building is
um staff officers or the like and at
ground floor we have the main entrance
and Lobby to the building
we have um uh
toilets and a canteen at ground floor
level and it does have a
a portion of it would be over a
two-story and on the first floor
um we have the the officers and meeting
rooms and the staff breakout area there
at first floor
some cross sections of the building just
for reference
and we have some more detail on the site
access and visibility splays for
highways assessment purposes
foreign
and this is the uh the drainage plan
um showing um
uh where a surface water drainage would
would fall and we have some large soak
aways here
um all assessed by County floods and
drainage deemed to be acceptable prior
to
other issues being addressed by word
condition which is uh included in the
final recommendation
and then the the foul drain drainage
which would drain to a uh a treatment on
site before being discharged into the
drainage ditch again
um Suffolk floods and drainage consulted
and environment agency uh no um no
objections raised subject to conditions
so we're satisfied with that as your
officers
excuse me now on to some uh photographs
for you this is the entrance to the site
onto the
a1141
cockfield to Lavender Road
and you can see here the existing
concrete apron and site Gates
leading to the concrete drive and this
is just turned towards the
the main Junction with the a134
this is a panoramic view of the interior
of the site as you can see
um we'll see later grass described as a
as a meadow within the application and
console T responses received
and the concrete driveway
and you just might be able to see the
applicants existing installation
in the distance
the dwelling Crossways is approximately
here obscured by existing tree screening
and you might be able to see the another
neighboring dwelling at uh at bendish
there across the road again hopefully
I'm pronouncing that correctly
and this is a view of the applicant's
existing business which they're hoping
to expand as part of this application
proposal this is taken from the uh the
main a134
they're just moving around to the to the
right of that uh that shot so we've got
the applicant's business here and this
is the
neighboring dwelling at Crossways
and then further down the uh a134
and then closer to the sites of the
proposed building would be uh in
approximately this location here
and you might be able to make um
at the uh the QX haulage existing
building which is uh
of the same scale I would say chair
um of the same height certainly and
character
and this is the uh the the main Junction
with the a134 and the a
uh 1141
in this direction and uh proposed
development would be in this approximate
location and we have the neighboring
dwelling just out of shot
um
in this location
um I don't have a photograph of that
dwelling I'm afraid
um
and some photographs of the existing
industrial buildings just down the road
at Hewitt's haulage and at Loft Farm
across the road
some more detail
of those here the idea of the existing
character
that concludes the presentation chair
um as I said I didn't report obviously
recommendation of approval subject to
conditions of course thank you thank you
very much
um for that uh all right let me just
catch up
we now then members is there any points
of clarification that you wish the
officer to clarify for you
no right we'll carry on
uh public speed sorry counselor Barrett
no that's fine clarify how how what sort
of industry is is going to take part in
that building is it light engineering or
can you describe that please
uh yes indeed yeah I think the the
question has been raised by um a lot of
the consultees you know is this a is
this a factory is it a workshop
um I think the most appropriate question
in certainly in planning terms would be
uh does this um
yeah does this fall under
um so I've got to remind myself now the
um the use classes order has um changed
um on the 1st of September 2020 so
um
what was previously b1c
um and that would be
industrial processes which are um
compatible within a residential
environment that has now changed to uh
Class E G three I believe
um
hopefully uh my senior officers will
correct me if I'm wrong
um so I think it's a question of whether
it would be industrial processes
compatible within a residential
environment
which is uh Plus eg3 or would it be
General Industry which is class B2
now my assessment within the report is
that um
your Environmental Protection officers
are advising that subject to conditions
that this wouldn't have a significant
impact on the nearby Neighbors
and therefore by definition
I think it would be compatible and
therefore we're looking at a class eg3
use here rather than B2 that would be my
professional advice there I hope that's
helpful thank you
uh any other questions
um to the case officer
no I can't see any right
um Mark what are you trying to get in
your pictures appeared
you're muted most Fame oh you're okay I
knew I was but I couldn't get to the
button uh yeah just clarify yes exactly
what Alex said was correct but the
trouble is we've covered this by a
condition that the new use classes
ordered and I wish they'd stop playing
around with it uh means this is in class
E which does open it up to other uses
which we don't want to have there so
we've got a restrictive condition
proposed chair so I would agree it's
light industrial but we pin it down to
being just that well well done
um officers football on that good uh
right will they move to
public speaking we don't have a
representative from the Paris Council
but we do have an objector Stephen
Hopkins you sir had three minutes in
which to address the committee and at
the end I'll say if there's any
questions for you good afternoon and
thank you for your patience for bearing
with us today
good afternoon I represent Mr Mrs
Hannaford who are the occupiers of
Crossways now
um the determination of a planning
application must be made in accordance
with the development plan less material
considerations indicate otherwise
paragraph 12 of the mppf reflects this
makes it clear that the development plan
is the starting point for decision
making your officer's report identifies
that the site is located in the
countryside out of any built up area
boundary current use is undeveloped
Greenfield it's capable of being used
only for agriculture without planning
permission the applicant's clear
intention is to vacate the site it
currently rents and construct larger
premises elsewhere this is an
application for a large new industrial
unit in the open Countryside it is not
for the extension of an existing site
The Proposal is contrary to policy CS2
rather than clearly outline this
conflict the officers report seeks to
draw support from the thrust of other
policies accordingly there is no
adequate assessment of the conflict with
the policy the officer's report says CS2
provides the hinterland villages will
accommodate some development to meet the
needs within the villages there is no
evidence that the proposal will help
meet a need within the village what CS2
actually says is that in the countryside
development will only be permitted in
exceptional all circumstances subject to
a proven justifiable need what are the
exceptional circumstances and where is
the evidence of The Proven justifiable
need
pursuant to CS3 cites in appropriate
locations have been allocated nuclear
evidence has been provided as to why
these sites are inappropriate or what
collaborative working has taken place to
see what sites are available in other
nearby local Authority areas the
Reliance on cs11 is misconceived the
site is located in the countryside it is
not located within a hinterland Village
the policy does not apply
any support from em20 relates to the
extension of an existing site and is
qualified provided there is no material
conflict with residential immunity The
Proposal is for a new site in the
countryside not an extension and for the
reasons outlined in letters of objection
the proposal will cause a material
conflict with residential immunity the
explanatory text to em20 provides this
some types of Industrial and Commercial
uses particularly those which have
direct connections with the local
agricultural economy may be located in
rural areas however this need to locate
in the countryside will have to be
clearly demonstrated the need will have
to be clearly demonstrated this is not a
real business in the sense that it
either needs to be located in a rural
location or relates to traditional rural
activities there is a human impact of
granting inappropriate development on
the lives of those who live nearby if
permission is granted a substantial
industrial operation will be introduced
in close proximity to my client's home
crossway's house their home life is
already impacted by the current
unrestricted industrial use of the sites
in the north and east the introduction
of The Proposal will mean there is no
respite from the industrial uses
surrounding them the proposal will
introduce noise light pollution vehicle
movements disruption and loss of privacy
to the southern aspect of their home the
proposed conditions do not effectively
overcome the clear harm that has been
identified for example although
operational hours are to be restricted
hdvs forklift trucks and roller shutters
will be in use until 11 pm at night it
exceptions to operational hours will be
allowed this would be impractical to
police noise-related harm has clearly
been identified however no clear
condition has been proposed placing
limits on the level of noise that should
be audible at the site boundaries or at
my client's home but propose this
contrary to policy will cause
substantial harm to my clients enjoyment
of the home and I urge you to refuse
this application and I certainly urge
the committee to undertake a site visit
thank you very much
your time
um right I'll see if there's any
um questions to you at all
I I think you said you urge to take a
site inspection
um I think we've already commented on
that that can be requested by any member
but at the moment we are in a situation
where we cannot
um legally do site inspections but I
have understood from members that some
of them have driven over there and
looked for themselves
but uh that can be picked up councilor
Busby
is the proposed development or isn't the
proposed development going to be further
away from Crossways and the the site
that they hold at the moment
Mr Hopkins
um yes but it's going to be surrounding
there'll be industrial developments
surrounding every side of their property
yes there will be a small gap between
the proposed development and there and
the boundary of their their dwelling
however that is in the ownership of the
applicant and we know how these things
go
so I thought no the existing site you
said they were they weren't planning to
extend that they're moving from there to
the new side my understanding is that
they'll be vacating the current site and
constructing the new building and
occupying the new building
so we don't know what's happening to the
the existing site what we do know is
that there is a long established use for
an industrial use there and there's no
restrictions on that use so someone else
could come in and occupy it but we you
know there's there's a permitted use
there for industrial activity okay thank
you thank you
uh any other questions
no that doesn't seem to be anything Mr
Scott
um
sorry uh uh councilor Parker uh yes
right just uh appeared at the bottom of
my screen
question for Mr Hopkins can you just
clarify Mr Hopkins um you uh you you
mentioned that your clients
um
will be blind well you didn't say
blighted but effectively your
um clients will be blighted by noise etc
etc but um in section six of the report
there is a whole raft of environmental
and amenity impact considerations so is
it your contention that um that you
don't hold with with with with that can
you just clarify what page uh can you
help us page well page 86 and Page 87 I
mean that's fine yeah yeah through all
the way through yeah
yeah no no I don't agree with that I
mean the starting point for those
assessments are that there's already
industrial activity and they've used
that as a background
um essentially background reading this
this is going to introduce further
activity which fully surrounds my
clients premises and I can I can only
urge you to go and um undertake that
site inspection to see what impact you
want to have you've seen the pictures of
the buildings the size of them there's
going to be considerable activity there
yes we can measure noise but here noise
has just been essentially predicted what
noise may be generated and I've
commented on the condition but it's not
just about noise it's about introducing
that activity that activity to late at
night movements at the site flashes of
light so on and so forth all those
things that you know are quite hard and
quite hard to quantify that's
disturbance and it's disturbance of
their residential immunity thank you
thank you for that response
um thank you counselor
um right there's no other hands gone up
so I'm just gonna ask um case officer
Scott
um because it's came up in both those
questions
um but the uh Mr Hopkins says that this
um house will be surrounded on all four
sides by buildings can you show us an
aerial shot or an overhead plan showing
where these where this dwelling is
surrounded on all four sides I think was
the words used
uh yes chair I'll just try to get back
to a um
a slide that I hope demonstrates that
the best let me see what we can find
maybe the site location plan yep I'll
try and use that so I'll try and
represent
because there's a road on uh one side
isn't there
um yes yeah there's a there is a road on
this side
surrounded on all four sides I believe
um I would certainly say it's not
surrounded on um
oh sorry the neighbors the neighbors uh
yeah so we're looking here right aren't
we rather that yes sorry um yeah okay so
we have a a road here the main buried to
something roads
um nothing across the road
um I've certainly been there
um but we have the yeah the applicant's
existing buildings here and um and to
the back so I would say okay to the
North and the the West existing
to the South
um
it's quite a way to the side and um I
think I measured uh approximately the
length of a uh a professional football
pitch um if that's helpful no I think I
think you've uh
pointed to date very clearly across the
road there isn't anything and to that
side it's further down on that
um site where they're proposed to put it
thank you okay
any uh no we've done that no other
questions so we'll move on then thank
you Mr Hopkins
um I'll now ask the applicant to speak
which is Mr Alan Valentine you sir also
have three minutes in which to address
the committee
and again I'd like to say thank you very
much because I know I saw your name come
up at um quarter past up has known this
morning so if you've stayed with us all
that time you've done extremely well
thank you thank you
can you hear me yes I'm here and see you
okay
thank you for allowing me let's say a
few words my name is Alan Valentine I'm
the founder and CE and sorry I'm the
founder at MD a first grade recycling
systems Limited first grade specialize
in design manufacturer of sorting
machinery for recycling industry we work
with recycling companies to improve
their processes and thereby reduce our
dependency on landfill and incineration
this is an exciting industry to work in
with great potential
we currently operate from three
buildings which are right next to the
proposed site these smaller buildings
are far from ideal and we have outgrown
them
we spend much of our time moving
material from one place to another to
make room to work
we have to do our assembly and testing
at Outdoors
since 2011 we have been looking for new
premises in the area to rent or buy
however we have not been able to find
anything but the space facilities and
access that we require
we consulted with the manufacturing
Technology Center in 2019 whose experts
help us to build up a plan for a new
workshop which would bring all our
operations together onto one clear span
roof
this will transform our business with
better material flow making our
manufacturing much more efficient and
safer
proposed Workshop will allow us to grow
and employ six to ten more people
both apprentices and skilled engineers
there have been objections to our
application on several grounds but I
believe we have taken considerable
action to alleviate these concerns now I
briefly like to outline some of these
there have been concerns about noise
we've had a detailed noise report
completed and Incorporated soundproofing
measures as recommended in essence we
will be doing the same operations we
currently do but inside a modern
in-stage building rather than an old
corny Insider building or Outdoors
they've accepted restricted working
hours of 7am to 6 P.M Monday to Friday
and we currently enjoy the freedom of
unlimited working hours
there have been concerns about light
pollution and yes we do want to have
lights in the yard so that we can load
and unload Vehicles safely in the winter
but these lights will only be used
during working hours and not left on at
night
the access to our current premises is
from the a134 on a busy section of a
busy fast section of the road with poor
exit visibility
proposed new access onto the a1141 will
be much safer
I'm passionate about making things and
employing young people this facility
will allow us to employ more young
people and train them to become highly
skilled engineers
I believe we can ensure to be doing much
more Manufacturing in this country
and I appeal to you to approve this
application
thank you thank you very much Mr
Valentine
um members is there any questions
of clarification
yes I've got councilor Owen followed by
councilor Jameson
hi yeah thank you for that um what what
would the hours of work be and how many
employees will you be
um employing
please
and the hours of work will be 7 A.M
until uh 4 30 or 5 they're restricted
from 7am till
6 p.m
five days a week and we currently
employed 12 people and the aim is to
increase that to 20 people over over a
number of years
thank you uh councilor Jameson yeah okay
thank you uh hello Mr Valentine
um just when you say you looked at other
sites it's a couple of questions firstly
when you say did you look at other sites
did that include the new business Parks
over the towards Ruffin
and the second question is also um what
sort of dialogue have you had with the
local community particularly residents
and Parish councils
yeah
yes
um we looked at others in the whole area
uh Ruffman industrial estate
um
that we've looked at and if you're
referring to the new uh business park
near rough from there uh the owners of
that wouldn't even talk to us they're
looking for absolutely massive uh new
buildings warehouses uh they wouldn't
speak to us and I spoke to uh other
small businesses and and they didn't get
a look in there either they're not
interested in something of this size
and local involvement
um
we haven't had a great deal of uh
I know I haven't discussed with the
parish council
um
well that's fine no thank you councilor
McLaren
thank you chair uh Mr Valentine I'm just
trying to
having watched the officer's plans
is that correct that
then where the new entrance is going to
be is there a bungalow opposite that yep
there is it and is that is that then uh
backed on is that where the haulage
business is at the other side of that
yes have you had any comments from those
people in The Bungalow uh the owner of
the Bunkley I was is in favor of our
application he's very agreeable
um I haven't done had any contact with
ux college
no but the Bungalow which is actually
got would have a potential industrial
estate opposite and one behind it uh
they've not made any comment no no thank
you very much
thank you councilman Karen councilor
Osborne followed by councilors
yeah thank you Mr Sharon um
thank you Mr Valentine um and
you're very uh your very patient way of
spending the morning and the afternoon
um the question is what what must What
machines are you actually using within
your um within your workspace uh in
terms of the levels of noise from them
uh it's mostly Welding and Fabrication
uh welders we um
yeah
um drilling uh solving welding painting
we subcontract our sheet metal work so
we have that done by other companies
locally and and brought into us
um so we don't get involved in the sheet
metal work uh it's it's a set it's yeah
assembly and sorry and then assembling
and wiring up of machines
so the majority of your any machines
that you would have had which carry the
most noise levels that are dealt with by
elsewhere
oh am I correcting that yeah there would
be sheet metal folders yeah yeah just
um this is sort of a bit of a What's
that question really for you but Hewitt
haulage I noticed um over the last uh
year and a bit of grown in space they've
um their their lorries and they're
they're are they to do with milk
milk uh deliveries and stuff like that
they're
they're liquid aren't they liquid
tankers
yeah not uh milk as far as I'm concerned
but certainly liquid tankers and there's
there's a lorry park there I believe as
well but that's increased in size isn't
it
yes so will that impact on on on your um
on your delivery and and
output from from your new place no no no
it doesn't affect us anyway thank you
thank you thank you
good afternoon and Mr Valentine
um I was interested to see that you will
um be able to employ
um more people and knowing the type of
thing you're doing will you be running
any programs for apprentices yes you
will yes certainly I'm very keen on on
having more apprentices and we've had uh
several apprentices through the years
and they they they're our best employees
in many ways
lovely thank you very much
thank you I've seen a councilor Parker
super job thanks sir
um Mr Valentine could you just just for
for context
um because I don't think it's material
particularly but um uh in our report uh
paragraph 2.31 on page 83 says on
completion of the development the
applicant would vacate in their current
premises
um so I'm just just for context What
will what what what do you see happening
with that are you going to dispose of
that or what what's what's the situation
there
well we're renting those premises at the
moment so uh it'll be up to the landlord
uh what to do with them
thank you thank you councilor Parker
counselor Busby
thank you
where are you putting the the new uh
building
is was there any reason why you couldn't
put it further back in the site so kind
of diagonally into the opposite corner
so it's away from the bungle that's what
I was thinking
uh um
we chose to put it where it is a couple
of reasons it's nearer to the entrance
which is which is uh convenient
um for security and it's further away
from crossway's house which is sort of
the most sensitive of the of the
neighbors
um The Bungalow is the opposite side of
the of the road
um and the the owner of the Bungalow is
you know is fully in favor of what we do
so we've tried to put some space between
us and Crossways house
um and be down there
okay okay thank you am I right and think
that if you if you moved away as
councilor Busby was suggesting pushed it
further but you'd be nearer to the
to the people that are objecting yes is
that correct you're some distance from
them at the moment and The Bungalow
that's the nearest to you across the
road is not object and is that correct
that's correct thank you
uh any other questions from um councilor
Parker
fine just just one more question um
chairman if I can um obviously metal
fabrication I mean it's quite a noisy
old business isn't it um metal
fabrication so could you could you just
confirm
um do you anticipate employing any new
processes over and above what you're
doing now or is it just going to be that
this extra capacity will give you more
capacity to do exactly what you're doing
can you just absolutely clarify that for
us please
it's more capacity
um yeah more capacity to
better and safer
so we've got no new processes uh planned
great thank you very much
I don't see any more hands up
councilor Jameson yeah yeah
so yeah can you um I have seen mention
that you're looking for 24 7.
um I was working is that true
originally uh our application was for 24
7 operation uh purely because that's
what we have at the moment in our
existing site and and consider reason
why we'd asked for anything different
um but with the uh various objections
and uh and uh about noise mainly uh we
conceded in the said okay we will accept
restricted errors because we rarely work
outside those errors
but we have a condition in there
allowing us to do so if we have a
customer as a breakdown who needs a part
in a hurry uh at very occasionally we'd
uh we'd work late to get that part made
for them
right so you can if you need to
basically it does the restrictions
saying yes up to 20 occasions a year a
year
um we're allowed to uh for for a
breakdown
for customers breakdown is important in
a hurry and that would be an emergency
yeah thank you
I don't think anyone would notice it
know if that happened it would be inside
the workshop with the doors closed you
know one two people staying late to to
finish something
um for a breakdown okay
councilor Busby
yeah how long was on the same grounds
really it remember it is a light
industry in the countryside rather than
on an industrial estate so
sounds can me make a lot more maybe more
of a nuisance to to neighbors I've got a
particular case in in chatishim where
there's a uh industrial site right next
to a house and it drives them round the
bend and yeah
the 20 occasions I guess from your view
it's reasonable
um if I was playing Devil's Advocate I
could say well that's every Sunday
between May and September which would
not be satisfactory if I had to live
close by I wouldn't want that noise
disturbing my piece on a on a Sunday
throughout the whole of the year
you know but you can see the our problem
we have to trust you
but we're putting
other people's trust in you not just our
own
very good point but I I don't know if
you can answer that at all sorry to
follow up on that yeah there's no I
don't know how we can monitor that I
don't know who could monitor that 20
occasions when do you start monitoring
it you know it could be
every night over three weeks or it could
be it's just almost impossible to gauge
I think I would assume councilor that's
been we can ask the officers in a moment
um that there would be some sort of
conditions that if if they got
objections they would then investigate
and perhaps enforce them to get involved
but
um I'll come to the case off after after
we've finished this part of it uh Mr
Valentine right sorry breakdowns are
really on a Sunday uh afternoon they're
mostly on the you know um on a Tuesday
night or a Friday night when someone
needs something done Harry
um and um we've had a detailed noise
assessment which has looked into all
this in in great detail uh we are in the
countryside but we're very right next to
a very busy roadway
um the a134 is a very busy road and uh
getting busier and so yes noise does
carry in the countryside uh but but this
isn't uh
this isn't a remote Countryside location
okay we want we want to help you want to
encourage businesses I appreciate that
but we we also have a responsibility to
look after the people who are in a less
fortunate position perhaps hmm
well said councilor Busby
um right there's no more uh hands gone
up yes please character oh sorry that is
okay uh sorry Council of hum
yep thank you just a quick question at
the moment your present premises you are
allowed to work 24 7. yes and your new
premises will be better insulated and in
respect of noise and means that you
won't be able to work 24 7. am I
absolutely right on that well yes yes
thank you
thank you all right I see no more hands
gone up
so
right thank you very much uh thank you
Mr Valentine
um I'll ask the officer
um Alex Scott if he can just comment
briefly on that point uh that if they
work outside hours and they can do it up
to 20 occasions how how are you sort of
monitoring that for want a better way of
putting it
uh World chairs I think there's said ad
in the report and there's certainly a um
a condition suggested at the end of the
report I think would cover this
um I'll discuss this uh briefly with the
Environmental Protection Officer and um
the suggestion we've come up with is um
no more than 20 occasions
um a year you know if I mean if this was
uh repetitive at a at a certain time um
as councilor Busby has alluded to um
there could be an issue but um what Mr
Valentine is saying I think that's
highly unlikely
um and we would monitor that um by way
of a register
um that that would form part of the
conditions keeping a register of the 20
occasions and there would also be a
requirement for uh our enforcement team
to be able to inspect that register
um if uh convenient notice was given and
that that really forms both the basis of
that overall condition and of course
we're not uh blind or closed off to
comments coming from the parish council
or members of the public that report
these fins to us
indeed if it comes in
um we may have to look at it yeah yeah
I'm sorry I think there's enough uh
enough in there to safeguard all this
uh well I think it's fair to just you
can comment yeah
it says the exceptions to the above
operation hours would only be permitted
in the event of emergencies
so only when there's emergencies so
we're not allowed to just uh open every
Sunday afternoon because uh because they
choose to yeah and I think what the case
after saying that you'd keep a register
of those emergencies and so that if
there were if it was challenged by
whatever course you would be able to
produce some evidence as to what was
happening yes yeah okay thank you very
much thank you then uh we'll move on
thank you very much Mr Valentine uh
County councilor
um is Robert Lindsay here and Kent um
yeah I'm good right sir sorry uh you
have uh three minutes all right I
thought it was five three minutes in
which to address the committee on County
issues only
sure
yeah so so just to explain for the
members of the committee on because I'm
a county councilor uh not the district
councilor for this area
um I uh I can only talk about the
highways and County matters on this
um but I have been approached by several
residents over this
um and um I noted the comments of the
parish council
um
I think I've got sort of uh three and
well three and a half points very
quickly to make on the highway side of
things
um one is that the the the highways um
the port itself says there's no
intensification
um they're using existing access
so not a problem but
um this you know they but your own
economics team says this is a
consolidation uh from several sites onto
one
um and it's a new site
um so this and and they're also talking
about expansion
from from day one going from 12 to 20
employees so uh I can't I it seems to me
like it is an intensification of the use
of the access there on the um the road
to Lavender
and the second point but just on
sustainable travel
um I'm applaud Mr Valentine for having
um you know doing we can for his
employees who want to cycle to work and
having a cycle shelter I just wonder if
the conditions that um
mentioned in the officer's Report with
15 meter radius curbs on the junction
The Junction that's
um dangerous is the the main road down
to Sudbury between Sudbury Berry and the
turn off down to Lebanon and um they're
talking about Big Radius curves there to
increase the visibility
um for I think particularly for hgvs but
I wonder if there's there's no there
doesn't seem to be any thought about
what would make that Junction safe for
Cyprus for people who might want to
cycle to that to work at that site even
um and huge having huge areas of
um curving uh curves doesn't isn't
necessarily make it safer for Cyprus
um so I'd appreciate if the committee
could could
um think about conditions to to to
improve the junction for cyclists
um the third point was
um and perhaps most important is the
lorries
um that this will generate now I know
the report says
um just one a week which sounds doesn't
sound like anything too bad at all
but
we no guarantee that this site will
forever remain with the current owners
and there's no in the realistic
restrictions as far as I can turn this I
missed it there's no restriction on the
numbers of lorries we're taking it at
face value it's just going to be one a
week
um you're talking about there that road
to Lebanon uh is very sensitive any
lawyers that go down there not only do
they go through cross green which is as
the planning officer showed was a it is
um it's kind of a conservation area it
also goes through lavender and kill um
Mr Lindsay I'm trying we have time
so I have to stop you there uh I I would
just like to to say that um
I I actually uh support a lot of what
you're saying on this particular
Junction and I did bring this up at
brief and that I think that Main Road
there uh is quite a dangerous spot a
dangerous Junction they're very fast
there and turn and right or left can be
quite lethal at times I think but I was
reminded that um that really is outside
the applicant's ownership but uh uh I
think you and I at County need to bring
more pressure to bear on the County
Council highways department on this
because that that is a bad junction and
I do take your pint of traffic then
entering into the Lebanon Road heavy
Goods vehicles
um that isn't the best of roads but um
certainly I consider that was a
dangerous Junction onto the a134
thank you uh members have you got any
questions to councilor Lindsay
uh councilor Busby
yeah just just one Robert an observation
really bearing in mind that they're
going to switch their exit onto the road
from the a134 to the a double one four
one
won't that make it safer rather than
pulling out onto a road where they're
going to be where people can be doing
60.
onto a part of a road where they're not
going to be doing more than 10 miles an
hour
uh
it was over the proposed um changes to
that Junction
um that they will be using I just I'm
not convinced those proposed changes but
if this is not Highway suggesting this
this is this is our planning department
suggesting this I'm not sure unless they
took into account
um pedestrians and cyclists then you
know I'm not not convinced it's going to
make it safer
I agree with what I agree with what
you're saying
it's just a yeah
thank you
um yes I've been blocking up the other
entrance and it actually doesn't that's
necessarily slow traffic down does it
um traffic coming along can stay at the
same speed if there's no turn until a
bit later but anyway that's a solid
issue
um any other comments members I can't
see any of our hands up so thank you
Council Lindsay
we'll move on
uh we're now moved to the ward member uh
which is councilor Clive after you so
have five minutes in which addressed the
committee and once again I'd like to
thank you for bearing with us it's been
a long day but over to you cancel arfi
thank you chairman um and and thank you
to Alex as well for a well presented
report
this has been um quite controversial
locally and I'm pleased the decision is
with committee
um so that it affords objectives
um the opportunity to to have their say
um I wanted to just mention a little bit
of of history in in the village of
cockfield it was about seven years ago
and before the Advent of neighborhood
plans that cockfield Parish Council
embarked on a on a village survey
those of you that have been on the
council for a while you probably know
that it was principally concerned with
housing needs and the identification of
those housing needs led to the proposals
that were approved and are currently
being built
um at what's known as Jeffrey's green
which is near crowbarca McKenzie on the
road from from this site if you like
down to lavignon
um but the parish council did a bit more
than that it wasn't just housing needs
they considered both potential housing
sites and employment sites and this site
was identified as one that might be
suitable for employment use with the
associated benefit of employment
opportunities within the village
there doesn't actually seem to be much
disagreement that the site might be
suitable for unemployment use
um the issue is um is the site suitable
for the use proposed
so the application as originally
submitted and I think the applicant has
mentioned some of these points
um was slightly different
um and I think was was not acceptable
mainly because it proposed as the
applicant said 24 7 365 operation
um
it presented a a range of other
potential impacts as well
those relates well they've been picked
up in the report actually by the parish
council in their responses but they
related mainly to residential amenity
impact impact on the landscape
maneuvering highways and so on but
they're in your report under the parish
council comments and I think the Paris
council did a very full and
comprehensive job when they when they
addressed those
um
one of the residential amenity impacts
that they addressed was the impact on
the property to the north Crossways and
you've heard from a representative of
the occupier of Crossways this afternoon
as is often the case for you on planning
committee it's a it's an issue of
balance
on the one hand you have to consider the
impact on residential and environmental
immunity and the landscape and does the
raft of conditions that are proposed in
your papers go far enough to mitigate
the potential impacts of the proposed
use
one of the questions that's often asked
in situations like this when you're
presented with with a raft of conditions
is if an application requires this many
conditions to control it is it
inherently unacceptable
but on the other hand you'll see the
policy and the nppf assessment at
paragraphs
3.0 to 3.5
and note that the application has the
full support of our economic development
team that's at paragraph 3.7 and I've
already mentioned the employment
opportunities that the proposal provides
that's not just for cockfield that's for
baber as a district as well
your planning officers at 12.1 to 12.6
suggest that the balance weighs in favor
of approval but the decision of course
is is yours
there are a few additional points which
I've I've noted down
um as a result of what I heard in the in
the public speaking
so
they're not all are they all planning
related I guess they are
um the first thing I ought to say is
that the applicant purchased the land
after a pre-application inquiry
um
you've heard that the applicant
currently operates out of buildings to
the to the north
and there is some history there of
alleged nuisance to the neighbor
I think that people have picked up that
this proposal could actually represent
an improvement in that situation being
that this proposal is further away than
the existing use
but that all depends on the ReUse of the
existing premises and I have great
sympathy with the occupier of Crossways
were he to be presented with a situation
where he had all of the current activity
that he's currently got behind his house
and this on top of it so I think you've
got to be a little bit careful
um because we we don't know what might
happen to the existing premises I'm very
sorry counselor I'm particularly sure
Cabinet member for planning but I'm
gonna have to stop you your time is up
and you have actually just gone over
slightly
so five minutes yeah really yep okay
thank you 25 to for 28 seconds now now
anyway uh sorry about that thank you for
um allowing me I wasn't looking forward
to cutting off the um the cabinet member
of clanon but there we are
um I'll see if there's any questions for
you
members uh councilor Busby you've got
one
I could ask
I actually like to know uh Clive
which way you would vote if you were on
the planning committee oh that I think's
a little bit unfair
he's planning
I'm going to say to councilor arfi as
I'd say to anybody in this situation
it's entirely up to you if you wish to
answer that I don't think you need to
thank you all right carry on
um any other hands up
no yes oh right
um that's councilor Hinton I think I
can't see your handbook please speak
just to uh just a quick one really uh Mr
chairman you'll remember uh what was
said as Clive will remember what it said
and I think we're probably I think none
other
um councilor Busby's in the same same
um
but when we had
when we had a certain planning office a
senior planning officer who used to say
that if you've got to put on more than
one condition it should be a refusal
uh can he remember that
um well I think you're referring to
quite a long time ago I think I actually
remember the application it referred to
as well
um
it was a lot more than one I think in
that particular case we had about 23
proposed conditions and the view that
committee took on that day was if we
need 23 conditions to control the use it
must be inherently unacceptable yeah I
do remember that but very well said
councilor arfi thank you councilor
Hinton any other uh councilor Parker
yep just a just a quick one um chairman
um councilor Arthur you'll see your
board member so the report is clear that
this is not within a neighborhood plan
area but is um are there any any moves
to look towards a neighborhood plan or
anything at all
um well that's a good question not
really relevant to the application
necessarily
um but um I think cockfield May well be
considering what I describe and Paul
Bryant describes as a a neighborhood
plan light
um the reason for that is that um
cockfield sort of did their work before
neighborhood plans as I mentioned they
did a lot of work seven years ago and
that was my point actually was sorry
chair that's why I asked the question is
yes and seven years that that's the
point um councilor Alfie that that um
needs assessment that you mentioned
um was seven years seven years ago
wasn't it so I just wondered if they'd
done anything with that information
since but no that's answered the
question that's fine thank you thank you
counselor Jameson
uh bro thanks yeah uh cancer off here I
just wanted to I think cockfield object
to the application if I read it
correctly and I just wondered if you
knew why they decided not to attend
today
um okay and I don't know whether that's
a question you need to answer because
you're asking him to get in the minds of
somebody that we don't know but it's
entirely up to him
well I can tell you that they did ask me
um for my advice on whether they should
attend or not
um the decision was theirs and it looks
as though they decided not to
I didn't tell you why they decided not
to attend in no no okay
thank you
uh I can see no other hands up no
they're all clear
okay I'll take that there's no more
questions to you counselor Alfie thank
you very much for your attendance thank
you chairman thank you uh we'll now move
on to the other award member for this
area which is counselor Margaret movie
you met him had five minutes also to
address the committee and again I will
thank you for your attendance and stay
in the course and
um I know once you start you're usually
hang in there so thank you very much
stop Mr chairman um thank you for the
opportunity to speak and I've enjoyed
watching the rain this afternoon as well
as this morning so thank you
and there's a compliment there somewhere
and they were accepted thank you it's a
rest
of the matter in question currently this
this open and undeveloped area of land
where there's planning application is
gives visibility at a well-known
difficult Junction for two roads the a
double one four one and the a134 a
Confluence of Highways upon which
several serious and fatal incidents have
occurred
this Junction does not have clear
visibility as when exiting the junction
from the a double one four one
visibility from the left is restricted
by a substantial dip in the road
here the speed limit is 60 miles per
hour
sadly on the a134 I was present as a
first driver who happened upon the
incident at one such fatality assisting
a lone police officer in the who was
innocently involved in the road traffic
collision
later I received and still retain
a letter of thanks for my assistance at
this tragic scene from a senior police
officer
I will not wave the letter in front of
you
or in front of this screen
as it is not necessary or appropriate
particularly in respect to the
individual involved and their family
I dare say you're getting to a point
here
um cancer Mabry but it does seem as
though you are wandering of course a
little bit but it's your time you're
using to continue thank you I therefore
suggest and someone else has got their
face on the screen now I therefore
suggest that this area is unsafe for
such further or even any large-scale
development
development currently along the a134
adds the difficult dangerous in
congesting situations on the highway in
my opinion despite what Suffolk County
Council highways may suggest
if Suffolk County Council High Council
High offices were to witness what I have
along this road I suggest they would
have a similar opinion to mine it is not
a suitable site
this site identified in this application
has not been formally identified for
economic use a Point I've checked with
an economic development officer Mr Hobbs
the parish council also object to this
application recognizing the application
will blight the entrance to the Village
along the
a0141 a village which has its roots in
agriculture and not recycling Machinery
Factory or any large-scale working
I failed to understand the sequential
record of the company looking for
another site in my opinion this is a
poor site for communications and a
better site would be closer to the A14
at berries and Edmonds for the ease of
access for hgvs
a site visit either in person or by
digital drone means could have and
should have been undertaken in my
opinion for the committee for members
and officers to witness the site
the home of Mr and Mrs Hannaford plus
those of others will be surrounded by
noisy Dusty possibly polluting
employment if this application is
approved Mr and Mrs Hannaford also have
a business which is housed in the
specially developed separate building
within the kirkletch of their property
baber District Council are aware of the
property as the building gained planning
permission in May 2014.
the business I mentioned supports and
encourages traditional crafts which are
in danger of being lost to the nation
the business is therefore of a quiet
nature and Demands a quiet environment
another Factory or large Machinery
manufacturing setting with its
Associated noise and pollution levels
will have a serious and detrimental
impact on another business the craft
business which I understand is against
nppf policies
I add if BDC through public consultation
with the parish council and residents
residents believe the site was suitable
for economic development which
personally I doubt to my previous
comments are more suitable application
would be for a single story Business
Park type of application which would be
environmentally and Visually more
acceptable for surrounding residents
including its immunity value the
entrance to the rural historic village
of cockfield and also a craft business
with high Heritage implications thank
you Mr chairman
thank you thank you very much councilor
Mabry I'll see if there's any questions
for you thank you uh members have anyone
got any questions for councilor Mabry
no there's no hands going up
so thank you very much thank you we'll
we'll move on
um members we're now going to debate
I'll now open that up so any who would
like to start
um
cancer councilor Parker
thank you chair yeah okay then well I'll
um I'll catch you in to start with um
Alex I wonder if we could have a look at
slide four please if you've if if you're
able to to put that on the screen for us
sorry indeed uh councilor Parker
I'll try to send that
are you able to see that yeah yeah
that's that's how I do
um so
um what struck me on here um Mr chairman
really is um
you know if we look at the site as a
whole my immediate thoughts in terms of
of location
are that this application it's not
particularly you know it's not in
Congress is it
um to to what is already there at the
moment
um so we've we've got a largely
agricultural Greenfield sites
surrounding uh uh you know a
semi-industrial area to the South
um and to the west and to to the north
um in fact
um so my my main point really on this
slide is is that it um it wouldn't be
out of place it
um and that that's that's my you know my
that's what hit me first of all when uh
when I looked at this I thought well
it's not uh it's not out of place where
it is so um that that's that's just the
start of a tent uh Mr chairman thank you
thank you uh
any other comments by members
no other hand's going up uh yeah
councilor Jameson followed by councilor
Barrett
uh just on the point that councilor
Parker made
um it's not much out of place in respect
to the other
uh building Brandy but it's in terms of
size
um it is a lot it does seem to me to be
a lot more substantial I mean you put
that building in there
um hashed area it does look
substantially bigger than the buildings
around it I think anyway
thank you
cancel a Barrett
thank you chair um I want to make a
point about uh jobs
um
and the proposal uh offers the creation
and retention of jobs
um and so I think we need to be aware
that the best option for jobs in an area
like ours a rural area is where uh
employers grow organically they don't
tend to move here and bring jobs from a
new employer because it's not the
obvious choice for a a a new setup
um so as we come out to the biggest
economic decline since the war
um we haven't even seen the half of it
yet because furlough is still still in
place
um we can't be dismissive about the
offer of secure
new jobs and retention of jobs and jobs
that offer
um jobs in a in a sector that is a
officer a really good career choice for
for young people
um so I um I do support this
um and I I Echo what um councilor Parker
has just said about the location and if
you look at the the adjacent businesses
that are are um not too far away so um
on the balance of um
uh be it that I I am going to be
supporting this I'm going to see what
other people
um come forward with thank you thank you
councilor
um Hinton
thank you Mr chairman
um
just to come back to what uh I was
discussing with yourself and councilor
Arthur earlier on
um there are 20 conditions on this
particular application so we're nearly
at that level of 23 that was mentioned
when we were talking about it
the building itself is
enormous we're talking about over a
thousand square meters of floor area
which is quite a sizable chunk of uh of
building so it's going to have an
extreme impact on the uh the local
environment visual environment if
nothing else
also it is just off the 134.
um
a few what 50 50 feet or something from
the junction
uh or down the down the the a1141 so
it's not any safer than direct access
from the 134 you've got to come off the
134 and go on to the 134 have you
negotiated uh access onto the 1141 when
it the both roads are de-restricted and
people might not coming right coming off
the 134 be expecting to see something
pulling out of that Junction just around
the bend from it so I'm a bit surprised
at highways um asking for visibility
splays for the entrance when in actual
fact it's traffic coming off the 134
that needs a visibility space because
they're going to come around the corner
and see something smack bang in front of
them with a little time to react and I
think the local members comment about
her personal
experience of how safe or unsafe that
road is is very pertinent
right thank you very much yes that whole
Junction area I consider to be
reasonably
um dangerous but anyway
um I have some simply there with you
councilor Busby
well yeah can I just take up the point
on that I think it's I said having been
there yesterday it's the end the new
entrance is quite a quite away from the
the crossroads The Junction and if you
try to go around a 90 degree turn any
more speed than 20 miles an hour you
probably deserve to have an accident so
I can't see that there'll be any problem
with people going into the side but
we're not when I've read this
I thought this is a marginal one
it could go either way which is why I
thought it was it was definitely worth a
site visit
on the one hand because I've had
experience of where we've got a an
industrial site next to a house in the
countryside
I know the problems that they can they
can create and it can blight people's
lives and I real have real sympathy with
them the trouble is that doesn't mean
that we should then turn down every
case that we come across we can't
you know paint every business in this
with the same brush we have to take them
on trust to some extent
as for the the road in a way ironically
might actually have an help on the road
Junction
because the more
businesses or the buildings there it
might make people think when they're
traveling down there that hang on
there's a junction ahead there's a it's
a built up site they might need to slow
down
perversely it might have that impact
I was concerned when I if the building
had been any closer to the corner I
think it would have been dangerous
because it would have uh impacted on the
visibility of people trying to get out
of the double one four one
I think it's far enough back
not to have that impact
um it is an existing business I think if
there were no businesses there at all
then I think we would say no because it
would have an impact but there are some
big buildings around that those
Junctions it's not it's not going to
appear seem out of place
I do sympathize with the The Bungalow
opposite
but if they've not objected
and they've got another big building
right behind them with the trucking
company then yeah I think
on the balance of everything I'm
inclined to say yes
thank you uh councilor McClellan
thank you chair
um actually Davis just said probably the
things I was going to comment on
um when we actually still hear them from
you
[Laughter]
um when I first looked when we first
looked at the application I mean you
were thinking about the the
um neighbors sort of in amongst
industry but when you look at the
sighting of all the other businesses
then I would agree with Dave that
actually this is just an added thing in
a in an area where there already is
Light Industry and therefore I will be
supporting it thank you councilor
Osborne
yeah thank you thank you Mr chairman
yeah I tend to um I tend to agree with
uh what's been said by councilor Parker
and and that of Margaret uh um Mary
McLaren and obviously I I do understand
the position of uh the roads thing that
um Council Mabry was talking about
however um on that aspect alone you have
got that um
um tanker business just up the road
which is increased in in volume from
from my experience of going past it
several times and uh you know you have
got okay you're not coming out from a a
minor Road onto onto an a road but you
are coming out of a business uh with
with large Vehicles which uh we're
actually going is going to go either
left or right so you're going to go
across the traffic at one point or
you're going to have to go with the
traffic on the other which is exactly
the same as that other thing coming
coming from a second Point coming from a
uh an industrial engineering background
I I can see the benefit of of sheet
metal work and Welding Etc that they do
and that is a skilled job they are
skilled jobs there's no doubt about it
so I'm very pleased that we're going to
see some skilled jobs coming into that
area and incidentally I would think that
uh young young people that are coming
into and not knowing what to do coming
from cockfield they would probably
um be able to have a job right near them
uh which is a good idea I mean I can
remember going to a forum years ago and
no doubt some of the members were there
as well when they talked about how
employment in in local areas and
parishes were all around the same place
so you know you had a parish which had
industry in there in their backyard back
back Garden basically but that's all
moved on because of uh you know the way
that Industries go and industries are
failing I I mean the firms that I have
worked for in fact one went uh about
three weeks ago so I do understand that
skilled workers are not there anymore
and not I for one will be supporting
anything that brings back skilled
industrial Works uh within the district
thank you
plum thank you chair I personally will
support this I think we should be
encouraging companies such as this who
are success and wish to expand and wish
to create more jobs coming from the
neighboring Ward I'm well aware of what
the a134 is and how important it is but
it is a site where they are quite
removed from there in terms of then are
pulling directly onto it and so I
personally would like to propose that we
accept the officers recommendation thank
you thank you very much for that I'm
gonna ask for a second
do I have a second from anybody
well I will second it then there's no
hands come forward so I I would be happy
to second that um councilor Plum
um members do you wish to speak to it
uh counselor Jameson
um yeah if this is going to be approved
is it worth having another condition to
I mean if HGB turn left out of this um
uh property they head towards Lebanon we
just got weight restrictions and um
obviously there's Cooks green and
then that way so he's there is it
possible just to make sure hgb's turn
right towards the a134 rather than
getting stuck in Lebanon
um we uh we've heard a highway and I
don't think they see any problems but
I'll asked Alex Scott to comment on that
point uh but I would just like to say
that I'm always reluctant to keep adding
on more conditions I'm not saying this
isn't one that could be quite important
it may be
um but if the highways have already
um looked at this and disregarded that I
don't think there's much pine to add in
any more conditions but anyway Alex can
you help out here okay so officer
um yes what I mean from what I've heard
from highways
um
I I think it's a question of
enforceability really chair you know how
would you enforce something like that
um you know from what the applicant has
said it's not the intention to um go
towards lavenum or through cross screen
anyway
um I take the point that occasionally
lorries may miss the access and
um you know there's a question of what
what to do when you uh when you um come
across cross green and there have been
some concerns raised about Laurie's
turning around in Cross green
um
yeah I think it's a question of
enforceability and if things like that
happen it's it's a mistake anyway yeah
so um yeah that would be my view I see
Mark's appeared yeah so I just saw him
Mark have you anything to add to that
I've been cross-bodied with Sam Harvey
and unfortunately she's gone now but um
I mean she's saying generally it's it's
it's a small site where you wouldn't ask
for highways improvements anyway apart
from the access to the property itself
um they certainly didn't request any
signage and you're asking for a sign on
the highway the highway is going to give
us permission to do it anyway so I I
don't see any way of going forward with
that idea to be honest
so they're the points I brought up at
brief and so let's answer that thank you
very much uh councilor Busby well just
to say it's an existing business if they
if they're going down that beat uh the
Double one four one now then I guess
they'll continue if they're not going
down it then why should they suddenly
start to do it when they move sites uh
okay
um I can't see any more hands up
so if there isn't then I shall go to the
uh counselor Osborne
yeah thank you um thank you Mr chairman
yeah I tend to agree there with with
David because
um we're looking at what they call HUV
vehicles coming onto that site but as
David has already alluded to if if
they're going towards Lebanon those
Vehicles won't be that size that they
cannot be uh cannot use that that type
of Road and incidentally I would think
that most bridges that uh were in the EU
situation years ago have been
strengthened to take to take heavier
load so you know we have that in Sudbury
and that's what's caused the
hgv is coming into the middle of Sudbury
thank you very much that's a simple
answer that can start I was born but I
don't think this is the place to mention
it
um any other comments members
nope there's no more hands gone up right
that I'm gonna ask
um the governor's officer uh Robert
Carmichael uh to take us through to the
voting process because it has been
proposed and seconded that we accept the
officer's recommendation
thank you chair
um if mems could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
on the agenda for today
and if you go on the subsection for
voting and attendance the vote is now in
progress under the light blue line you
may need to scroll down as it will be at
the bottom of the list
I'm trying to log in again server let me
know
all right
agenda oh God got a bit further this
time but whatever that will let me write
the way through go on to the Plus
around to attendance and floating
yes we've got there I don't know what
you've done this time Robert but you
seem to be making it working for me
[Music]
all right I'm about to vote now
um
has it gone through Robert
yes Jim that's now overall votes are now
coming through so why did it first back
into life for me when it wouldn't do it
a couple of times ago right thank you I
I don't know
the outcome of the vote um was that it
was carried by eight votes to two with
one abstention
okay so that is Carrie thank you very
much
uh right it just seem to have lost me
close again because I've got that up
let's get back to it
um just bear with me I believe we're at
the end of it
no so
um members will come to the end of
today's session
so I'd like to thank you all very much
for a long day and afternoon and your
patience and all those that have been
involved and to our officers who have
taken us through it today thank you all
very much and now I'd like to declare
the meeting closed thank you